rob merci monsieur rapporteur madame la
ministre au but
alors en fait votre amendement vise à
modifier le périmètre des lignes
éligibles au transfert de propriété et a
conditionné le transfert de certaines
catégories de ligne au maintien de
services ferroviaires de transport de
voyageurs en effet il conduirait à
exclure du champ des lignes
transférables des lignes actuellement
fermée aux circulations ferroviaires
ainsi que les lignes dites capillaire
fret utilisé uniquement pour le
transport de marchandises par ailleurs
en imposant le maintien de solutions de
services de transport ferroviaire de
personnes de type ferroviaire lourd il
priverait les régions de la possibilité
de mettre en place les solutions de
transport les plus adaptées aux besoins
des territoires concernés et d'aménager
aussi des voies vertes enfin les shows
des états de politiques qui sont
demandées d'une manière générale madame
la ministre je mais on voit l'amendement
720 qui a donc reçu deux avis
défavorables qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée et
le 1322 avec les deux avis défavorables
aux sikhs et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté deux
amendements identiques toujours faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 721
messieurs mari merci madame la
présidente
au delà des besoins de la politique
nationale de transport et des besoins de
la défense
il s'agit de garantir que le transfert
de ligne permettra de contribuer à la
transition écologique en améliorant le
bilan environnemental de l'exploitation
antérieures ou à tout le moins à ne pas
le détériorer
cet événement cet amendement s'inscrit
dans la nécessité de prendre en compte
l'impératif écologique dans tous les
actes de la vie publique et notamment en
matière de transports un secteur
particulièrement contributeurs à
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre
de plus si comme le prévoit la loi
d'orientation des mobilités le transfert
de ligne ferroviaire aux régions
permet de renforcer l'offre ferroviaire
ou d'en garantir la pérennité c'est un
pacte devra nécessairement être positif
merci scénarii monsieur fernique
président le ministre cet amendement
donc travailler toujours avec la cfdt
vise à s'assurer que l'impact écologique
du projet lié aux transferts la ligne de
chemin de fer soit positif en clair le
résultat doit améliorer le bilan
environnemental de l'exploitation
antérieures ou en tout cas ne pas le
dégrader il s'agit ici de mettre la
transition écologique au coeur de
l'action publique particulièrement dans
le domaine des transports
particulièrement déterminant on le sait
je vous remercie
avis de la commission je ne suis pas
favorable au fait de conditionner le
transfert de propriété des lignes à la
prise en compte de l'impact
environnemental du transfert pour deux
raisons tout d'abord comme le souligne
d'ailleurs l'objet des amendements
l'objectif environnemental est inhérent
aux transferts en sauvant les petites
lignes nous allons favoriser le report
modal ensuite en pratique je m'interroge
sur la possibilité d'apprécier l'impact
environnemental de chaque transfert au
moment de demander le transfert de
propriété les régions n'auront pas
nécessairement un projet détaillé sur
l'avenir de ces lignes je rappelle
également que les petites lignes
ferroviaires correspondent à un réseau
peut électrifier est donc en l'état peu
écologique en comparaison du reste du
réseau national
il me semble donc que cet ajout risque
de fragiliser la mise en oeuvre du
transfert
l'avis est défavorable aux deux
amendements
je vous remercie monsieur rapportèrent
madame la ministre
oui évidemment la préoccupation
de l'objectif de transition écologique
est partagé par tout le monde
néanmoins votre amendement conduirait à
analyser l'impact d'un projet transport
ferroviaire préalablement au transfert
de gestion de la petite ligne free
preneur ce qui alourdirait les
procédures de transfert alors même que
la collectivité intéressée pourrait
porter un projet alternatif nous adapter
aux besoins les territoires desservis
tels que des bus à haut niveau de
service en site propre ou encore des
solutions du type train très léger il
semble donc préférable de ne pas réduire
le champ de possibilités offertes aux
bénéficiaires lors des transferts merci
madame la ministre je mets aux voix ces
deux amendements identiques qui ont reçu
un avis défavorable qui est pour et qui
est contre cette cei ne sont pas
adoptées je me vois l'article 9 qui pour
au pardon explications de vote
monsieur mari merci madame la présidente
juste nous allons voter l'article
puisque dans sa philosophie générale
nous exprimerons notre part nous avons
obtenu un certain nombre de garanties de
la part de la ministre sur les droits
des salariés dans le cadre du transfert
nous en avons pris acte ils seront
d'ailleurs au procès verbal ce qui
permettra de rassurer les partenaires
sociaux ceci étant les propos temps du
rapporteur que de la ministre sur
l'organisation de ces transferts et
leur vocation définitif nous laisse
quelques inquiétudes quant à la
pérennité des petites lignes
et quant à l'objectif environnemental
donc nous resterons avec sa main
vigilants quant à la mise en oeuvre de
ce dispositif
merci merci chers collègues je mets aux
voix l'article 9 qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté un
additionnel après l'article 9 le 1233
rectifié bis
monsieur karoutchi qui le présente
monsieur le président mais la présidente
madame la ministre
combien de temps on va considérer que ce
que dit l'europe où ce que nous avons
tous dit d'ailleurs n'a aucun sens on a
parlé d' ouverture à la concurrence pour
certains réseaux franciliens notamment
ceux de la ratp
je m'en souviens j'étais membre du
conseil d'administration du stif
c'était pendant le gouvernement jospin
ya vingt ans vingt ans et puis depuis 20
ans et quels que soient les
gouvernements gauche droite
tous les cinq ans on reporte on trouve
des moyens de faire en sorte de dire oh
la la
un peu plus tard on a adopté au stif
devenu ensuite ile-de-france mobilité
des règlements notamment sur la
sécurisation des droits
évidemment des agents de la ratp sur la
répartition sur le transfert de
compétences sur les équilibres et tous
les cinq crimes actualise pas ce qui se
passe rien mais rien est depuis 20 ans
ça continue désespérément ce qui fait
que alors la direction de la ratp
s'empresse de dire oh bah tant mieux
comme ça hein on n'a pas à mettre les
choses au point en place les syndicats
disent bah tant mieux comme ça ça change
rien
mais le résultat c'est qu'en réalité la
ratp ne fait pas les choix décisif ni
l'investissement ni le fonctionnement
sur la suite parce que on ne sait pas
comment se passera l'ouverture à la
concurrence
un jour et donc mon amendement est très
simple finissons-en on n'a aucun élément
technique de retour nécessaire
aucun l'entreprise comme la région sont
parfaitement prêt prête pour que on
ouvre à la concurrence
alors je fais une folie je dis plutôt
que de dire 2039
je vous imaginez si on avait pu honorer
me 2099 comme ça on sera tous morts et
donc les suivants se débrouille mai au
jeudi 2029 c'est à dire 8 en 8 ans pour
faire quelque chose qui est prévu qu'ils
étaient prévus pour la première fois il
ya 25 ans donc ça va il faut 35 ans pour
juste ouvrir à la concurrence
certains réseaux ratp et je suis pas sûr
de l'emporter
merci monsieur le rapporteur avis de la
commission
la loi 2009-10 509 de 2003 relative à
l'organisation et à la régulation des
transports ferroviaires dites lois rtf à
fixer les échéances spécifique pour
l'ouverture à la concurrence des
services réguliers de transport guidé un
région ile de france ainsi que pour les
service régulier de transport routier ne
transporte pas tramways et de transports
scolaires
compte tenu de l'ampleur des services
ferroviaires considéré et du nombre
d'usagers de législateur avait jugé
appropriée de prévoir une ouverture à la
concurrence progressive en commençant
par les 10 les moins fréquentés comme
les lignes alger
n par exemple s'agissant des lignes de
rer a et b gérée par ile-de-france
mobilité qui sont les services les plus
empruntées du réseau leur ouverture à la
concurrence devait avoir effectivement
lieu en 2039 soit au même moment que
pour les services exploités par la ratp
le présent amendement vise à avancer
cette date limite de 10 ans pour la
fixer à 2029 je suis sensible aux
arguments selon lesquels la
diversification des opérateurs dès 2030
permettra ile-de-france mobilité de
sélectionner des offres plus adaptées
aux besoins et de favoriser une qualité
de service plus optimales pour les
usagers par ailleurs l'avancement de ces
date correspond à une demande
d'ile-de-france mobilité madame valérie
pécresse talent elle n'avait d'ailleurs
pas manqué de le rappeler lorsqu'elle a
été entendue par notre commission
au mois de février dernier toutefois je
souhaite émettre une réserve les dates
délais d'examen qui sont les nôtres ne
m'ont pas permis d'entendre des parties
prenantes notamment les opérateurs et
d'évaluer pleinement les répercussions
de cette proposition
le processus d'ouverture à la
concurrence est déjà lancée sur de
nombreuses lignes modifier le plan de
riom cours de route risque dont de
déstabiliser les travaux qui ont été
lancés de plus les dates d'ouverture à
la concurrence qui avait été arrêté en
2009 n'ont pas ou alors de manière très
limitée été remise en cause par le
législateur dans l'ordre d'examen de la
loi portant nouveau pacte ferroviaire
puis de là l'homme en 2018 et 2019
ces éléments plaident pour la prudence
et je donnerai donc un avis de sagesse
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre à vis du gouvernement
nous sommes sur la même position que le
rapporteur et à ceci près que moi je
donnerai plus tôt une demande de retrait
parce que je pense qu'il que c'est
quelque chose qui se travaille mais je
comprends bien même si de réduire de 4 à
10 ans c'est quand même à temps très
comment dire un raccourci important et
comme l'a dit à l'instant le rapporteur
guéret il y a déjà des lignes ouvertes à
la concurrence
sur la décennie à venir et qu'il faut
aussi avoir le temps que tout cela se
passe dans les meilleures conditions
si même la ministre alors mesdames sens
large c'est pour explication de vote
pris le président karoutchi merci madame
la présidente je pense que nos débats au
cours de cette séance montre à quel
point il est plus que temps de
dépoussiérer ce qui est en place
que ce soit pour les réseaux routiers
les réseaux ferroviaires
il y a vraiment du travail de
simplification et la simplification sera
d'autant plus efficace qu'on s'en
donnera les moyens
si aujourd'hui en séance ont décidé de
raccourcir ce délai cela veut dire que
l'on sera tenue quelque part de
l'honorer et je pense qu'il faut être
vraiment trop actif et donner les moyens
aux collectivités qui sont actives et
bien d'agir si sir collègues se 46
madame la ministre
comment vous dire dire il faut réfléchir
ça fait 25 ans qu'on réfléchisse 1
alors ça ça on va être mûr de mur je
dirais même que c'est au delà de mur
parce que en vrai qu'est ce qui se passe
dans la réalité c'est que chacun renvoie
à 10 ans voire 20 ans parce que comme ça
le gouvernement en place et tranquille
c'est pas lui qui assume d'ailleurs les
instances européennes s'étonne chaque
fois mais après tout ça ça convient pas
à tout le monde c'est à dire ça comme ça
tout le monde ça ne permet pas à la ratp
de prendre de fait
véritable engagement d'avenir parce que
on sait bien qu'à un moment faudra le
faire tout est opérationnel madame la
ministre par don de vous dire depuis 25
ans quand même la sécurisation des
droits des travailleurs la répartition
des charges les attributaires les
délégataires tout a été travaillé 10 x
15 x 20 x toujours au même toi qui va
décider d'une date et chaque vague on
décide d'une dette
on la met à 20 ans dix ans comme ça
entre temps il va se passer au moins
trois renouvellements sénatoriaux et 3
assemblée nationale ce qui fait que les
suivants se débrouilleront et assumons
ce qui se passe à un moment ça suffit
quoi il faut que la ratp puis je dire
franchement si j'avais dit ouverture à
dans deux ans je peux comprendre qu'on
dit oh là là attention mais dans huit
ans vous imaginez pour des dossiers
qu'ils sont déjà largement travail et
qui ne demande qu'à être actualisée huit
ans je sais bien qu'en france il faut du
temps pour tout enfin là c'est du temps
à perdre donc moi je souhaite
franchement qu'on avance et qu'on fixe
des règles un peu plus précises
maintenant
merci monsieur le président je vais donc
mettre aux voix l'amendement 1233
rectifié qu'a reçu une sagesse de la
commission une demande de retrait du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre
au compte- nom qui s'abstient il est
adopté
le 1669 rectifié bizarre mais madame la
ministre c'est un amendement de notre
collègue philippe tabarot qui est un
porteur de dés des mobilités dans le cas
de la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et développement durable
dans le cas de l'ouverture effective de
la concurrence des ter il serait utile
et pragmatique d'inclure un principe de
réalité pour les région autorité
organisatrice de mobilité rappelons
qu'entre le début d'une procédure
d'appel d'offres et le démarrage du
contrat il s'écoule au minimum 4 ans il
peut y avoir dans ce délai des
évolutions importantes comme par exemple
la réouverture d'une ligne ferroviaire
aussi il propose de compléter l'article
du code des transports pour permettre la
prise en compte des trajectoires
d'évolution des effectifs dans la
détermination du nombre d'effectifs à
transférer en cas de changement
l'attributaire d'un contrat de service
public de transport ferroviaire de
voyageurs
merci cher collègue reporter l'ouverture
à la concurrence des lignes de ter
permet région d'avoir recours aux
services de la sncf opérateurs
historiques ou de prestataires privés
pour la réalisation des services de
transport de voyageurs dans ce cadre est
prévue la conclusion d'un contrat de
service public de transport ferroviaire
de voyageurs entre l'autorité
organisatrice de transport et
l'attributaire en cas de changement
d'attributaires l'article 2121 20 du
code des transports prévoit le transfert
des contrats de travail en cours depuis
au moins six mois à la date de
notification de l'attribution l'article
l2121 22 précise les modalités de
détermination des effectifs transférable
il est prévu que le nombre de salariés
dont le contrat se poursuit auprès du
nouvel attribut terre est fixée d'un
commun accord entre l'om et le cédant et
qu'il est calculée à partir de
l'équivalent en emploi à temps plein
travaillés par catégories d'emploi des
salariés concourant directement ou
indirectement
à l'exploitation du service concerné or
les procédures de changement
d'attributaires sont souvent longues
entre le moment où les au tpa
transférées sont arrêtés et le
changement d'attributaires les effectifs
employés peuvent évoluer
substantiellement cet amendement qui
propose la prise en compte non pas d'une
photographie des effectifs mais de leur
trajectoire prévisionnelle me semble
donc pertinent toutefois compte tenu des
effectifs importants qui peuvent être en
jeu il me semblerait utile d'encadrer
davantage les choses par exemple en
précisant la manière dont cette
trajectoire prévisionnelle sera établi
et dont elle sera prise en compte dans
le calcul des au tpa transférer madame
la ministre
votre avis sur le sujet m'intéresse nous
pourrions peut-être préciser les choses
dans le cadre de la navette je donne
donc un avis de sagesse merci monsieur
le rapporteur madame la ministre
alors votre amendement vise à ce que
soit pris en compte les évolutions
prévisibles de l'organisation de la sncf
dans le cadre de l'ouverture à la
concurrence du transport ferroviaire de
voyageurs est cependant nécessaire de
tenir compte d'une part de la nécessité
de prévert de préserver l'égalité de
traitement des candidats au regard des
règles de la commande publique et
d'autre part des conséquences
économiques et sociales du calcul de ce
nombre d'emplois déterminant pour les
entreprises
et comme pour les salariés au moment du
changement de effectifs d'attributaires
à ce titre là justement que vous
proposez ne pourrait s'expliquer que
pour les procédures qui n'ont pas encore
été initiée par les autorités
organisatrices qu au risque dans le cas
contraire d'aboutir à un vice de forme
les candidats n'ayant pas été informé en
amont des règles applicables
par ailleurs il me paraît nécessaire
d'encadrer davantage les modalités selon
laquelle est
elle part dont le nombre d'emplois
transférer pourrait tenir compte des
évolutions prévisibles de l'organisation
de la sncf de manière à refléter au
mieux le nombre de salariés concernés au
moment du transfert notamment ces
évolutions quoique prévisionnel doivent
être suffisamment certaine pour ne pas
créer un nouvel à nouveau décalage entre
le nombre d'emploi fixé en amont et le
nombre effectif de salariés qui seront
transformés au moment du changement
effectif d'attributaires bref je crois
que je vais vous demander de retirer
votre amendement
merci madame la ministre monsieur la
mini pour explication de vote
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues donc concernant
cet amendement présent à l'initiative de
notre collègue philippe tabarot qui
connaît très très bien le domaine
ferroviaire et sur lequel j'y rêve sont
posé des problèmes et aussi des
inquiétudes parce que j'irai on parle
des désorganisations de de transport les
les marchés qui seront passés et serait
l'opérateur historique et la sncf
bon après l'ouverture à la concurrence
un saut avec la loi sur le pacte
ferroviaire la loi sur les mobilités
alors de l'autre côté
priorité aux moyens humains c'est ce que
aussi souvent c'est très important et on
peut aussi mesurer l'inquiétude ou les
inquiétudes aussi des des personnels du
monde cheminot est aussi l'heureux leur
évolution et bombes et après la
complexité de ces procédures
un champ large est tout à leur disait
faut simplifier les choses
bon c'est sûr que si vos là il ya la
complexité juridique est aussi mais
j'aurais quand même les inquiétudes
parce que les moyens humains
j'irai sur en particulier sur les lignes
secondaires
le rapporteur indiqué qu'il ya beaucoup
de ligne à voie unique
la plupart qui sont non électrifiées et
aussi avec des passages à niveau
notamment et c'est vrai que il ya aussi
la notion de sécurité à prendre en
compte et c'est vrai que malheureusement
la plupart des gars aussi sont fermées
donc remplacer les moyens humains port
j'irai des distributeurs autres sais
c'est pas forcément
je le partage pas du tout donc j'insiste
aussi beaucoup sur les moyens humains et
sur les inquiétudes à prendre en compte
est aussi ces procédures qui sont
longues complexes mais sur lequel creux
en faisant aussi confiance donc je
suivrai bien entendu aussi eu la vie
dure à porter merci monsieur laménie
s'il n'ya plus la parole non c'est juste
je maintiendrai en tous les cas
l'amendement de notre collègue tabarot
et un rapporteur de nouveau les
transports dans la course au large du
territoire il n'a pas fait ça à la
légère
alors je mets aux voileux 1669 rectifié
bis qui a reçu une sagesse de la
commission une demande de retrait du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté un
additionnel après l'article 9 225 madame
assassi le défend merci madame la
présidente
dans un discours en date du 14 juillet
dernier le président de la république a
abordé la question des petites lignes
ferroviaires et qui devait selon lui
faire l'objet d'un effort particulier
aujourd'hui la situation de celles y
reste extrêmement précaire comme le
souligne le rapport
philizot les lignes de desserte fine du
territoire souvent appelée petite ligne
catégorie u i ses sept à neuf dans le
classement de l'union internationale des
chemins de fer représente pourtant
environ un tiers du réseau ferroviaire
accueillant des voyageurs soit 9000 135
km sur un total de 28 mille trois cent
soixante quatre kilomètres et l accueil
de 10 7% du trafic des trains régionaux
dont notre amendement vise en fait à
inclure dans les objectifs de la
stratégie la programmation financière et
opérationnelle des investissements de
l'état dans les systèmes de transport de
transport le renforcement et
l'amélioration des lignes classé us et
sept à dix et neuf correspondant
généralement au réseau
régionales alors il faut dire que les
besoins sont quand même relativement
important et sont estimés par icf réseau
à 7,6 milliards d'euros jusqu'en 2028
dont 6,4 milliards restants tag a engagé
à partir de 2020 les régions ne peuvent
engager ses investissements et nous
pensons qu'il est de la responsabilité
de l'état de permettre la poursuite de
ces lignes de vie pour nos concitoyens y
compris au moyen des contrats de plan
nous considérons par conséquent que
l'état doit apporter des réponses
financières pertinentes aux
collectivités territoriales pour
l'entretien de ces lits sous peine est
bien de les voir disparaître au profit
d'alternative je dirais écologiquement
peu pertinente jour merci merci madame
est celle ci messieurs le rapporteur
j'émets un avis défavorable à cet
amendement pour deux raisons ces lignes
elles seront transférées région
moyennant des compensations financières
de la part de sncf réseau les besoins de
financement auxquels feront face les
régions seront donc en principe couvert
il n'est pas cohérent de maintenir ce
système de financement partagé alors que
les lignes reviendront tirman région la
deuxième
l'objectif qui sous-tend cet amendement
est celui du maintien de l'ensemble des
petites îles ferroviaire hui ses sept à
neuf qui sont les moins fréquentées du
réseau mais région ne souhaiteront
peut-être pas maintenir l'ensemble de
ses lignes
il faut leur laisser l'autonomie
nécessaire pour décider de leur sort
or prévoir un subventionnement des cff
réseau pourrait induire une pression sur
les régions en faveur du maintien des
lignes cela n'est pas cohérent avec
l'esprit du transfert merci monsieur
rapporteur madame la ministre mais ma
vie c'est ma vie je précise que l'état
mobilise d'ores et déjà 500 millions
pour les investissements de remise en
état des lignes de desserte fine du
territoire dont d'ailleurs 300 millions
du plan de relance
si je mets on voit l'amendement 225 a
reçu deux avis défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre qui et contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté alors
après l'article 9 le 1406 et c'est
madame la ministre qu'il défend au nom
du gouvernement
oui merci madame la présidente l'article
4 de la loi d'orientation des mobilités
prévoit la possibilité de créer des
établissements publics locaux ayant pour
mission le financement sur un périmètre
géographique déterminée d'un ensemble
cohérent d'infrastructures de transport
terrestre dont la réalisation représente
un coût prévisionnel excédents un
milliard d'euros hors taxes c'était ces
établissements peuvent également avoir
pour mission de concevoir et exploiter
ces infrastructures ou de mettre en
place des services complémentaires ou
connexes à ses infrastructures
cette disposition a été adoptée pour
faciliter l'association des
collectivités concernées par des projets
à leur conception et à leur financement
cet article vise donc à préciser et à
élargir la possibilité de création de
tels établissements publics locaux
il étend ainsi cette possibilité aux
grands projets phase et afin que leurs
différentes composantes piste est
intégré dans l'établissement public
local le cas échéant au fur et à mesure
des arbitrages les concernant cela
pourrait être par exemple
cela pourrait par exemple pardon
concernés le projet de ligne nouvelle
provence côte d'azur prévue en quatre
phases
et pour lequel le gouvernement a annoncé
son financement au titre des deux
premières phrases phase pardon il y a
quelques semaines
il vise également à ela
la possibilité de créer de tels
établissements publics locaux pour les
projets ayant fait l'objet d'une
décision du ministre chargé des
transports de procéder aux démarches
pour l'ouverture de l'enquêté publique
alors que la loi d'orientation des
mobilités ne réserve cette possibilité
qu'au projet ayant fait l'objet d'une
déclaration d'utilité publique d'une
déclaration de projet ou d'une décision
de l'autorité administrative d'engager
l'enquète public et d'une
contre-expertise à l'évaluation socio
économique
voilà merci madame la ministre ali de la
commission mais seul rapporte
je suis favorable à cet amendement qui
permettra de faciliter la mise en oeuvre
de projets d'infrastructures transport
terrestre au niveau local dont la
réalisation représente un coût élevé
supérieur à un milliard d'euros
nous avions adopté ce dispositif dans le
cadre de la l'homme il s'agit ici de
l'approfondir pour prendre en compte le
cas des grands projets phase est bon
fait effectivement de temps parti lalit
ferrovia nouvelle provence côte d'azur
prévue en quatre phases qui vise à
désaturer les deux ferroviaire de
marseille toulon et nice et améliorer
les liaisons ferroviaires entre ces
métropoles pour faciliter les
déplacements quotidiens cette
proposition va dans le sens du
renforcement des moyens à disposition
des collectivités territoriales pour
mettre en oeuvre et financer les grands
projets d'infrastructures merci monsieur
le rapporteur
je mets au voile amendement 1406 de
gouvernement qui a un avis favorable de
la commission qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'appelait il est adopté
un amendement 722 rectifié défendu par
l'onem filleul oui madame la présidente
madame la ministre
cet amendement doit permettre aux
régions enfin voudrais pas me voudrait
donner la possibilité aux régions qui le
souhaitent expérimenter le transport
autonome sur rail en zones peu denses en
réutilisant et réaménagements
réaménagement des lignes de chemin de
fer fermé avec pour objectif la
recherche de la baisse des coûts
énergétiques financiers et
environnementaux tout en améliorant la
qualité de service aux usagers pour
concurrencer fx efficacement lusage de
la voiture mon collègue monsieur jacques
un s'appuie sur l'exemple de la région
grand est qui soutient depuis 2010 est
un projet de transport autonome sur rail
innovants il a été développé par les
universités les labos les laboratoires
de recherche et ce projet conduit
aujourd'hui un nouveau paradigme de
déplacement basé sur une flottille de
petits véhicules autonomes sur rail
hyper légers véhicules pour une ou deux
personnes une personne ou une personne à
mobilité réduite ou une personne et son
vélo qui concurrencent efficacement
l'usagé de la voiture individuelle
merci madame fille élevée sur un porteur
à vittel commission le transport
autonome sera imaginée il ya seulement
quatre ans de cela par des élèves
ingénieurs de meurthe et moselle à
travers le projet urban loupe présente
de nombreux atouts en termes de sobriété
énergétique de complémentarité avec les
autres moyens de transport et même
d'accessibilité aux personnes à mobilité
réduite cette solution innovante me
semble aussi intéressante au regard
d'objectifs de développement et de mise
en valeur des zones rurales
je suis tout à fait favorable au fait de
laisser aux régions qui le souhaitent la
possibilité d'expérimenter ce type de
projet j'ai quelques réserves sur le
délai de deux ans qui est proposé les
lignes ferroviaires concernés vont
nécessité d'importants travaux cette
durée me semble courte pour conduire des
investissements et pour permettre la
mise en service de ce mode de transport
par ailleurs hormis la région de route
est qui porte ce projet transport
autonome depuis 2010 est je n'ai pas
connaissance à ce stade le région
intéressés je donne donc un avis de
sagesse merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre je suis allé
récemment à nancy est évidemment joué
j'ai rencontré le sénateur jacques 1 et
le maire de nancy mathieu klein
expliquer le sujet urban loupe très long
dans le détail ils ont une vraie fierté
je dirais régionales
moi je n'ai aucun problème sauf que je
ne sais tu pas utile de le mettre dans
la loi
je veux dire l'expérimentation se fait
quand ils veulent
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il est
inutile de charger la loi de ce genre de
choses je le dis haut et fort nous
sommes favorable à l'expérimentation de
l'utilisation d'urban look mais voilà
merci madame la ministre
il n'y a pas de demande explications de
vote il est maintenu donc je mets aux
voileux 729 rectifié qui a reçu une
sagesse de la commission et une demande
de retrait du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
voilà le sénat a voté la mise en place
d'un contrat de mixité sociale entre les
communes et le préfet de région qui
permet d'adapter le rythme de rattrapage
de la construction de logements sociaux
en gros c'est une commune atteint les
objectifs fixés dans ce contrat elle ne
sera pas sanctionné
même si ces objectifs sont inférieurs
aux quotas de la loi sru
mais en contrepartie les sanctions
financières en cas de non respect de ce
contrat de mixité sociale
en revanche et est alourdie voilà merci
nous avoir suivis la politique
et l'actualité parlementaire se poursuit
sur public sénat
[Musique]
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
l'actualité parlementaire et politique
continue sur publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
ce soir à 22h hashtag thomas pesquet
même depuis l'espace soutiendrez les
bleus mais il représente quelque chose
de symboliquement très fort qui ce
dialogue entre la terre et l'espace à
22h30
allons plus loin rebecca fitoussi
interroge ses invités pour comprendre
l'actualité du jour
bonne soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]
du coup d'état du 18 brumaire qui amène
napoléon bonaparte au pouvoir jusqu'à la
chute de l'empereur en 1814 le palais du
luxembourg a joué un rôle crucial dans
cette période clé de l'histoire de
france
les grandes étapes du régime napoléonien
ont été imaginés en tout cas toujours
validé par le sénat conservateur dans ce
palais le sénat conservateur créé en
1799 s'installe au palais du luxembourg
qui se métamorphose pour l'occasion avec
l'arrivée de napoléon pouvoir le palais
du luxembourg va subir sa première
grande transformation
ce palais qui était un palais
d'habitation pour les princes pour les
rois va devenir un lieu où va siéger une
assemblée législative
longtemps décrié pour sa docilité ou au
contraire pour avoir déchu l'empereur en
1814 le sénat conservateur a en tout cas
été au coeur des institutions pendant
les quinze années où napoléon un
gouvernant la france les institutions
d'atteinte à leur fonctionnement
régulier et en écartant napoléon du
pouvoir le sénat a réussi à permettre la
continuité de l'état
le sénat au fond est un des grands
acteurs du régime napoléonien peut-être
le plus méconnu
[Musique]
c'est ici dans l'allée qui mène du
palais du luxembourg proprement dit est
ce qu'on appelle le petit luxembourg qui
était à la fin de la révolution entre
1795 et 1799 le siège du pouvoir
exécutif tenue par cinq directeurs parmi
ces directeurs l'abbé emmanuel sieyès
préparer un coup d'état parlementaire
pour renforcer le pouvoir exécutif dans
la constitution et rendre les
institutions plus fluide fonctionnant
mieux et c'est donc ici que à son retour
d'égypte en octobre 1799 bonaparte a
rencontré on va dire pour la première
fois l'abbé sieyès et c'est dans ces
locaux du petit luxembourg qu'ils ont
préparé le coup d'état des 18 et 19
brumaire de l'an 8 un coup d'état pensée
de longue date et pour lequel napoléon
bonaparte n'était pas le premier choix
mais le général s'impose vite comme
l'homme de la situation
reste à convaincre les chambres
parlementaires le coup d'état du 18
brumaire devait être un coup d'état
purement parlementaire ont fait croire
aux chambres qu'un complot jacobins les
menaces ont fait nommer bonaparte à la
tête de la garnison de paris et les
chambres décident de se réunir en dehors
de la capitale comme le prévoit la
constitution au château de saint-cloud
le deuxième jour du coup d'état le 19
brumaire on essaye d'obtenir des
chambres le vote de la révision de la
constitution et bonaparte perd patience
et finalement après une bousculade dans
un des deux conseils
il fait intervenir la troupe et expulse
les députés ce coup d'état parlementaire
devient un coup d'état militaire mais
redevient un coup d'état parlementaire
puisque on fait revenir les chambres en
séance et c'est là qu'elle vote la fin
du directoire et demande le vote d'une
nouvelle constitution
dès le lendemain le 11 novembre 1799
napoléon s'installe au palais du
luxembourg depuis 1795 c'est le lieu du
pouvoir
la douce se gouverne la france
où
nous allons entrer dans les salons de
boffrand du nom de son architecte c'est
ici que siéger le directoire exécutif de
1795 à 1799 donc c'est ici qu'a été
gouverné la france à la fin de la
révolution
le directoire n'était pas un régime très
populaire il a connu beaucoup d'échecs
d'abord la constitution fonctionner mal
un coup d'état par an en moyenne
les finances publiques étaient exemple
l'administration locale
inexistante et puis surtout la guerre
civile continuer à l'intérieur et la
guerre extérieure était très vive elle
aussi en allemagne et en italie
en italie le général napoléon bonaparte
s'illustre dans les batailles face aux
autrichiens jusqu'à leur faire signer la
paix en 1797 mettant fin à cinq années
de guerre
c'est auréolé de gloire qu'il revient à
paris en 1797 napoléon bonaparte rentrer
de la campagne d'italie et il est reçu
ici au palais du luxembourg
solennellement par le directoire à qui
il doit remettre le texte du traité de
campo font mieux le directoire reçoit
bonaparte avec tous les honneurs parce
que il faut savoir aussi que bonaparte
est déjà connu et déjà un peu populaire
donc c'est une façon de de capter la
gloire qu'il a obtenu en italie et puis
surtout de montrer au peuple qu'on
accepte ce traité de campo forme yuki au
départ n'a pas fait très plaisir aux
directeurs parce que qu'un général se
substituer au gouvernement et au
ministre de l'intérieur pour négocier la
paix ça n'était quand même pas habituel
à cette époque
le directoire chargera ensuite naboléon
d'envahir l'egypte ce n'est qu'en retour
de cette expédition que sieyès fera de
bonaparte son homme de main pour le coup
d'état une fois le directoire renversé
il faut mettre en place une nouvelle
organisation
c'est dans les salons du palais du
luxembourg que vont être débattues les
principes du consulat la première tâche
qui a été assigné au consul provisoire
c'est de rédiger une constitution et
c'est dans ce salon que vont se réunir
deux commissions législatives en
présence des consuls et elles vont
travailler pendant un petit mois à la
rédaction de la nouvelle constitution
dite constitution de l'an 8
et c'est là que bonaparte va intervenir
il va laisser à seignosse la partie
législative qui l'intéressent peu mais
va beaucoup s'occuper de la partie
concernant le pouvoir exécutif
avec évidemment les plus grands pouvoirs
la principale liberté qui sera donné au
futur consul sieyès a donc le champ
libre sur la partie institutionnelle
dès le titre 2 de la constitution le
sénat conservateur est créé
avec un rôle majeur à la clé
la grande innovation de la constitution
de la 8c la création de ce sénat
conservateur au sens de conservateurs de
la constitution c'est une idée de sieyès
qui souhaitaient une assemblée de sages
qui puisse surveiller l'application du
texte fondamental arbitrer les
différends et même exercer un contrôle
de constitutionnalité des lois et des
textes de l'exécutif
en plaçant le sénat conservateur aussi
haut dans la constitution
les rédacteurs veulent marquer son rôle
de garant d autres institutions
très clairement et une volonté
honorifique d'une part et aussi très
symbolique mettre en avant les sénateurs
en tant que tel comme étant des garants
du bon fonctionnement des institutions
et d'autre part s'assurer du fait que
l'on vise justement à stabiliser les
institutions le sénat conservateur a
l'ascendant sur les chambres
législatives
c'est lui qui est chargé de désigner ses
membres par un suffrage en direct les
pouvoirs sont effectivement considérable
le premier d'entre eux c'est se
substituer à l'élection puisque ce sont
les sénateurs qui vont désigner la
plupart des personnes amenées à
travailler au sein des institutions
publiques et notamment au sein du corps
législatif du tribunal et c est à dire
les membres du sénat sont au départ
nommé par siess les autres consul puis
par une formule de cooptation ils sont
au début du régime 80 et vont donc se
voir assigner comme siège le palais du
luxembourg
[Musique]
enfin 17 199 commencent alors les grands
travaux au palais du luxembourg peu
retouché depuis sa construction pour
marie de médicis au xviie siècle le
grand palais va être totalement
transforme
nous sommes donc en 1799 et un napoléon
vient de créer le sénat conservateur
on va confier à chagrin qui est
architecte d'état la double mission de
rénover entièrement le palais mais aussi
de le changer
structurellement afin que cet édifice
qui était jusque là une habitation royal
deviennent un bâtiment administratif
premier chantier de chagrin va être
d'offrir à ces nouveaux sénateurs une
entrée digne de ce nom
va complètement évident et c'est l ouest
celle là même qui abritait les
appartements de marie de médicis est
installé à la place
cet escalier monumental
monumental par ses dimensions nous
sommes ici devant 48 marche juste
entrecoupé d'un palier de repos il faut
bien comprendre que chaque marche est
construite d'un seul pan de pierre large
de 7 m imaginez le travail que ça a pu
représenter pour l'installer
non
chalgrin va utiliser quelques éléments
de décor pour donner une touche
d'orientalisme à l'ensemble c'est à dire
qu'il va faire installer des lions de
nubie des lions qui sont sans cris
wierre et qui viennent de l'egypte
ancienne
il va aussi installés tout autour de
l'escalier une frise sculptée qui
reprend des éléments de décor qui
proviennent de la grèce et de la rome
ancienne
on retrouve dans le haut de l'escalier
d'honneur le style antique emprunté à
part chalgrin il va utiliser 28 colonnes
d'ordre ionique pour tenir la voûtes
majestueuses qu'il vient de créer cette
voûte est composé de 308 rosas en
caisson
nous entrons maintenant dans le coeur
des transformations réalisées par
chalgrin cette grande salle était à
l'époque divisée en trois parties
nous avons ici une salle de réunion
c'est une salle qui permet aux sénateurs
de se réunir cette investiture avant
d'entrer dans la salle des séances
il y avait un grand mur sur lequel était
apposé un portrait de plain pied de
napoléon car si l'empereur n'était pas
toujours présent lors des séances ça
voulait quand même dire que chaque
sénateur qui avaient pénétré dans la
salle des séances le faisait sous le
regard de l'empereur
[Musique]
la porte se situer sur le côté droit du
mur vous n'aviez qu'à la pousser et vous
rentriez directement dans la salle des
séances
[Musique]
au coeur de cette salle chalgrin réussi
à aménager un hémicycle pouvant
accueillir 80 puis 120 sénateurs à
partir de 18 cents 2,26 colonnes en
marbre soutiennent l'édifice ou des
statues antiques décor l'ensemble dans
le plus pur style néoclassique
face au travail des sénateurs au coeur
de la pièce dans un renfoncement créé
spécialement chalgrin installe le trône
de l'empereur un trône surmonté d'un des
soutenus par six cariatides de plus de
deux mètres de haut
drapé à l'antique
si le des a depuis quitté le palais le
trône est lui toujours dans la salle
qu'il accueillait à l'époque
l'inspiration orientale est évidemment
présente puisqu'il repose sur deux
sphinx aux ailes déployées sur le
velours le n napoléonien et l'abeille
rappelle les emblèmes de celui qui
deviendra empereur en 1804
dans le
nous arrivons maintenant dans la
dernière pièce de cette enfilade qui fut
aussi la dernière créé puisque on estime
qu'elle est terminée
en 1809 cette salle on va la nommer le
salon de l'empereur ou la salle des
victoires on retrouve que ce soit dans
la voûte ou sur les murs des peintures
qui relate les victoires napoléoniennes
mais la pièce la plus importante que
l'on trouve ici va se trouver à ce qui
est aujourd'hui la porte du salon victor
hugo c'est là qui est installé l'immense
statue représentant napoléon elle fait
plus de deux mètres de haut et il est
habillé avec les apparats du sacre
le sénat conservateur a donc désormais
un palais aménagé pour travailler
à
en l'an 1800 napoléon bonaparte quitte
le palais du luxembourg pour emménager
aux tuileries
il pose les premières pierres d'un état
moderne en créant la banque de france et
la fonction de préfet relais du pouvoir
dans les départements mais à la fin de
l'année 1801 tournant va changer la
donne pour napoléon comme pour le sénat
conservateur en décembre 1800 à mauléon
et échappe à un attentat
il désigne comme coupable les jacobins
et dessine que 130 d'entre eux vont être
transportés aux colonies
l attentat raté de la rue saint-nicaise
va provoquer un dilemme moral car
contrairement à ce que pense napoléon ce
ne sont pas les jacobins qui ont tenté
de le tuer mais des royalistes
même une fois les véritables coupables
arrêtés napoléon veut profiter de ce
moment pour purger l'opposition jacobine
trop remuante à son goût
[Musique]
c'est un acte qui va contre la liberté
publique et donc cambacérès le numéro
deux du régime lui propose d'interroger
le sénat sur la constitutionnalité de
cette mesure
l'attentât de la rue saint-nicaise est
vraiment le tournant politique juridique
du consulat indéniablement on était dans
une situation d'illégalité la plus
totale puisque on souhaitait des portes
et des personnes qui n'étaient en rien
responsable de l'attentât qui visait le
premier conçu alors le sénat va
travailler pendant une grosse journée
sur le sujet et va approuver l'action du
gouvernement sous forme de ce qu'on a
appelé un sénatus consulte qui était une
vieille procédure romaine et c'est à
partir de là que le sénat a pu s'arroger
presque le pouvoir constituant dérivé
qui lui sera accordée formellement par
la constitution la réforme
constitutionnelle de l'an 10 en 1802
deux ans après son arrivée au pouvoir
napoléon bonaparte à stabiliser le be
sur le plan intérieur le concordat est
signée pacifier les relations avec
l'église catholique
sur le plan extérieur la france signe
avec l'angleterre la paix d'amiens
offrant la première période de paix
totale depuis plus de dix ans
[Musique]
les chambres législatives veulent saluer
ce moment en donnant au premier consul
un signe de reconnaissance en le nommant
conçu la vie mais le sénat conservateur
est mesurée dans un premier temps le
sénat n'est pas d'accord avec ce projet
et il le fait savoir puisque il vota
premier texte dans lequel en réalité le
pouvoir de bonaparte ne prolonger que de
10 ans et puis c'est finalement avait
après un bras de fer entre les sénateurs
et le gouvernement que sera adopté le
sénatus consulte de l'andi ce qui
modifie assez profondément la
constitution et parmi les mesures qui
sont prises il y en a deux qui intéresse
le sénat la première c'est sa défaite
puisque bonaparte est nommé consul à vie
mais la deuxième c'est un peu sa
victoire puisque le sénat voit ses
pouvoirs renforcés
le nombre de sénateurs augmenté on va
donner au sénat des outils qu'il n'avait
pas emmené en 8 pour qu'il n'utilisera
jamais d'ailleurs mais qui lui
permettent justement d'être le garant
effectifs de la constitution clairement
il a maintenant une île est vraiment un
garant de la constitution mais un garant
outillés et efficace cette pratique
qu'on va appeler celle des senatus
consult qui va être de la part du sénat
dans son rôle de conservateur de la
constitution une mission
d'interprétation de la constitution
voire même à un moment donné de
modification de la constitution
ce qu'on appelle le pouvoir constituant
dérivé qui n'était pas prévue dans la
constitution et que l'on va remettre au
sénat qui lui assure s'en saisira
le sénat ne cesse donc de voir son rôle
grandir et pour assurer de bons revenus
à une partie des sénateurs en 1803 on
leur attribue de grand palais et des
domaines situés aux quatre coins de
france les sénatorerie pour beaucoup on
achète ainsi la docilité des sénateurs
mais pas seulement
au début du consulat ce qu'il veut
simplement c'est recréer une élite
sociale qui a été très largement
déstructuré par la période
révolutionnaire en créant ces structures
que sont les sénateurs rit on peut ainsi
s'assurer d'avoir une élite qui est au
service de l'état qui s'insèrent aussi
localement à travers la propriété
foncière et la propriété terrienne qui
éventuellement d'ailleurs se lit
familialement avec les élites locales de
façon bien plus efficace que ne le sont
les préfets en 1804 après quatre années
de pouvoir de napoléon bonaparte les
bases du régime sont posées le consulat
vit ses derniers jours et napoléon
bonaparte se rêve en empereur des
français
une fois encore c'est le sénat qui va
assurer la rédaction d'une nouvelle
constitution
contrairement à ce qu'on dit souvent
napoléon n'est pas devenu empereur le 2
décembre 1804 au moment de son sacre
mais le 18 mai 1804 au moment où le
sénat a voté à sénatus consulte
transformant le consulat en empire le
sénat est le seul à pouvoir permettre le
passage à l'an pire puisqu'il est devenu
officiellement le garant des
institutions certes mais surtout
l'acteur principal de la modification
constitutionnelle donc et on ne pouvait
pas envisager autre chose qu'un système
de passation par le sénat alors on pense
toujours que les choses sont passés
comme une lettre à la poste comme on
dirait populairement mais en réalité ça
a été très difficile
la procédure a été complexe et surtout
au sénat il ya eu des débats de
véritables débats avec des discours de
sénateurs qui bien qu acceptant lempire
le rendait conditionnelle ils sont en
partie à l'origine du serment impériale
qui relativise cette idée que l empire
met à mal toute idée de conservation des
institutions bien au contraire
l'empereur et ses descendants s'engage à
respecter les principes fondamentaux
ayant conduit au système consulaire est
impérial ces conditions se retrouve
d'ailleurs dans le serment
constitutionnel que l'empereur a prêté
justement le 2 décembre 1804 à notre
dame
notre dame de paris et le théâtre de ce
couronnement le 2 décembre 1804 le pape
est présent pour bénir ce sacre napoléon
bonaparte devient napoléon 1er empereur
des français mais comme prévu par les
sénateurs l'empereur prête serment de
préserver une grande partie des acquis
de la révolution liberté de culte
liberté politique levée de l'impôt par
les chambres législatives est de
gouverner dans le seul intérêt du peuple
français
la constitution de 1804 qui installe
lempire prévoit que le régime est
héréditaire le rôle des assemblées est
clairement amoindri mais le sénat
obtient tout de même la création de
première commission censée garantir les
libertés les plus fondamentales un ténia
blement les commissions sont dans la
dans le prolongement du contrôle de
constitutionnalité et de l'idée que le
sénat est une sorte d' oracle de ce qui
doit être le bon fonctionnement de
l'état elles ont pour vocation de
contrôler finalement toutes les
atteintes qui seraient portés aux
principes fondamentaux que sont la
liberté individuelle mais il la liberté
de la presse
il s'agit donc éventuellement d'ordonner
la publication d'organes de presse qui
aurait été interdit mais aussi de
demander l'élargissement de personnes
qui seraient injustement fermé
je
pendant les dix années que dure lempire
le sénat se réunit beaucoup moins et se
contentent souvent de valider les
demandes de l'empereur ce sont ainsi les
sénateurs qui votent les conscriptions
qui permettent de fournir à la grande
armée les troupes nécessaires au caire
napoléonienne en retour napoléon
n'oublie jamais de remercier les
sénateurs
ceci est la plaque dit delfingen
cette plaque rappelle que napoléon a
déposé au sénat après la campagne de
1805 une grande partie des drapeaux pris
à l'ennemi le reste allant aux corps
législatif au tribunal ou aux invalides
cette plaque rappelle aussi que le sénat
a joué un rôle dans cette campagne
puisque grâce aux sénatus consulte il a
permis d'augmenter la conscription et
d'augmenter finalement les effectifs de
l'armée française c'est aussi une façon
pour napoléon de distribuer la gloire
auprès des grandes institutions civiles
afin que cette gloire soit véritablement
celle de la nation pendant près de dix
ans personne ne remettra en question la
vision de l'empereur du moins tant que
les victoires s'enchaînent mais
l'invasion de la russie en 1812 fini par
tourner à la berezina en 1814 la france
est acculé les armées étrangères
envahissent paris napoléon est reclus à
fontainebleau est allé rendement dos et
n'a de porter le coup de grâce
le 2 avril 1814 les sénateurs peaufine
mot par mot leur dernier sénatus
consulte dans les archives du sénat on
retrouve le brouillon à noter à la main
ou les sénateurs liste l'ensemble des
griefs qui les pousse à déchoir napoléon
1er le 3 avril en séance
illzach tu cette déchéance de l'emploi
le senate us consulte explique que
napoléon n'a pas respecté son serment
constitutionnel et donc par conséquent
le sénat ne peut que constater la
déchéance de l'empereur l'acte de
déchéance est un vrai modèle d' analyse
contentieuse d'une situation les
sénateurs avaient peur qu'on leur
reproche l'absence de fondement pour
cette décision malheureusement on n'a
absolument pas retenu ce problème de la
justification juridique pour se
concentrer sur la situation politique et
la trahison
au fond les sénateurs n'avaient pas
tellement le choix le territoire
national était occupée napoléon était
maintenue à fontainebleau avec très peu
de troupes
il fallait sortir de cette crise je
dirais avec une solution française et
non pas une solution imposée par les
vainqueurs de napoléon et c'est pourquoi
le sénat après avoir été le grand
complice de napoléon a accepté d'être le
grand complice de talleyrand à
fontainebleau napoléon rumine contre ce
sénat qui s'est retourné contre lui mais
s'il n'a d'autre choix que d' abdiquer
le 6 avril 1814
les vainqueurs l'envoi en exil sur l'île
d'elbe tandis que le sénat appelle aux
pouvoirs louis xviii frère du roi louis
saez décapiter la monarchie restaurée
le sénat est remplacé par la chambre des
pairs il perd sa mission de contrôle
constitutionnel pour devenir une
véritable chambre législative
le sénat a probablement permis dans son
fonctionnement et dans simplement dans
son existence de poser des piliers
fondateurs de notre france contemporaine
comme par exemple l'université
le code du commerce comme le code pénal
ou alors tout simplement comme le code
civil
au fond ce qui reste surtout de ce sénat
là c'est l'idée d'une assemblée de sages
d'abord plus âgé il fallait avoir 40 ans
pour être sénateur sous l' empire non
soumis aux pressions extérieures aux
pressions de la politique du quotidien
c'est peut-être un petit peu autour de
cette idée qu'on pourrait trouver une
filiation entre le sénat de napoléon et
le sénat de la vème république
[Musique]
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
la femme reste toujours subordonné à
l'homme la plupart du temps elle est
vraiment un objet sexuel ou une servante
économique elle est toujours sous payée
elle appelait tous les chances égales à
celles de l'homme elle est toujours a
servi à la maternité au foyer je crois
pas du tout tienne le progrès
malheureusement beauvoir est née au
début du 20e siècle
à l'époque on ne reconnaît ni le droit
de vote des femmes ni l'autonomie
financière ni l'avortement est lourd
je lis la cage de la prison dans les
hôtels sont infirmées les femmes depuis
des millénaires
vous rendez compte
c'était enthousiasmant l'état jeudi puis
la révolution sur ce temps là sur nos
plans de travail ménager s'est lui
refusé c'est obliger les hommes à faire
avec elle après bien si ceux ci étaient
changer toute la société en seraient
bouleversés
mais comment a t'elle conquis sa liberté
car elle n'est pas née beauvoir elle
l'est devenue beauvoir laventure d'être
soir et demain à 22h sur public sénat
stéphane giraud et militant écologiste
il a choisi de nous amener sur le
chantier d'un nouvel axe autoroutier
près de strasbourg pour nous faire part
de ses inquiétudes
il craint que le nombre de camions
n'explose dans sa riche la société
autoroutière qui a remporté la
concession est pas là pour pour faire de
la philanthropie
elle est là pour faire du bénéfice donc
à la tout intérêt est là à ce que le
maximum de poids lourds viennent
emprunter sa et des camions il y en a
déjà beaucoup en alsace au moins 2000 de
plus par jour depuis 2005
car à cette date le voisin allemand a
mis en place une éco taxe sur les poids
lourds sur l'autoroute qui relie le nord
au sud
conséquence les camions venus de toute
l'europe empreinte la parallèle
française l'a 35 qui elle est gratuite
c'est même une question d'environnement
c'est une question de santé publique
c'est la santé de nos enfants nos
petits-enfants c'est les a les accents
vasculaires cérébraux qui explose
complètement en alsace sans vie dans un
environnement qui est fortement pollué
on a d'autres exemples la vallée la
revanche amis etc qui nous montre un peu
ce que ça peut donner
et ça date pas d'hier donc on va penser
on a le recul pour pallier à cela l'état
vient d'autoriser par ordonnance la
collectivité européenne d'alsace qui
regroupe le haut-rhin et le bas-rhin à
mettre en place une écotaxe sur
l'autoroute a35 côté français un premier
test qui pourrait être généralisé aux
régions avec la loi cadets la communauté
européenne d'alsace gère déjà six mille
kilomètres de routes départementales
pour son président elle est l'échelon
idéal pour s'occuper des autoroutes
confiée par l'état
mais la mise en place de l'éco taxe pour
les poids lourds en transit est plus
difficile après l'échec national de la
mesure en 2013
tout est à imaginer pour ce nouveau test
locale ça peut être une taxe a peut être
une vignette donc ça peut être une
redevance donc les systèmes sont
nombreux et ont chacun les avantages et
des inconvénients et ensuite parce que
pour moi c'est important que sur les
enjeux majeurs
je puisse consulter les alsaciens nous
ferons ensuite un système de votation
et ce n'est qu'à ces tissus la queue
nous mettrons ou pas en place la
taxation lui ne risque pas de voter pour
michel chalot gère une entreprise de
transports de matières premières et de
véhicules 85% de ses livraisons se font
localement en alsace
d'après lui les transporteurs français
seront les premiers à être pénalisés par
cette taxe sauf s'est fabriqué à une
chérie qui est à 60 kilomètres d'ici eh
ben on va payer l'écotaxe avec le
véhicule qui va monter à vide pour
pouvoir charger et qui va charger là-bas
et redescendre et qui va repayer nouveau
l'écotaxe de manière naturelle
c'est à dire on va payer 120 km des
côtes axe il a d'ailleurs fait ses
calculs
on peut penser que si elle est mise en
place elle sera a minima au même niveau
de taxation que l'écotaxe en allemagne
ça représente à peu près entre 4 et 5 %
de nos coûts qui vont augmenter c'est à
dire pour une entreprise comme ça vous
serez à 300000 euros à ma les seuls qui
peuvent le payer c'est les consommateurs
finaux c'est nos donneurs d'ordres et
derrière le consommateur toute manière
c'est toujours le bout de la chaîne qui
paiera
l'éco taxe devrait être mise en place à
partir de 2024
les tractations ont déjà commencé entre
les transporteurs et la collectivité
européenne d'alsace pour d'éventuelles
dérogations mais le champ d'action est
particulièrement minces les lois
européennes n'autorisent pas de
différence de traitement entre les
transporteurs en fonction de leur
nationalité
[Musique]
public sénat en partenariat avec france
culture et avec le soutien du centre
national du livre présente livres et
vous
[Musique]
m
bonjour me bienvenu dans livres et vous
l'émission littéraire de public sénat
et aujourd'hui on va vous parler de
livres jeunesse avec trois personnes je
vous présente tout d'abord les deux
auteurs marion brunet on vous doit
franchir et frangine vient de paraître
en poche et puis une oeuvre imposante
que l'on voit ici dont vous allez nous
parler dans quelques instants à côté de
vous fabrice colin necropolis l'appel du
sémaphore il vient de sortir ainsi chez
nathan et puis alors en face de vous une
dame
régine hatchondo bourges où régine
hatchondo vous présidez le cnl le cnl
c'est notre partenaire vous le retrouvez
chaque semaine d'un livret vous et
justement ça va être l'occasion de nous
dire régine hatchondo qu'est ce que ce
centre national du livre
à quoi sert-il le centre national du
livre c'est un organisme financé par le
par l'état par le ministère de la
culture et dont le financement est dédié
à toute la chaîne du livre des auteurs
traducteurs éditeurs
libraire plus récemment dans le cadre du
plan d'urgence bibliothèque est ce que
vous avez fait beaucoup de choses
pendant confiant
toute la vie littéraire fait toute la
vie littéraire être un peu prétentieux
dans tous les cas à 100 130 festival de
littérature partout en france et enfin
le festival que nous lançons bientôt
partir en liberté en livre qui est donc
diriger vers la littérature jeunesse
dont quel but
justement dans le but de faire naître ou
renaître pour certains découvrir la
littérature sous un angle qu'on essaye
de rendre plus ludique j'aime pas le mot
parce qu'il ya des choses très sérieuses
vont partir en livres mais en même temps
avec une approche très vivante de la
lecture on y reviendra
et alors on va pas assommer nos
téléspectateurs avec des chiffres mais
ils vous faites beaucoup de sondages
d'études
régine hatchondo pour essayer de
comprendre quel est le rapport des
français avec le livre des jeunes lisent
quand même moins qu'avant
oui les jeunes lisent moins qu'avant on
en imagine très bien les raisons pour
lesquelles ils lisent moi ils font
extrêmement sollicités par les écrans de
toutes tailles par les réseaux sociaux
avec un sentiment parfois que la lecture
les isole c'est pas un plaisir collectif
et partagé avec le sentiment qu'elle est
obligatoire parce qu'on se fait souvent
très fortement sollicités à la fois par
le corps enseignant ce qui est normal
mais aussi par les parents et donc la
lecture comme une contrainte et je pense
qu'il faut arriver et c'est un des
objectifs phares du centre national du
livre à faire en sorte que la lecture
soit vecchi quand même plaisir un
plaisir pour soi alors on se rassoit on
va voir quels sont les différents
efforts qu'on peut produire mais tout
d'abord on peut faire de bons livres
comme les vôtres on vous a choisi
fabrice colin et et marion brunet parce
que vos ouvrages sont deux des ouvrages
que l'on lit avec beaucoup de plaisir il
appartient à une catégorie je veux dire
en français parce que il ya un élément
phare shooting en anglais mais pour
jeunes adultes
arion rooney frangine par exemple c'est
une histoire qui a une histoire très
sérieuses il s'agit donc de deux enfants
qui sont nés d'une pma dans un couple
formé de deux femmes et qui sont
confrontés notamment à l'homophobie
pourquoi avoir décidé de traiter de ce
thème pour des enfants
alors c'est pas pour des enfants
inspirent des adolescents quand young
adult comme on dit en français alors
pour moi c'est j'écris quand j'écris je
au départ je me dis pas que j'écris pour
des ados en fait j'ai l'impression que
c'est un public beaucoup plus vaste et
que selon souvent l'âge de mes
personnages je vais plutôt aller vers
une édition jeu jeunesse ouvert une
édition adultes puisque globalement mes
romans qu'ils soient en jeunesse on
adule traite des problématiques sociales
parce que c'est ce qui m'intéresse ce
qui me meut les injustices l'engagement
voilà tout ça c'est celle où des thèmes
qui m'intéressent des thèmes sérieux
parce que je pense que les jeunes sont
aussi friands de ça et que ça
m'intéresse d'aller vers eux avec ces
questions là et d'ailleurs quand je les
rencontre
quand on voit la dent lors des
rencontres publiques autour de mes
romans je sens qu'il ya une vraie
un vrai intérêt pour pour toutes ces
questions là ils sont pas déconnectés du
monde
comment faire pour écrire donc là en
l'occurrence d'histoire de joachim et de
pauline ses frères et sept soeurs qui
sont donc confrontés à cette question là
comment vous mettez à la place si on se
met à la place d'un public dont
d'adolescents pour moi ce sont des
enfants vous dites des ados parce que
effectivement c'est plus précis que cela
alors moi je pense que je vais plutôt
chercher dans mes propres souvenirs de
cette période là que dans les jeunes que
je vois autour de moi mais je pensais
quand même un peu un mélange des deux
et je trouve que c'est un âge absolument
passionnant puis qui est assez
romanesque puisque c'est quand même le
moment des premières fois donc
donc c'est forcément passionnant parce
que voilà c'est la découverte c'est le
moment aussi des choix le moment des
ruptures des ruptures familiales entre
donc le moment où on choisit de rester
ou de quitter un univers familial
comment se positionne par rapport à ce
milieu là aux idées enfin voilà tout
tout tout ce que ça brasse de cet âge là
moi je trouve que c'est absolument
passionnant et c'est très sérieux
c'est ce qu'ils vivent est très sérieux
fabrice cola c'est très sérieux aussi ce
que vous faites alors il ya une partie
c'est de l'héroïque fantaisie comme par
exemple necropolis via une autre partie
vous écrivez des ouvrages consacrés à
des grandes dames de grands hommes
simone veil et barack obama marilyn
monroe pour des jeunes c'est chez albin
michel
là aussi comment fait-on découvrir par
exemple simone veil à des enfants alors
déjà sont les ouvrages qui sont
consacrés à la jeunesse de ces
personnalités c'est à dire qu'on
s'arrête généralement dans le cadre de
simone veil je me suis arrêté quand elle
s'est mise à travailler quand elle est
devenue mère à son tour c'est-à-dire
quand elle quitte vraiment le premier
âge on va dire il ya tout un travail de
documentation évidemment à fournir
l'idée est de montrer en quoi la
jeunesse de ces personnalités va
informer ce que ce qu'elles vont devenir
par la suite
donc il s'agit pas nécessairement de les
ériger comme l'exemple mais il ya un peu
de ça quand même c'est à dire dire aux
lecteurs
voilà ces gens ont eu votre âge
également ils ont affronté dans le cas
de simone veil évidemment de grandes
difficultés
une adversité et massive et puis par la
suite ils ont réussi à surmonter ces
épreuves là et à devenir les personnes
que l'on connaît que vous connaissez
peut-être en cours d'histoire que vos
parents connaissent mais on va nous sa
tâche est allé à les montrer dans cette
prime jeunesse qui est comme le disait
marion l'ag des premières fois où ils
vont aussi commencer à se construire et
l'héroïque fantaisie alors donc l'autre
partie de votre travail
alors là les littératures de
l'imaginaire c'est à dire que bon on
devient créateur de mondes raconteur
d'histoires là dans le cas de necropolis
par exemple si une histoire qui met en
scène des adolescents qui sont gardiens
de cimetières mais c'est pas le
cimetière traditionnel c'est un
cimetière qui est peuplé de créatures
mort vivante c'est à dire qu'ils sont
susceptibles de se réveiller
donc c'est un cimetière qui n'est pas
sous contrôle on va dire et et les
créatures qui l'habite sont susceptibles
de sortir de leur tombe de venir hanter
les mortels et donc ses apprentis
gardiens qui sont quatre sont chargés
d'y mettre bon ordre
régine hatchondo justement on voit la
diversité de la diversité de cette
littérature jeunesse
comment la promouvoir comment vous
faites au cnl pour permettre à ces
différents livres de rencontrer leur
public alors de manière générale en
matière de littérature là on vient de
pour la première fois deux de tester des
nouveaux formats de podcasts qui
rencontre un certain succès à l'échelle
suisse et l on n'est pas
on n'est pas un gars fin mai en a
l'intention de s'emparer des réseaux
sociaux pour rendre beaucoup plus
visible la littérature littérature
jeunesse et la littérature de manière
générale la rendre la rendre beaucoup
plus visible avec des petites formes
courtes pouvoir donner envie de lire un
livre de l'acheter et puis pour les
jeunes dans l'étude puisque vous dites
qu'on fait beaucoup d'études a raison
parce qu'on essaye de comprendre
pourquoi pourquoi effectivement en
l'occurrence les jeunes lisent moi mais
c'est pas que les jeunes les lecteurs
aussi dix mois sauf pendant le
confinement ou les lecteurs
traditionnels ont acheté plus de livres
mais sinon globalement tout le monde
l'ignoré parce que on n'arrêtait pas de
ce caviar ise du bon état à juste titre
dieu la librairie pendant le confinement
malgré tout dans les études que vous
avez fait il ya deux ou trois bémols on
a eu raison de se gargariser puisque la
lecture a fallu le les librairies sont
de loin et le livre et deux mois le
marché qui a le mieux tenu malgré les
fermetures puisqu'il n'a perdu que 3 %
même si j'aime pas trop toujours donné
des chiffres quand même 3 % c'est peu
par rapport aux voies que cela quand on
compare à d'autres
d'autres d'autres activités culturelles
ou artistiques je pense aux jeux vidéo
par exemple que les jeunes m
il a baissé davantage que le livre
pendant le confinement mais on s'est
rendu compte très près avec nous et 8
que c'est beaucoup plus les lecteurs
traditionnels qui ont plus loin que nous
n'avions élargi le nombre de lecteurs et
c'est ça notre souci fondamental et pour
les jeunes ce qu'ils réclament en tous
les cas dans toutes les études que l'on
fait et on va en faire une
spécifiquement pour les jeunes l'an
prochain quand on pourra vous réserver
l'exclusivité diffusé dans le cadre
d'autres partenariats
il réclame qu'on les prenne par la main
ils sont un peu perdus et il aimerait
qu'il y ait des clubs de lecteurs de
deux du même âge qu'eux ils n'ont pas
une grande confiance dans les adultes
ils n'ont pas une grande confiance dans
les médias
ils ont besoin en excuser moi
en fait ils ont besoin d'être entre eux
et de ce conseiller des choses iront
beaucoup plus et donc on va essayer de
créer non seulement des clubs de
lecteurs avec des personnes en chair et
en os qui peuvent se voir se croiser
celle le souhaite mais aussi des clubs
virtuelle des changes de bons conseils
marion brûler vous en rencontrez
beaucoup fabrice collaro 6,2 des
lecteurs vous êtes plutôt optimiste sur
la jeune génération
oui môssieur optimiste après une prune
période aussi où je pouvais être un peu
oui les jeunes parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les mêmes repères que moi non plus qui a
toute la partie technologique qui
m'échappe totalement de ce que je suis
vraiment vraiment pas doué sur cette
question là voilà tous les réseaux
sociaux je suis c'est moi qui suis
perdue pour le coup et je me dis ben non
ils amènent d'autres choses avec leurs
outils mais mais je trouve que c'est
quand même une génération qui qui évolue
qui qui se pose plein de questions qui
je trouve qu'ils ont avancé sur certains
sujets là où nous lesquelles par exemple
et bas par exemple vous parler de mon
roman frangine donc qui est mon premier
jeu sorti en 2013 j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de jeunes et la question de
l'homophobie dans des tas de 2,2 qu'elle
se pose même plus pour c'est vrai
qu'elle cet égard la tolérance
progresser ça c'est quelque chose dont
on peut se féliciter mais leur rapport
au livre
ils sont ils sont en train de prendre un
petit peu en pleine face je dirais
quelque chose qui est qui et qui est
sans précédent dans l'histoire de la
technologie et de la culture c'est à
dire c'est un flux monumentale de
d'information de sollicitations et ses
draps et comme nous parce que moi
contrairement à un mariage et je plaide
coupable j'ai été aussi à moi je me
considère presque victimes des réseaux
sociaux n'ont pas de la façon dont j'ai
été traité mais du temps que j ai perdu
on peut dire et c'est pas évident de se
débarrasser de ça et de faire le point
et de dire est ce que tout ça m'apporte
tellement quelque chose que ça me
grandit est ce que ça me nourrit
est-ce que ça me rend heureux il faut du
temps et j'imagine que s'il en faut pour
moi bien fou du temps pour répondre non
quoi exactement
oui et puis pour comprendre pourquoi on
me répond non et puis pour pas non plus
tomber dans la caricature et dire voilà
plus technologie c'est terminé mais
arriver à trouver un juste équilibre et
revenir vers les plaisirs incomparable
qu'offre la lecture ce qui veut dire
quand même parce que les réseaux sociaux
bon en dire du mal c'est assez simple on
peut tout si je pense se retrouver pour
en dire du mal mais dans le même temps
ça veut dire que les cris aussi il
perdure ce qui n'était pas évident oui
moi je suis un petit peu réservé là
dessus parce que dire que quand on lit
des statuts twitter ou des commentaires
instagram on électeurs moi ça me paraît
un petit peu exagéré certes on est en
train de lire des mots qui forme des
phrases et encore pas toujours écrivait
des sms vous fouillez souvent mais bon
encore une fois ce sont deux choses
différentes pour moi je pense pas qu'il
fallait dire aux jeunes tu perds ton
temps avec les réseaux sociaux par
définition peut pas s'ils sont vraiment
sociaux a cédé à régine hatchondo
trancher ce débat reste longtemps
bonjour je pense que vous avez raison
le il évolue dans un univers y compris
nos enfants alors qu'on n'a pas un écart
menstrues avec eux en tous les cas moi
je me sens par ailleurs très proches
alors qu'ils sont très jeunes
de ce point de vue là on est dans une
situation qui est totalement différente
l'accélération a été énorme avec la
scène j'ai ça va être dix fois pire ou
mieux ça dépend de quel côté anvers
personnellement je pense que le temps
est plus me semble-t-il perdu que il
apporte véritablement de choses très
grand différentes en tous les cas pour
son être personnel sans intimité son
architecture intérieure son sens
critique
une fois qu'on a dit ça on n'a rien dit
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça et s'il
s'éloigne de ça ils perdent aussi
finalement le contact avec leur père
dont il faut arriver à ne pas opposer
réseaux sociaux perte de temps et
plaisirs de la lecture qui est une chose
très particulière je pense en revanche
que la proche qui est la vôtre et je dis
pas ça parce que vous êtes là ce matin
sur ce plateau est intéressante il faut
sûr parler du monde dans lequel ils font
le rique leur écrire des livres qui leur
parlent de ce qu'ils vivent et ne pas
toujours être aussi dans la nostalgie
permanente de lecture entre guillemets
dite de qualité qu on opposera des
lectures qui serait deux mois une grande
qualité alors je crois que nous il faut
qu'on a notre génération il faut qu'on
se trouvera dans l'éducation aussi
qu'est celle qu'on peut donner à nos
enfants à nos je suis d'accord avec ça
et entre eux je pense aux classiques
qu'on a tous lu qu'on a été obligé de
lire à un moment qu'on a aimé qu'on les
ait aimé ou pas et avec cette phrase
qu'on nous disait tout le temps de l'île
et cinquante premières pages tu vas voir
après c'est bien mais non mais non
aujourd'hui je lis pas 50 pages que je
n'aime pas avant de rentrer dans un
roman c'est pas vrai même ma façon de
lire à la changer donc je comprends que
des jeunes est aussi envie d'être dans
des littératures aussi on va les dires
elle a changé c'est à dire que
vous disiez tout à l'heure que les
réseaux sociaux s'étaient pas votre truc
mais peut-être que votre corps défendant
ça a changé votre manière de lire toutes
façons un film n'est plus construit
comme auparavant
je pense au cinéma je pense à la lecture
je pense aux séries effectivement il ya
des choses de plus immédiat lors on peut
dire et c'est négatif ça parle d'un
rapport au monde où tout de suite mais
ça donne aussi des fictions qui sont
incroyablement à pente dès le départ et
même moi en tant qu'adulte j'adore ça
j'adore qu on m'attrape comme ça que ce
soit dans un film où dans un roman où
dès la première dès le premier chapitre
je vais avoir une scène et on embarque
et j'ai l'impression que en jeunesse
peut-être que la particularité de la
littérature jeunesse c'est un peu ce
qu'on peut y trouver c'est de raconter
une histoire elle a raconté en allant
chercher le lecteur comme s'amuse olala
toi tu vas tu vas rester là et tu vas
voir je vais te raconter une super
histoire qu'est ce que vous en pensez et
fabrice que là bas je suis assez
d'accord on ne fait pas en littérature
jeunesse où il fait pas entre guillemets
littérature si on ne fait pas le malin
on essaye évidemment de les décrire le
mieux possible on s'adresse à des
lecteurs adultes en devenir aussi mais
ce qui va primer c'est l'histoire moi
j'aime pas trop le terme de messages
mais c'est vrai qu'on commence à faire
passer des des valeurs plus comme
c'était souligné on participe aussi à
l'édification de cette fameuse
architecture mentale du du citoyen en
devenir
vous vous faites notamment de l'heroic
fantasy vous faites à quitter l'armée
l'heroic fantasy c'est lorsqu'on regarde
ces catégories régine hatchondo quand
vous faites des sondages on voit que
c'est quand même un jean qui est très
populaire qui parle aux jeunes et aux
moins jeunes d'ailleurs
oui parce que il ya aussi cet attrait de
l'imaginaire qui est qui et quand même
pas à négliger c'est à dire que certes
il faut qu'on parle aux jeunes du monde
dans lequel ils sont mais il faut aussi
qu'on les fasse rêver c'est les deux
s'opposent
est ce que n'ont absolument pas une
manière de parler bien sûr on peut aussi
oui alors par exemple la science fiction
si on se place dans un futur plus ou
moins lointain
moi je dis toujours en écrivant de la
science fiction on écrit aussi sur le
présent parce qu'on écrit sur la façon
dont les choses pourraient se passer on
extrapole à partir d'une situation
donnée voilà via le futur et puis il ya
aussi le passé est le passé ça concerne
l'invité qu'on n'a pas pu inviter et
s'est invitée on n'a pas pu inviter
c'est l'un des auteurs qui comptent en
littérature jeunesse c'est tout
simplement
alexandre dumas et on a choisi les trois
mousquetaires est ce que ça vous parle
marion brunet les trois mousquetaires
dumas oui énormément énormément c'était
mon c'est je crois que c'est un mets
livres préférés je crois que c'est le
livre que j'ai le plus lu dans ma vie
puisque je le relis régulièrement
je crois que j'arrête parce que je le
connais trop parker qu'est ce que j'y
trouvais moi je trouve vraiment le
souffle de l'aventuré de l'histoire de
voilà deux bêtes et ça c'est quand même
l'ancêtre des séries puisque on est dans
du feuilleton
on est aussi dans une grande grande
histoire d'amitié moi c'est le plus beau
roman d'amitié qui existent
on sent aussi une véritable réjouissance
de l'auteur quand il écrit moi j'ai
l'impression que alexandre dumas s'amuse
et qu'on partage ça avec lui c'est un
souffle épique j'adore j'adore fabrice
colin
ben ça me parle d'autant plus que le
premier roman que j'ai publié alors pour
les adultes mais en fantaisie c'est aux
éditions bragelonne donc un nom qui
parlera aux amateurs et que le premier
livre
dont j'ai gardé un grand souvenir des
eaux lecture alors c'est pas les trois
mousquetaires c'est le comte de monte
cristo et c'était un livre qui m'avait
été offerts comme premier prix de je
sais plus quoi quand j'étais en vous
insérez abonnés il faut le savoir pour
deviner était un auteur qui sait pas non
c'est vraiment pas une obligation
voilà mais ça fait pas de mal et sinon
il ya d'autres noms qui comptent pour
vous en littérature jeunesse d'hier ou
d'aujourd'hui alors en littérature dire
mon premier le premier nom qui me vient
à l'esprit c'est maurice sendak là
l'auteur de max et les maximonstres
claqué vraiment l'art un album qui n'ont
pas un roman et qui est vraiment un
livre pour les pour les petits mais
aussi pour les grands puisqu'il ya une
force symbolique et je dirais même un
contenu psychanalytique très très fort
et c'est un livre qui continue à rester
en moi
45 ans après quoi régine hatchondo la
place des classiques que fait le cnl que
fait-il aussi auprès des bibliothèques
parce que vous avez tout une action en
faveur de la lecture dans les
bibliothèques auprès des bibliothèques
on a surtout une action à l'égard des
publics
ce qu'on appelle les publics empêchés
handicap et c'est donc avec des outils
spécifiques
et puis nous avons développé récemment
et donc on n'a pas encore suffisamment
de recul des aides sur des projets
portés par des bibliothèques autres
justement de en face et j'ai enfance et
jeunesse
et quand je vous entendez parler par
exemple de 2,2 lexandre dumas a raison
avec une dimension très jubilatoire on
sent que votre corps parle presque pour
le plaisir qu'a été le vôtre c'est en
cela que je dis qu'il faut jamais opposé
littérature contemporaine littérature
classique bijoux et jeu mais je pense
que la littérature jeunesse aujourd'hui
qui parlent plus directement aux jeunes
est un moyen aussi de les emmener vers
une littérature plus classiques on n'est
pas obligé d'attendre 50 pages pour pour
prendre du plaisir où on peut aussi se
préparer à être dans une situation de
tension et d'attention pendant cinquante
pages en attendant le plaisir le rapport
au temps court est une chose aussi que
la lecture permet peut-être d'éviter et
je dis pas qu'il faut pas avoir aussi un
rapport au temps court mais je pense
aussi qu'il faut qu'on arrive et la
lecture étant probablement la requis de
qui là qu'il invite le plus se cultiver
une forme de temps long pour soi par
moments ça me paraît et faire partie de
l' équilibre justement lorsque l'on
écrit vos romans marion boon est ce que
vous y pensez est ce que il y a
justement dans votre manière d'écrire
quelque chose qui relève je ne sais pas
de la pédagogie parce que peut-être que
l'on ne ferait pas de la pédagogie pour
des adultes mais on a envie de le faire
pour des adolescents j'espère que non en
tout cas je fais tout pour qu'il n'y en
ait pas et
parce que je crois moi personnellement
je trouve qu'il ya rien de deux pires
canton ligue d'avoir l'impression qu'on
veut nous faire penser quelque chose
donc je préfère essayé d'interroger de
poser des questions et de dan électeurs
à découvre les eaux l'histoire oui et
que la morale elle soit finalement aussi
celle que chacun en vie dit m après on
écrit avec ce qu'on est évidemment je
vais les histoires que j'écris le simple
choix de mes personnages du lieu du
contexte dit déjà quelque chose je
trouve que c'est déjà suffisant après et
puis elle aime la morale soit écrite en
gros ça me déplaît un petit peu fabrice
colin puisque vous parler par exemple de
grands personnages historiques édifiant
par les obama simone veil
oui mais les mois je suis d'accord avec
marion les faits parlent d'eux-mêmes de
toute façon dont on écrit d'une certaine
position on vient d'un endroit mais
ensuite si j'écris pour la jeunesse ce
mois c'est principalement pour le
plaisir de raconter des histoires de
d'emmener le lecteur soit dans des
mondes imaginaires soit dans des
dimensions psychologiques qui l'avait
pas encore exploré mais j'ai jamais
pensé en termes de voilà le message que
je voudrais faire passer maintenant il y
en a probablement on laisse aux lecteurs
normalement le soin de les découvrir et
de faire sa propre interprétation
originale jandaud il ya quand même un
obstacle auquel on est confronté
moi j'y suis confronté par exemple avec
ma fille que je salue donc alma c'est en
a peur d'être perçus comme une intello
et c'est un vrai souci pour elle et
je pense que même si elle dit ça
peut-être pour embêter son père elle le
dit aussi peut-être parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est pas toujours bien vue d'avoir un
livre vous montrez d'ailleurs de votre
étude ya une frontière nette entre le
collège et lycée à partir du nice et les
choses se compliquent oui même avant je
dirais que des choses se compliquent
après la cinquième en fait en tous les
cas 14 ans j'aurais que le livre
redeviennent à la mode
13 14 ans mais je pense que d'ailleurs
on le constate dans toutes les formes de
2-2-2 d'apprentissage par exemple dans
les conservatoires puisqu'il il dans une
vie précédente j'ai eu à m'occuper des
conservatoires de musique et du
spectacle vivant
les enfants commencent à l'achat ce
moment là on est dans cette situation
que vous décrivez très très bien de
l'adolescence où tout
toutes et toutes les premières fois
arrivent toutes les questions se posent
une première fois puis des dernières
fois où si je pense que c'est ça la en
l'occurrence voit la vie en vert plus
tôt
moi je crois pourquoi la rencontre en
revanche vous parliez tout à l'heure de
votre de du goût que vous avez pour
aller rencontrer les collégiens ou des
lycéens je suppose qu entre vous y étiez
combien il faut aussi ça je pense que
c'est une chose qu'il faut qu'on
développe énormément de la même manière
que les résidences d'auteurs
mon rêve c'est ce qui ce serait qu'il y
ait un auteur par par école par collège
par lycée là cette année
dans partir en livre on va tester pour
la première fois la présence d'auteurs
en dans les colonies de vacances avec
bien sûr un temps qui est que pour eux
pour leur travail
il s'agit pas de les transformer en le
médiateur culturel mais un temps aussi
où ils peuvent venir parler avec les
jeunes de leur travail de leur
participer éventuellement des ateliers
d'écriture je pense que le passage aussi
de l'écrit pour arriver à la lecture est
une chose très importante donc il ya
énormément d'initiatives à prendre et
puis il faut les rendre plus équilibrée
aussi à l'échelle de toute la france
parce que certaines régions sont
beaucoup plus développés que d'autres de
ce point de vue là et la présence
d'auteurs que comme vous l'êtes
aujourd'hui dans certains dans certains
établissements scolaires n'est pas
suffisamment systématique et la
rencontre est toujours un élément très
important tous les adolescents de 10 à
aller tous les adolescents disent que ça
changer leur regard
vive partir en livre on souhaite bon
vent à cette septième édition régine
hatchondo est l'occasion donc de lire de
bons livres frangine marion brunet aux
éditions j'ai lu et necropolis de
fabrice colin l'appel du sémaphore et
c'est chez nathan à très bientôt sur
public sénat
[Musique]
public sénat en partenariat avec france
culture et avec le soutien du centre
national du livre vous a présenté livres
et vous
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
fausse affaire pourrait laisser
centralise les écarts de responsabilité
tu a très peu changé tu le sais j'ai
réussi à détruire en pologne en
allemagne tous les documents
susceptibles de faire connaître un jour
mon identité
le camouflage est parfait nous sommes
réunis ici sous le regard de dieu
respect ce titre le temps défiler au
mieux pouvoir toucher aussi le type qui
étaient dans le même quart que vous mais
sa valise et rester là et n'a pas pris
ça va péter un tien
comment gérez vous avez changé de
costume
le criminel de et avec orson welles
samedi à 22h45 sur public sénat
[Musique]
non
si vous aimez
tél
mais qui
[Musique]
parce que moi
mais note de synthèse
[Musique]
à chaque vaccination c'est la vie qui
reprend faisons nous tous vaccinés
maintenant tous vaccinés tous protégés
dom dieux du stade louis cône du web
plus besoin de choisir mais ses prises
de parole en solo de nos héros pose
parfois des problèmes de communication
beaucoup plus politique qu'ils en ont
l'air ces sept semaines de racheter
hashtag ce soir à 22h sur public sénat
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans en
séance alors aujourd'hui programme
exceptionnel puisque nous allons revivre
deux auditions organisées par la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur les
dysfonctionnements observés dans la
distribution de la propagande électorale
lors des dernières sélections en
régionale une double audition de
représentants des sociétés de
distribution
adrexo eco bat global services regarder
du fait que nous avons les pouvoirs
d'une commission denquête vous êtes
amenés devant cette commission a juré de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
et toute la vérité
à défaut pour la forme je vous rappelle
qu'un faux témoignage peut engendrer des
poursuites pénales sur la base des
dispositions des articles 434-3 terry
14-15 du code pénal
ceci a rappelé monsieur fils viroulais
monsieur alain gueguen me suffire
viroulais je remercie de lever la main
droite de dire je le jure l'autre jour
je vous remercie et vous monsieur magri
yens je le jure je vous remercie
nous sommes dans le cadre venait
peut-être suivi les auditions que nous
avons menées déjà maintenant depuis
plusieurs jours et nous avons sommes
heureux de pouvoir vous recevoir vous
êtes les représentants du du syndicat
confédération autonome du travail des
personnels
adrexo et nous aimerions avoir votre
point de vue est votre avis sur la
situation que nous avons connue dans la
distribution des documents de propagande
qui ont été confiés à votre entreprise
et dont on a pu établir par témoignage
ou par constat dans les deux cas qu'un
certain nombre de documents dont il
reste à déterminer le volume dont nous
avons déjà une petite idée n'ont pas été
distribués parfois même abandonnées en
plein milieu de forêts brûlées pour
certains déposé
hall d'immeuble en tous les cas de façon
anormale n'ont pas été attribués à leurs
destinataires
nous avons auditionné vous le savez sans
doute évident les dirigeants de votre
entreprise nous a paru important d'avoir
votre point de vue car il nous a été
indiqué qu'il ya eu un préavis de grève
au sein de l'entreprise
nous aimerions connaître les raisons les
conditions et avoir votre regard sur la
manière dont les choses se sont passées
d'autres collègues ensuite vous
déposeront des questions bien évidemment
ils sont là pour ça mais peut-être dans
un premier temps vous vous laisser le
soin dans l'ordre que vous souhaitez de
nous donner votre avis sur la situation
oui monsieur le président messieurs
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs ont
effectivement je voulais d'abord vous
remercier de nous écouter aujourd'hui et
d'écouter les salariés d'adrexo qui
effectivement sont une partie importante
de l'entreprise puisque la distribution
des documents se fait grâce à eux
chaque semaine que ce soit pour les
imprimés publicitaires ou le courrier et
ils font en général un travail
remarquable avec des conditions
difficiles et ils produisent chaque
semaine un travail de qualité
nous sommes effectivement des
représentants syndicaux nous sommes
aujourd'hui nous représentons
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des salariés
d'adrexo nous faisons effectivement
partie de la confédération autonome du
travail qui est une confédération qui a
été créée en 1953
le syndicat d'entreprise existe depuis
2010 et il est le premier syndicat de
l'entreprise depuis 2020 en ce qui
concerne les salariés d'adrexo je
voulais en préambule
vous indiquez déjà qu'ils sont au nombre
de d'un peu plus de 15000 à fin 2020 que
58 % de ses distributeurs ont plus de 50
ans et 25% plus de 64 ans que ils ce
sont majoritairement des retraités et
des actifs est un tout petit peu
d'étudiants que ces retraités cherchent
un complément d'activité est un
complément de revenu et que les actifs
sont plus sur un complément de revenu
pour des gens qui sont soit à temps
plein par ailleurs soit à temps partiel
ses 15000 distributeur chez adrexo sont
tous pratiquement à temps partiel donc
il faut oui je crois oui d'accord
donc c'est quinze mille salariés sont
pratiquement tous à temps partiel et ce
qui équivaut à 6200 équivalents temps
plein en réalité dans l'entreprise 46%
de ses salariés ont un contrat qui va de
sentiers entre 7 et 12 heures par
semaine de travail et 16 % ont un
contrat inférieur à 7 heures 38 %
simplement un contrat supérieur à 12
heures donc nous sommes sur des contrats
vraiment qu'ils sont des compléments de
revenus et d'activités la moyenne
nationale des contrats pour adrexo est à
14 heures par semaine sur la zone qui
concernait la diffusion de la propagande
électorale puisque les 15000 donc le
distributeur dont je vous parlais sont
sur le plan national sur la zone qui
concernait la distribution de la
propagande électorale et qui avaient été
confiés adrexo fait environ 8000
distributeurs à temps partiel qui était
présent sur les territoires ça
correspond à 2006 en équivalent temps
plein c'est le distributeur cdi chez
adrexo sont très déçus et voir monteux
de du traitement qui a pu être fait
du travail qu'ils ont rendu puisque ces
gens sont habitués chaque semaine à
distribuer des secteurs des communes
connaissent bien leur secteur et ont
généralement très bien effectuer leur
mission les incidents que vous avez pu
noter comme des jets documents sont
anecdotiques en ce qui concerne les
salariés d'adrexo ce sont des gens qui
chaque semaine
distribuer de la publicité et c'est un
métier qui n'est pas facile qui
nécessite de marché de porter des poids
et qui en plus n'est pas très bien
rémunéré donc ce sont des métiers qui ne
sont pas faciles à exercer et
malheureusement sur cette opération de
la distribution de la propagande
électorale
au premier tour il n'y avait que deux
mille deux cents salariés qui étaient en
capacité de travailler pour cette
mission donc 2200 cdi donc d'adrexo
forme est habitué aux secteurs ont
travaillé pour le premier tour des
élections départementales et régionales
alors vous
il était pour information mais j'y
reviendrais 4000 pour le deuxième tour
des élections
vous parliez d'un préavis de grève qui
avait été déposé par notre syndicat
effectivement les raisons sont simples
c'est une entreprise
adrexo où le climat social est
extrêmement tendue il ya très peu de
place pour la négociation
à titre d'exemple en 2020 la direction a
convoqué les organisations syndicales à
des négociations quatre fois seulement
huit fois en 2018 12 fois en 2019 très
peu de respect des organisations
syndicales en général avec y compris
d'ailleurs notre syndicat qui a été
victime d'un véritable tir de barrage
dont il est devenu le premier syndicat
de l'entreprise avec plusieurs
manoeuvres qui ont été faites auprès à
la fois de notre confédération en
proposant ce que je pourrais dire entre
guillemets un don est également en
contestant en justice l'ensemble des
mandats syndicaux
il faut savoir également que le groupe
up se refuse depuis 2010 est à créer un
comité de groupe que nous n'avons eu
aucune négociation sur ce point depuis
2010 est qu'une seule fois avec soin a
signé un accord concernant les
négociations annuelles obligatoires en
2017 qui a octroyé 9 euros par mois une
centaine de salariés de l'entreprise
il n'y a donc jamais eu d'autres accords
de haine a aussi nié et enfin 83
nouveaux dossiers prud'homaux en 2020
135 en 2010 939 en 2018
vous voyez que sur ce point là nous
n'avions nous avons voulu attirer
l'attention en déposant ce préavis de
grève qui permettait aux distributeurs
qui n'aurait pas souhaité faire ces
travaux de ne pas le faire il a été
assez peu suivie par des gens qui
étaient en capacité de faire ce travail
puisque ils ont besoin de ces heures
supplémentaires et de ses revenus
supplémentaires pour améliorer leur
salaire qui avoisine les 450 euros par
mois en moyenne
mais ceux qui voulaient ne pas
distribuer pouvaient se référer à notre
préavis de grève en fait il faut savoir
que dans la gestion du courrier qui est
une activité d'adrexo les salariés ne
sont pas rémunérés du temps de tri de
ces courriers qui se fait à domicile ils
reçoivent des courriers ils doivent les
trier par rue par ordre dans la rue
ce temps n'est pas prise en charge par
l'entreprise c'est la revendication
principale qui nous avait conduit à
déposer ce prêt vitale ça ne concerne
pas spécifiquement je précise la
propagande électorale puisque là le
travail avait été fait en amont par les
routeurs et par les régies pour que ce
courrier arrive trier dans paru et par
ordre de rue donc il n'y avait pas de
temps de tri par les distributeurs
alors autre point important que l'on
doit porter à votre connaissance c'est
le turn over qui est présent dans cette
entreprise
quinze mille un peu plus de 15000
distributeurs 793 personnes en moyenne
quittent l'entreprise chaque mois et
dans 79 % des cas c'est pour une
démission ou une fin de période d'essai
ça veut dire que des nouveaux entrants
ne reste jamais très longtemps dans
l'entreprise et qu'il faut passer
énormément de candidats avant de
stabiliser quelqu'un sur un poste des
distributeurs principalement ces départs
sont du bien effectivement à une partie
des temps de travail qui ne sont pas
rémunérés le temps de tri du courrier le
temps les temps de trajets parfois
certains temps de distribution et puis
l'utilisation d'un véhicule personnel
avec également une prise en charge
partielle des conditions de travail
difficiles et un paiement au salaire
minimum voilà monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur je pense qu à avoir
répondu à votre première question
mais si je me suis ghislaine peut-être
voulu dire quelque chose ou à ce stade
non
je ne ferai que qu'appuyer vient dire
philippe pourrait rentrer dans les
détails bien évidemment oui mais je
dirais j'aime à grand chose à ajouter
sur ce tableau même bien madame kerman
ensuite oui merci messieurs pour votre
présentation d'une situation sociale
particulière on va dire dans
l'entreprise peut être bon sur la
situation plus spécifique de la
distribution de la propagande électorale
tout d'abord est ce que vous vous avez
eu des alertes de la part de salariés
qui finalement comment je vais le dire
n'y arrivait pas voilà ça c'est à dire
que la distribution appelé à dresser
était beaucoup trop compliqué il demande
est finalement tellement de difficultés
de contraintes pour pour y arriver que
que ça mettait une pression sur eux
mêmes énorme et
qu'en est-il au sein de l'entreprise sur
la prise en compte de ces difficultés
comment les salariés sont accompagnés
pour mieux exercer leur tâche et et
ainsi répondre à cette exigence assez
particulière tout de même puisqu'il ya
un enjeu de démocratie bien évidemment
derrière
n'évalue pas la rentabilité commerciale
comme on évalue la rentabilité
démocratique
donc voilà est-ce que y'a un moment
donné d une crise on compte spécifique
pour ces femmes et ces hommes qui
travaillent et qui pouvait ne pas y
arriver où trouver la tâche trop dur
même si de ce que vous nous avez dit si
j'ai bien compris les salariés étaient
exemptés de l'organisation de la tournée
qui était donc du coup fournis par ceux
qui mettaient sous plis par excusez moi
mais j'avais du coup une question
césaire que pour un salarié lambda ça
veut dire qu'ils avaient entre
guillemets ça tournait une tournée dite
traditionnelle qu'il peut avoir sur une
distribution de prospectus soit 2 je
suppose de noms de communes et/ou de rue
en zone plus plus dense
mais est ce qu'il y a quand même une
réflexion sur comment est-ce qu'on
organise une tournée pour que celle ci
soit rentable en matière de tâches
d'efforts et de temps consacré par le
salarié je vous remercie madame goulet
monsieur le rudulier monsieur kerrouche
oui merci monsieur le président j'aurais
plusieurs questions à vous poser la
première c'est sur la formation en règle
générale comme vient de le rappeler le
président puisque nous avons auditionné
les gens d'adrexo et puis les dirigeants
qui nous ont expliqué un peu la
formation moi j'ai plusieurs donc j'ai
une demande de précisions vous avez dit
les salariés d'adrexo connaissent bien
leur terrain est-ce que vous est ce que
vous seriez en des zones affectées est
ce que vous avez quadriller la france où
les zones qui vous ont été affectés par
l'appel d'offres est ce que vous aviez
donc déjà des salariés aura des
collègues qui travaillaient sur ces
endroits là est ce que ça a été
quadrillé est ce que est ce qu'il ya une
certaine connaissance puisque on a
entendu des choses assez terrifiante
tamment la formation géolocalisation par
rapport à une grande enseigne de vente
de meubles qui semble pas très courant
dans nos territoires ruraux dans ça nous
a un peu inquiété donc ça c'est la
première chose c'est sûr votre
implantation et la préparation en fait
de la tournée sergent à ce qu'elle dit
c'est cyclique hermans et le quadrillage
préalable la deuxième chose c'est est ce
que est ce que vos collègues ont
certains ou tous où un certain niveau
des relations avec les sous-traitants
parce que on a vu qu au fur et à mesure
je comprends que les salariés d'adrexo
été choqué de la mauvaise publicité
faite par cette opération mais la
réalité c'est que de sous traitants sous
traitants et de ce qu'on peut appeler de
l'ubs et risation de la fonction tous
assez éloignée manifestement de la
connaissance que vous indiquez du
terrain bon donc sk est ce que vous
aviez
lien est ce que c'est vous qui avez je
présume pas mis en place les modules de
formation est ce que vous avez en tout
les cas transmis votre savoir où votre
méthodologie ou es ce que vous avez été
twitter en quelque sorte à un moment ou
à un autre des sous traitants est ce que
vous en avez eu connaissance de même
qu'avec les syndicats des entreprises
sous-traitantes par exemple est ce que
vous avez eu des liens avec eux voilà
pour l'instant merci merci mais je suis
stéphanois rudulier oui merci monsieur
le président ma question sera donne dans
le prolongement de ma collègue
tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué le
nombre de 2000 salariés qui ont été
mobilisés pour le premier tour si j'ai
bien compris de ces élections sur les
quinze mille au total ce qui veut dire
qu'il ya une mobilisation quand même
assez faible par rapport à l'ensemble de
l'effectif
et est-ce que c'est cela qui a amené la
société adrexo à faire appel à de
l'intérim
pour combler ce déficit de main d'oeuvre
si j'ose dire par rapport à la
réalisation de cette prestation
ma deuxième question si j'ai bien
compris vous avez doublé le nombre de
salariés adrexo entre le premier et
second tour est-ce que c'était une
volonté de la part de la société de
peut-être corriger les effets néfastes
de la pelle excessif à l'intérim par
manque de formation ou autres parce que
on a pu vérifier que la qualité de la
prestation n'était pas au rendez vous
merci messieurs guerrouj est donc en
complément de ce qui vient d'être dit
vous nous avez mentionné au premier tour
que 2200 cdi formé était disponible si
je vous ai bien compris on parle de deux
cdi ou de tp combien ont été mis sur le
terrain en équivalent temps plein et
même question pour le second tour mon
collègue le rudulier parler d'eux
quatre mille personnes disponibles pour
le deuxième tour là aussi on parle de b2
de tp ou ou de cdi ou de contrats
d'intérim fin peu importe mais ça peut
simplement connaître la différence
ça veut dire que si vous avez fait cette
distinction
j'imagine que c'est parce qu'une grande
partie provient de pour le deuxième tour
provient de l'intérim est donc toujours
cette cette question de la formation
particulière la pince ta campagne en
faisant un an faisant faire des tours à
blanc entre guillemets de deux cdd gens
qui vont travailler sur le terrain est
ce que cette pratique vous ai connu ou
est-ce qu'on se contente des modules de
formation dans la direction d'adrexo
nous a parlé et puis plus
fondamentalement parce que vous ne
l'avez pas abordé directement
quels ont été selon vous les difficultés
de l'entreprise au deuxième tour comment
voulez qualifieriez comment vous
expliquer qu'on arrive à cette situation
et je ne parle pas uniquement pour pas
que je parle pas uniquement de la
situation d'attraction parce que d'une
certaine façon vous est à la confluence
de difficultés qui s'amoncellent mais
quelle est votre lecture en tant que
syndicat de la désorganisation qui avait
lieu au second tour concernant partie
des plis distribués par votre par votre
société
merci interventions mais vous avez la
parole
ainsi choisi leur jeu par rapport à la
formation d'un point qui est important
effectivement en temps normal et sur la
distribution de la publicité
la société dispose de distributeurs
formateur qui sont en capacité
d'accompagner les nouveaux entrants de
les former
à la lecture d'un plan à la préparation
des documents et ensuite sur le terrain
à la distribution en accompagnant les
débuts de distribution ce dispositif
n'était pas en place pour la
distribution de la propagande électorale
et les personnes qui ont été engagés
sous forme de contrats d'intérim n'ont
bénéficié que d'une visualisation d'une
vidéo qui a été diffusée par certains
prestataires d'intérim et d'une
formation ensuite sur les sites où
étaient stockées les imprimés d'environ
une heure sur la façon dont il fallait
appréhender la tournée avec une remise
d'un plan et quelques explications sur
les modalités de distribution donc pas
d'accompagnement pour les intérimaires
en revanche sur les cdi
ces personnes étaient la plupart du
temps affecté à leurs tournées
habituelles donc était déjà formée sur
la distribution
adrexo distribuer des courriers chaque
semaine et koné ils connaissent donc les
rues ils connaissent leur secteur et
surfer cdi qui était effectivement au
nombre de 2200 2200 individus environ
800 équivalents temps plein et 4000 au
deuxième tour environ 1200 1300
équivalents temps plein ces gens là
n'ont pas eu de soucis pour distribuer
les plis électoraux dont ils ont ils se
poser puisque ils connaissent bien leur
secteur et que ça leur posait pas de
problème est que c'était un travail
supplémentaire qu'il se faisait en solo
donc une tournée dédiée à la
distribution de la propagande électorale
qui se faisait peut-être en fin de
semaine alors qu'ils avaient en début de
semaine distribuer leur publicité sur
ces cds il a pas de souci de formation
puisqu'ils ont des zones affectées
on appelle
cela la fidélisation au sens de la
convention collective de la distribution
directe et donc ces personnes là n'ont
pas rencontré de difficulté
supplémentaire par rapport à l'habitude
quant à la mobilisation des salariés qui
paraît faible
elle est effectivement assez limité mais
pour des raisons qui tiennent au fait
que les salariés sont à temps partiel et
qui l'ont parfois et souvent même un
emploi ailleurs pour compléter ce temps
partiel chez adrexo et s'ils n'ont pas
donc la liberté de travailler un jour
deux jours ou trois jours
supplémentaires parce qu'ils sont
occupés sur un autre emploi il faut
savoir que quand on a un contrat de sept
heures par exemple ça peut tout à fait
se cumuler avec 1 35 heures et qu'on
fait ça en deux soirées trois soirées la
préparation se fait à domicile donc on
le fait quand on a un peu de temps le
week-end par exemple
et puis on fait deux soirées de
distribution et on a fait son secteur
pour quelqu'un qui à 6 700 boîtes aux
lettres à distribuer c'est tout à fait
possible
donc ces gens là par exemple ne pouvait
pas se mobiliser sur la distribution
électoral puisqu'il était occupé sur
d'autres d'autres activités pourquoi le
nombre des cdi a augmenté entre le
premier et second tour c'est que la
société adrexo effectivement à sollicite
énormément de candidats cdi
d'autres régions qui n'étaient pas
concernés par la distribution au départ
qui ont été déplacés avec mise à
disposition d'hôtel etc vers des régions
qui avaient besoin de personnel
effectivement le le vrai problème pour
7 la dernière question qui était posée
sur notre lecture des motifs qui ont pu
engendrer ces dysfonctionnements premier
tour de 1200 personnes
là je pense qu'effectivement ces deux
mille deux cents individus cdi n'ont pas
eu de problème pour la distribution et
la distribution s'est passé tout à fait
correctement
par contre il y avait 4000 intérimaires
sur un besoin qui avait été exprimée au
départ de 18000 personnes au total donc
on était à 6200 personnes en fait entre
les cdi et les intérimaires recrutés
c'était clairement insuffisant par
rapport au nombre de personnes
il faut savoir sur les 4000 salariés
intérimaires 1500 abandonné la 1re
journée de travail au premier tour au
premier tour sur 4000 personnes en
intérim mille 500 abandonnait dès le
premier jour dès le premier jour donc il
ya eu effectivement un nombre
d'intérimaires qui descendu d'un seul
coup des gens à qui sont partis avec un
coffre plein d' enveloppe sur un secteur
qu'il ne connaissait pas faire un métier
qu'il ne connaissait pas avec une
formation qui a duré environ une heure
donc effectivement ces gens là se sont
senti totalement perdus sur des sur des
endroits
et quand on sait quand on a distribué ne
serait ce que des prospectus dans les
boîtes aux lettres on sait que c'est pas
spécialement facile qu'il faut s'y tenir
et que c'est pas c'est pas évident au
deuxième tour la situation était très
différente et d'un autre point de vue
n'a pas poser autant de problèmes qu'au
premier tour
le vrai dysfonctionnements que notre
lecture du moins de 2 ce qui s'est passé
c'est que le dysfonctionnement a été
plutôt au premier tour qu'au second au
second les choses ont été très vite et
il ya d'autres problèmes qui sont
arrivés les routeurs les imprimeurs un
bon toute la chaîne amont et les
livraisons qui ont pu poser des
problèmes mais
là avec sow disposait de quatre mille
personnes en cdi des gens alors certes
qu'il ne connaissait pas qu'ils étaient
venus d'autres régions qui ne
connaissaient pas forcément les secteurs
nikon connaissait le métier et donc il
n'était pas totalement perdu quand ils
sont arrivés sur ces secteurs là et il
ya eu onze mille intérimaires recrutés
pour le deuxième tour
trois mille ont abandonné dans la
première journée mais le dispositif
était quand même beaucoup plus important
pourtant il y avait moins de plis il y
avait moins de plis effectivement et des
plis qui sont arrivés parfois
tardivement en dehors des limites
prévues ont quand même parfois été pris
en charge par les équipes mais il y
avait il y avait effectivement beaucoup
plus de monde à disposition
merci mike ehrmann plus même couleur ou
et une première question sur la façon de
travailler compris au vu de ce que vous
venez de nous exposer sur comment chacun
entre guillemets s'organisent pour pour
sa distribution pour les zones
principalement urbaine qui sont
concernés pas seulement par des fois des
interphones mais des codes des badges
d'accès etc
comment ça se passe et notamment alors
mon option a tourné à dire avec des gens
peut-être plus fidéliser mais celles qui
ont été utilisées par tous les
intérimaires et vous nous dites donc
1500 démission dès le premier jour pour
le premier tour 3000 pour le deuxième
tour ce sont des démissions qui sont pas
liés par d'autres embauches dans la
foulée ou in fine et ce sont autant de
gens disponibles en moins pour assurer
la bonne distribution dans les secteurs
concernés
merci madame boulet moi j'ai aussi bien
retenu les le nombre de démissions la
première journée est-ce que c'est
simplement parce que les gens étaient
dépassés par la tâche
et est ce que vous êtes et qu'est-il
advenu des documents qui les avait pas
ce que est ce qui vous les ont ramenés
par exemple merci monsieur mais suis pas
moi j'ai un complément de questions vous
évoquez tout à l'heure le nombre de 18
mille personnes se faire ma part c'est
la première fois que j'entends ce nombre
je voudrais d'abord avoir des précisions
sur danger j'ai évoqué le nombre de un
peu plus de 15000 personnes
distributeurs quinze mille quatre cents
exactement à fin 2020 mais le besoin
vous l'aviez dans le lieu zouaoui pardon
c'est dire ça et le besoin exprimé par
l'entreprise en interne avait été
exprimée sur la base de 18 mille
personnes en ce qui concerne la la
distribution adrexo dispose d'une
licence postale et à ce titre dispose
des badges électroniques et des clés que
l'on appelle un passe ptt pour pouvoir
accéder aux immeubles et au moins au
saas qui contiennent les boîtes aux
lettres
donc il n'ya pas de poser de problème
pour cet accès est la société avait mis
à disposition des salariés
le matériel nécessaire pour pouvoir
disposer de ces badges et ses clés en
nombre suffisant y compris pour les gens
qui étaient recrutés en intérim qui
avaient ce matériel quant à la question
sur l'airé embauches après les abandons
je n'ai pas cette information
je n'ai que le total des salariés qui
ont été recrutés donc 4000 en intérim et
1500 abandon
mais je n'ai je ne sais pas si alors il
ya eu des embauches mais probablement
effectivement les réseaux d'entreprise
de travail temporaires ont été
sollicités en continu pour fournir tout
au long de l'opération de salariés et
éventuellement de nouveaux ça lag sur le
le retour des documents pour ces gens
qui ont abandonné oui dans la formation
qui avait été mise en place cette
formation d'environ une heure il avait
été indiqué qu' il fallait donner une
importance particulière à la valeur des
documents qui étaient distribués et que
si d'aventuré le salarié souhaitait
arrêter que il rapporte les documents
puisqu'il était obligé de déposer un
rapport indiquant le nombre d'heures
travaillées et le nombre de kilomètres
qu'ils avaient effectué pour faire ce
travail
donc il avait la nécessité de revenir de
déposer ce rapport est de rendre les
documents qui n'avaient pas distribuer
éventuellement en indiquant sur le plan
la partie qu'il avait distribué donc là
dessus à notre connaissance il n'y a pas
eu de souci il était possible de
réaffecter un salarié pour poursuivre
une distribution qui avait été
interrompue mais mme boulet oui monsieur
le président si c'était possible d'avoir
une copie des contrats qui sont donnés
aux salariés éventuellement des notes de
service
ça nous permettrait d'avoir peut-être
une idée plus précise merci beaucoup
bien y at il d'autres questions
une question un peu plus délicate mais
pensez vous que l'organisation prévu par
l'entreprise a été à la hauteur des
enjeux
le contraire
non on va vous attendre je le seul fait
de notre présence ici dans une partie de
la réponse non l'entreprise ne pas je
dirais voilà su anticiper et construire
la réponse attendue
bien sûr dans le prolongement est ce que
le personnel qui était qui devait
remplir cette mission au-delà du fait
gentiment convaincus qu'ils voulaient
faire la mise et remplir la mission
parfaitement avait conscience de la
différence de l'enjeu de ces
distributions par rapport à ce qui est
fait habituellement à savoir qu
habituellement jeu simplifié à outrance
on distribue des documents publicitaires
en toutes boîtes ya pas d adresses y à
rien ou alentour boîte et là on est sur
une distribution d'un courrier adressé à
vocation électorale c'est à dire
vraiment dans l'exercice le plus absolu
du système démocratique est ce que
c'était une avait conscience de cet
enjeu là ou pas du tout sur le terrain
je crois qu'il y avait une réelle
conscience dans les agences
qu'effectivement c'était cette opération
appelée propaganda en interne était
essentiel pour l'image adrexo prêts
effectivement on n'avait aucune
responsabilité sur la mise en oeuvre de
toutes les solutions ou des critères à
la réflexion c'est une mission que vous
souhaiteriez continue en tant que
salarié j'entends je pense qu'en tout
cas les salariés envie de faire leurs
preuves
petit de questions je regarde oui
monsieur les rouges comment vous
établissez les moyennes de distribution
il ya un an moyen de deux boîtes aux
lettres par heure par face j'imagine que
ça dépend du rural au dur goodell
urbania vous avez une une trame à peu
près temporel de ce que ça peut donner
en fonction de la distribution oui alors
la distribution a évolué ces dernières
années notamment un petit peu avant la
reprise par les actionnaires actuels de
la société adrexo puisque la convention
collective prévoyait auparavant une pré
quantification du temps de travail
cette pré quantification et est calculé
en fonction du nombre de boîtes aux
lettres de la difficulté du secteur de
les différents paramètres du poids des
documents également etc est ce ce temps
près quantifier a été a fait l'objet de
deux annulations par le conseil d'état
ce qui le rendait inapplicable à la
société adrexo qui un peu avant la
session a négocié un accord d'entreprise
mettait en place un système de badges 2
qui permet de mesurer le temps de
travail est également de localiser le
salarié non pas en temps réel mais à la
fin de sa distribution les données sont
envoyées à l'entreprise qui place six
vérifier le temps de travail est
également la qualité du travail et que
ce travail a été réalisé sur le secteur
prévu pour cette mission de distribution
lorsqu'il y à du courrier le courrier
est distribué simultanément aux plis
publie au pli pour faire aux documents
publicitaires et donc le distributeur
passe devant une boîte aux lettres la
badgeuse lui signale qu'il a un pli
adressé à m -dans une adresse à
proximité et finalement il met la
publicité et il fait un geste
supplémentaire en mettant un courrier au
passage ce n'était pas le cas pour la
propagande électorale puisque c'était
une tournée dédiée il aurait été tout à
fait impossible d'avoir autant de
documents en même temps que la publicité
à distribuer et en ce qui concerne la
rémunération donc c'est normalement
cette badgeuse qui prend en compte la
réalité du temps passé sur le secteur de
distribution et qui donc génère une
rémunération ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant avec l'attrait quantification
quelques quelques soucis encore dans la
mise en oeuvre de cet accord
d'entreprise puisqu'à l'arrivée des
actionnaires actuels
il a été mis en place un certain nombre
de dispositifs qui replace le salarié
dans la position d'être payé autant prêt
quantifié par exemple s'ils utilisent
mal ça badgeuse si elle ne fonctionne
pas et puis aussi un dispositif qui
permet de bloquer le temps de travail
c'est le fameux temps max que nous
critiquons depuis sa mise en oeuvre et
qui bloque le travail du salarié à un
certain temps déterminé comme étant le
temps de référence qu'il ne faut pas
dépasser et à ce moment là le salarié
dispose d'un code qu'il doit taper pour
débloquer la badgeuse si le manager lui
en a donné un
s'il n'a pas donné ils cessent de
travailler il rentre il rentre chez lui
sera rémunéré sur la base du temps max
temps max a été appliquée pour la
distribution de leurs règles électorales
non l'application l'application sur la
badgeuse pour la propagande électorale
qui d'ailleurs permettait cette fois une
géolocalisation des salariés en temps
réel
contrairement à l'application classique
de mesure du temps de travail
cette application ne comportait pas de
cas page du temps nécessaire à la
distribution donc le salarié pouvait
aller au bout de sa tournée sans avoir à
générer un code ou à débloquer sa
batteuse
[Musique]
j'habitais un peu de mal bien entendu je
ne connais pas précisément le poste de
travail que vous décrivez vous le
décrivez bien mais j'ai
j'ai du mal à l'imaginer totalement et
donc la question que je me pose c'est
pour le salarié
qui est en train de distribuer en fait
est ce que dans la réalité de l'es6 dos
que représente pour lui cette
distribution il va se retrouver avec un
travail qui pour une quantité de travail
équivalente va lui amener un revenu
identique supérieure ou inférieure à une
distribution traditionnelle tenant
compte du fait que là il a décoré à
distribuer précisément à des gens qui
ont fait des personnes définies je ne
vois pas au fait je n'arrive pas à voir
précisément quelle est la répercussion
de ce travail sur la rémunération du
salarié pour un travail identique en
temps c'est un peu la question que je
voulais vous poser parce que c'est il ya
eu beaucoup quand même de deux
défaillances la première journée elles
peuvent s'expliquer par des tas de
raisons en général les gens qui
trahissaient attractions que j'ai connu
c'est parce qu' au bout de 24 heures ils
comprennent que le rapport entre ce
qu'ils vont gagner et est ce que ça leur
coûtait particulièrement défavorable
pour même clique herrmann oui j'avais
une question vous nous avez donné le
ratio entre le nombre de cdi dans
l'entreprise
et finalement le faible nombre qu'ils
ont fait c'est tourné là pour les
raisons y compris que vous avez évoqué
liés pour beaucoup d'incompatibilité
avec une autre
notre fonction par ailleurs à partir de
quand ce recensement a t-il eu lieu dans
l'entreprise est ce que chaque salarié a
été contacté pendant qu'elle conçoit
d'ailleurs la voix mais pour savoir s'il
était intéressé ou pas intéressés est ce
qu'il ya eu des négociations vont très
particulière sur des prises en charges
de compensation ou de salaire pour
pouvoir s'assurer que le plus de
personnes déjà cédé puisse faire ses
missions
donc voilà j'ai envie de vous dire un
peu comment et surtout à quelle date
l'entreprise en interne fait ce
recensement auprès des salariés pour
ensuite pouvoir effectivement estimé le
manque à gagner humain et ainsi pallier
part de l'intérim les personnels mon
camp merci monsieur
enfin madame boulet pardon excusez moi
même me suis empressé président mais
c'est au fur et à mesure de l'audition
qu'on compense oui en tant que délégué
enfin avec le comité d'entreprise vous
devez avoir évidemment le bilan
économique
enfin le bilan de l'entreprise est-ce
que vous avez une connaissance de
difficultés financières ou 2 2
comment dire de rémunérations
disproportionnées à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise qui aurait pénalisé a juste
équilibre juste rémunération de certains
de vos salariés
merci monsieur le président sion et
revenir quelques instants sur sur la
formation tout à l'heure vous vous nous
indiquer si je ne fais pas d'erreur que
ça comprenez en fait deux temps une
diffusion d'une vidéo
alors je ne sais pas de combien de temps
dure cette vidéo est derrière ça une
mise une mise en pratique d'une heure de
formation plus tôt plutôt pratique
est ce que pour vous cette formation
s'est avérée suffisante sachant que
effectivement c'est de la distribution
adressée donc c'est quand même assez
particulier et si on compare avec le
groupe la poste où vous aviez déjà trois
quatre heures de formation pratique plus
deux jours véritablement de tourner avec
le facteur qui avaient l'habitude de
pratiquer le secteur est-ce que
clairement ça vous apparaît suffisant ou
largement insuffisant et ça pourrait
aussi expliquer les défaillances dans la
distribution ce qui concerne l'impact
sur la rémunération il est important
puisque quelqu'un qui fait une tournée
de distribution publicitaire habituel de
madère
va à peu près avoir le même salaire
chaque semaine 6 il fait le même secteur
s'est il a l'habitude de le faire
il sait comment le distribuer il
connaissait point de stationnement etc
donc c'est ce temps est à peu près
toujours le même et donc quelqu'un qui
va avoir une tournée dédiée courriers
supplémentaires va se voir ajouter à son
salaire le temps alors là en
l'occurrence puisque le temps n'était
pas limité le temps réel qu'il va passer
à distribuer ses plis s'il passe ce
qu'ils y passent 10 heures il aura sur
cette semaine la deezer de rémunération
supplémentaire donc ça se traduit
immédiatement sur le bulletin de salaire
par des heures supplémentaires
donc l'impact l'impact et efforts
puisque ronny vraiment sûr de tournée
dédiée donc complètement différente et
inhabituelle pour nos collègues sur le
terrain pour le recensement des besoins
et notamment le recensement des
personnes qui a allait être disponible
il a commencé dès le mois de février à
ma connaissance il a été fait au moins 2
mois enfin terminer au moins deux mois
avant l'opération de distribution pour
connaître les personnes qui allaient
être en capacité de participer et de
prévoir avec eux les secteurs qui
allaient leur être affecté certains
distributeurs n'ont pas pu prendre tous
les secteurs qu'ils font habituellement
en publicité parce que cette opération
prenait beaucoup de temps et il ne
pouvait nous faire par exemple qu'un
secteur sur deux est le deuxième secteur
donc l'été confié à une autre personne
et tout ce recensement a été terminé
deux mois environ après avant
l'opération de distribution a commencé
oui pour la vidéo qui durait cinq
minutes
c'était vraiment une vidéo très très
pratique quand vous voyez quelqu'un a
distribué des plis vraiment quelque
chose de très très synthétique est ce
que cette formation vidéo plus sept
heures de formation a été suffisante
à notre avis non le dispositif qui est
mis en place pour accompagner les
distributeurs de publicité nouvel
entrant par les distributeurs formateur
est un moyen qui est mis au service des
agences pour limiter le turnover ce
dispositif d'accompagnement clairement
n'a pas été mis en place pour la
propagande électorale et a énormément
manqué le l'accompagnement sur le
terrain permet de rassurer les
distributeurs de l'assister un petit peu
au début de sa distribution de lui
montrer quelques gestes quelques
méthodes et à notre avis il était
nécessaire de prévoir cet accompagnement
peut être en amont formant sur la base
de salariés également intérimaire mais
formés spécifiquement à l'accompagnement
des des collègues soit la comparaison
avec nos collègues de la poste un peu
difficile parce que encore une fois
adrexo et s'appuie sur un modèle
économique
tina
des salades des salariés de quatre ans
partiel sur nos collègues de la poste se
sont pratiquement que des temps pleins
et donc c'est très très différents et on
peut difficilement comparer un
accompagnement de deux jours par exemple
sur sur un temps plein à un salarié qui
va travailler pour une entreprise pour
dix ou quinze heures par semaine goulet
oui monsieur vous venez bien deux
collègues de la poste et ses trésors
vous considérez vous fait le même métier
de plus en plus parce que l'activité
distribution publicitaire n'était pas
spécifiquement en concurrence avec la
poste autrefois c'était plutôt une
filiale de la poste qui opérait pour la
publicité
maintenant cette filiale de la poste
opère plus en milieu urbain et sous
traite à la poste n'a plus beaucoup les
zones rurales ce que ce que fait
également adrexo d'ailleurs de plus en
plus à la rixe au sous traite à la poste
en zone rurale donc c'est aussi et donc
le courrier qui est venu s'ajouter en
2017 2018
l'activité de l'entreprise fait que le
salarié fait un travail qui est un peu
comparable à ce que peut faire un
facteur même si le volume de courrier
n'est pas le même c'est aussi aussi pour
nous un point de valorisation du métier
l'importance d'un courrier nominatif
adressé permet aussi aux salariés
d'adrexo de se considérer comme étant un
vrai porteur d'un message au delà de la
publicité et cette activité courrier est
aussi un moyen de valoriser les emplois
c'était effectivement quelque chose
d'intéressant on vous a pas répondu sur
l'aspect économique
c'est alain qui voulait avant que vous
répondez à cette question je vais à
compléter si vous me permettez
dans un article du monde que l'on a lu
récemment il est indiqué que les
dirigeants de la société aurait
volontairement ou délibérément affaiblir
les finances du groupe alex auld
adrexo au profit des résultats de colis
privé c'est quelque chose avant l'entrée
en bourse de cette dernière société
d'ailleurs vous avez un point de vue là
dessus on a un point de vue puisque
adrexo fait partie d'amour qui co op
synchro ça a été créé en 2010 est alors
même où adriq sow était repris puisque
adrexo a été repris avec une soulte de
l'ordre de 65 millions plus le siège
d'une valeur d'une vingtaine de millions
cette entreprise était parfaitement
connue des repreneurs actuelle puisque
ils avaient l'un et l'autre étaient soit
directeur général d'adrexo et adrexo
colis donc entre 2008 et et 2012 et à ce
moment là la filiale adrexo colis elle
s'appelait comme ça à l'époque avaient
été sortis d'adrexo avec une soute de 50
millions
donc effectivement ce le groupe se
reconstitue en 2017 avec les mêmes les
actionnaires actuels et ensuite
effectivement il ne s'agit que de soi
stratégique
oui nos experts comptables au cs nous
ont bien mis le doigt sur les
déséquilibres qu'il y avait entre les
factures les liens entre adrexo colis et
colis privé il y avait quelques redire
quelques anomalies donc
donc il ya des vrais choix stratégiques
qui sont faits nous on est convaincu
cadre xo peut être une entreprise
d'avenir puisque
effectivement c'est la capacité à
couvrir le dernier m donc avec de la
publicité avec du courrier adressé avec
des petits colis avec bien d'autres
choses à l'ère d'internet c'est une
vraie valeur ajoutée
c'est aussi ou pensent nos afrique sous
une vraie alternative à un monopole
celui de la poste un deux-roues clé je
vais pas ici décrire ce cas nous
monopole mais donc on pense qu'à taxe
aux havrais à venir ces dirigeants font
ce qu'ils sont en train d'enfer mais mme
goulet vous avez la réponse
pour convient bien je constate y'a pas
d'autres questions
il n'aurait spéciaux à vous remercier
d'être venu jusque là et des réponses
que vous avez apporté à nos questions et
donc nous devons la séance merci à vous
nous sommes heureux le représentant du
notte familiale et entrepreneuriale
française qui fait le travail sur les
élections depuis six ans maintenant
donc ce n'était pas un coup d'essai
c'est un une expertise qui a été
développée depuis ces dernières années
et pour vous donner à peu près le poids
que cela représente dans notre société
c'est cette année à peu près 3 5
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
sur un total de 120 millions donc un
petit peu moins de 2 3%
nous avons opéré cette année pour le
compte de la région normandie les
départements de la seine et marne seine
maritime pardon de l'heure et de l'orne
pour 870000 plis 430 milles et 205 me
respectivement pour l'île de france le
département 77 et 95 et pour la région
bourgogne franche comté le 58 et 71 donc
voilà les marchés dont nous étions
titulaire pour les élections
départementales et régionales sur un
volume de plis à peu près équivalent à
celui que nous avions pris lors des
élections précédentes ni plus ni moins
peut-être important de préciser que nous
avons été en situation de devoir dire
non à des sollicitations de préfecture
qui nous ont sollicités pour que nous
puissions prendre des volumes
supplémentaires mais la configuration de
l'élection ne nous permettait pas d'en
prendre plus donc nous sommes restés à
is the volume
nous déposons chaque année 1 milliards
de plis dans nos usines
donc nous avions trois millions sept
cent mille électeurs ce qui fait à peu
près 3 8 millions 7 x 2 élections x 2
tours une quinzaine de millions de plis
le chiffre est donc très petit par
rapport à la somme globale des volumes
que nous avons néanmoins concentrée sur
une période extrêmement petit pied le la
criticité de l'opération vous dire juste
en préambule que le la discussion se
porte sur le deuxième tour pour nous et
de la régionale puisque le premier tour
était fini largement en avance et pour
avoir partagé avec un certain nombre de
concerts je précise que nous sommes sur
des volumes très inférieur vous l'avez
rappelé à notre confrère koba kiki qui
parlera juste après mais l'enjeu n'a pas
été le premier tour nous l'avons fini
avec plusieurs jours d'avancé la
départementale a été fini avec cinq six
jours d'avancé la régionale avec trois
jours d'avancé au premier tour
par contre c'est au 2e tour que se sont
cristallisées
un petit peu plus les soucis bien que
grâce à l'ensemble des soupapes de
sécurité des réserves que nous avions
prévu dans le groupe diffusion plus nous
avons produit est déposé en temps et en
heure 98 % des volumes qui nous étaient
confiées au deuxième tour 100% lié à un
transport non prévue qui était lié à
l'activation d'un pca entre nos deux
sites mais voilà vous dire que sur le
premier tour ya pas eu de soucis et nous
avons produit déposer l'ensemble de la
propagande qui nous étaient qui nous
étaient confiées néanmoins nous avons
constaté comme l'ensemble de la
profession de la filière des difficultés
une complexité que nous avions avec vous
même au mois de décembre en commission
sénatoriale évoqué puisque nous nous
étions fait le porte parole très fort de
demander un délai supplémentaire dans le
cas d'un double scrutin
mais à cette complexité du double
scrutin se sont ajoutés d'autres
complexités liées au temps de séchage
des documents liés à l'hydrométrie de la
période de production à laquelle nous
avons dû produire liées à la période qui
était qui était pas facile mais nous y
reviendrons certainement pour vous
apporter des réponses détaillées dans le
cadre de cette audition
bonjour à tous bonjour à tous
monsieur le président madame des
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
bon je vais me concentrer principalement
sur les élections parler mon entreprise
on est là depuis 40 ans ont droit à une
belle entreprise mais je vais me
traînant vous donner un petit peu ce qui
s'est passé donc nous nous faisons les
élections depuis plus de 25 ans je pense
que c'est important de le préciser
on a démarré avec la seine maritime en
95 avec 200 milles plus nous produisons
aujourd'hui entre 15 et 25 millions
d'électeurs par tour d'élection sur un
process 100% industriel nous sommes
dimensionnés industriellement pour
répondre aux marchés qu'ils nous ont été
notifiés néanmoins à l'inversé de deux
de nos collègues diffusion plus nous
n'avons pas de capacités machine
complémentaires pour doubler notre
capacité sur un deuxième tour d'une
double élection c'est un sujet sur
lequel nous reviendrons plus tard
d'autant plus sur 36 heures pour vous
donner l'ordre de grandeur des volumes
sur le deuxième tour nous avons nous
avions 32 millions 116500 29000 cli un
peu moins de 33 millions sur le premier
tour
nous avons produit sur ce premier tour
100% des prix sans incidence aucune donc
le sujet se portent principalement sur
le deuxième tour sur ces 32 millions
nous avions une répartition de 14
millions un peu plus de 14 millions à
jouer pour vous donner après des
chiffres précis si vous le souhaitez
82 74 fois mon bref et 17 millions de
régionales
nous avions 35 préfecture qui sont
clientes de chez clo bas nous avions
plus une ville en sous traitance nous
avons produit c'est important 642 canton
dont 698 au premier tour nous sommes
titulaires de marchés dans cinq régions
l'ile-de-france auvergne rhône-alpes
paca nouvelle aquitaine et une partie de
l'os italie et on oublie souvent nous
produisons si les bulletins de vote les
colis des bulletins de vote qui vont
mairie qui ont représenté 9445 comme une
fois des départementales et bien sûr
régionale au niveau des moyens de
production comme aa2 site de production
historique avec sont basés à creil à
bordeaux et à chaque élection nous
montons ce qu'on appelle chez nous
vulgairement un site éphémère qui est
basé en rhône alpes
historiquement souvent à lyon va
toujours d'ailleurs à lyon et pour
répondre à ce double scrutin
vu la difficulté de ces fameux 36 heures
sur le cas on débattra plus tard nous
avons pris le parti de monter 27
cellules réparties sur l'ensemble du
territoire où nous sommes concernés par
nos régions dans des lieux assez
inhabituel pour une entreprise comme la
nôtre puisque nous étions à l'aréna de
daix par exemple on a eu des salles de
spectacle on a eu l'air au port de nice
le t1 des parcs des expositions des
grands palais donc c'est l'un des
endroits assez majestueux pour produire
et la répartition s'est faite par
rapport à nos volumétrie c'est à dire
trois sites au fou 3 cellules on parle
de cellules pour nous autres dans l'oise
7 en région rhône alpes auvergne ronald
six en région paca neuf ans nous l
aquitaine et deux en occitanie
on pourra parler peut-être je sais pas
si vous le souhaitez tout de suite des
moyens techniques et humains que nous
avons globalement je l' ai dit en
préambule cobas et avant tout une usine
enfin des usines donc du matériel avec
50,2 assembleuse 41 matériel de mise
sous pli ou demi sous film et pour
répondre à ce complément de deuxième
tour qui représente globalement 17
millions supplémentaires nous avons
ouvert nos fameuses 27 cellule
représentant 2540 table puisque ce sont
des cellules manuel donc avec une mise
sous pli et mis sous pli par nos manuels
tel qu'on l'a fait historiquement dans
toutes les préfectures et préfectures
depuis la nuit des temps depuis que des
élections il existe au niveau du
personnel 8500 personnes ont été
mobilisées pour ce deuxième tour
voilà ce que j'ai à dire merci merci
monsieur
ils étaient les questions
on a construit chez les rouges
excusez-moi dead un peu direct ça doit
être le matin mais j'ai bien entendu
votre exposé donc en revanche que j'ai
pas compris c'est d'où viennent les
problèmes
quelles ont été les difficultés qu'est
ce qui s'est passé c'est aussi simple
que ça en ce qui me concerne monsieur le
régulier oui merci monsieur le président
effectivement pour rebondir par rapport
à l'intervention du sénateur kerrouche
on parle de deux millions deux pays qui
n'ont pas été distribués on aimerait
savoir et connaître les la chaîne de
responsabilités il n'y a pas un acteur
responsable de tous les
dysfonctionnements pour vous d'après les
retours que vous avez de cette
expérience qu'elle serait en fait le
pourcentage ou le nombre de plis non
distribués lio fait de
dysfonctionnements qui viennent de votre
de votre chaîne je compléterai la
question qui vous est posée à la date à
laquelle on vous avait demandé de livrer
les plis au distributeur
avez vous pu remplir déjà l'ensemble de
cette mission qui vous vient ce qui vous
incombent à espérer que toute l'année la
mise sous pli était faite quelques
heures près
dans les délais si oui bon tout ça il
n'y a pas de difficulté sinon quel était
le délai supplémentaire nécessaire et si
au pire des choses vous n'avez pas pu le
faire
pour quelle raison ne pas ne vous n'avez
pas pu le faire madame boyer et monsieur
le président je voudrais savoir dans
votre activité si vous avez eu à faire
vous même à la sous traitance quelle est
la proportion de la sous traitance dans
votre activité pour quel type de tâche
c'est ma première question sur la
sous-traitance et par rapport à cette
sous traitant si vous avez eu recours à
l
combien de temps vous avez consacré à la
formation de ses sous-traitants est ce
que ce sont des sous traitants avec
lesquels vous avez l'habitude de
travailler
et comment vous vérifier la qualité de
ses sous-traitants
merci papa d'autres questions je vais le
faire
oui je vais reprendre les questions dans
l'ordre benjamin tu complétera si si
besoin
donc en ce qui nous concerne groupe
diffusion plus
nous avons géré avec nos interlocuteurs
des préfectures et du ministère tout le
délai supplémentaire que nous pouvions
avoir pour pouvoir déposer les flics
dans le cadre qui nous étaient
autorisées dans ce cadre autorisé nous
avons fini 98 % de la production le
vendredi midi et 100 % à 14 heures avec
une navette qui a dû traverser paris
parce que nous avions un site de pca que
nous avions repris mais le site de paix
ça ne pouvait pas être collectées donc
il a fallu mais nous avons pour le
groupe diffusion plus un j'entends donc
pour trois les trois millions sept cent
mille électeurs avec le délai
supplémentaire qui nous a été accordée
j'ai entendu l'audition de monsieur
albert tillières qui disait qu'en fait
implicitement l'accord avait été
repoussé à 21h le vendredi il a d'abord
été repoussée le vendredi matin puis 21h
dans ces délais là nous avons produit ce
que nous avions à produire une question
a été posée sur la chaîne de
responsabilités c'est la question c'est
vraiment la question parce que nous les
routeurs nous sommes au milieu de la
chaîne nous sommes alimentés par les
imprimeurs qui est le premier maillon de
la chaîne
on peut même dire que les candidats avec
les profs leur validation profession de
foi sont le vrai premier maillon de la
chaîne et nous donnons la distribution
des plis aux opérateurs postaux
j'ajoute et je joue vrai firme une
parenthèse que quand nous prenons les
marchés des préfectures
nous ne savons pas qu'il y aura un
deuxième opérateur postal qui rentrera
dans le dispositif et je pourrais vous
expliquer si vous le souhaitez la
conséquence que ça dans nos usines
d'accord mais simplement vous doublez
les contraintes vous doublez les vous
doublez la complexité du travail c'est à
dire que d'un ordre de fabrication sur
machine il faut en faire 2 1 pour la
poste un pour adrexo il faut deux
interlocuteurs 2 administration des
ventes
il faut remplir deux continents
différents donc en fait c'est notre
travail c'est notre métier c'est notre
service mais il faut savoir que quand
plus on multiplie le nombre d'opérateurs
de distribution plus ça complexifie le
travail dans les dents les dans les
usines
parce qu'en fait vous devez gérer deux
typologies de prestataires différentes
des développements informatiques
différents mais bon qu'est logistique
que madame boyer voulais je comprends
qu'il ya de sa part après dans deux
tuyaux si je peux me permettre
mais ce que je comprends pas c'est
pourquoi parce que la mise sous pli elle
est identique et professions de foi sont
les mêmes qu elle soit distribué par la
poste ou par un autre opérateur
en quoi c'est différent c'est pas parce
que ces deux paquets qui vont ailleurs
sont les étiquettes qui sont différentes
à gérer ces sas et l'étiquetage sur les
plis et puis cela fatiha c'est un marché
dans un communiqué la mise sous pli elle
est identique puisque c'est le même
contenu mais c'est sur l' enveloppe
c'est le fait que vous avez un certain
nombre d'étiquettes pour mais ça
j'imagine que c'est pareil parce que
c'est distribué par bureau de vote
c'est pas par ordre alphabétique c'est
comment alors expliquer no mercy pardon
il ya notre bien mais chez le cheval a
oui bonjour monsieur le président
mesdames il si nature vous m'entendez
oui effectivement il ya un cahier des
charges différend sur la logistique
postal entre eux adrexo et la poste on
obligé de deux mètres dans des
contenants qui sont différents donc pour
la poste cd contenant d'un plus petit
format que pour adrexo oui on a un ordre
de tri qui est différent puisque le on
passe dans un moteur de tri pour trier
le fichier informatique mans pour la
poste est un moteur de tri différents
pour adrexo qui va préparer la tournée
du distributeur ou dut ou du facteur et
ça il ya des séparateurs à m il ya d une
organisation de production qui est
vraiment différente entre l'une chaîne
une chaîne ou l'autre pardon c'est la
finesse du tri et la haye la manière de
travailler de l'opérateur postal qui
nous demande d'aller au plus loin dans
sa préparation physique des plis pour
gagner du temps dans sa distribution
si vous me permettez pour le ministère a
choisi de faire rentrer
un deuxième opérateur postal il s'en est
suivi un certain nombre de réunions avec
cet opérateur postal et entre le cahier
des charges qui avait été demandé par
cet opérateur postal au moment de la
soude de la soumission de son appel
d'offres et le moment on rentre en
production se passe un certain nombre de
réunions parce que nous les routeurs
nous sommes obligés d'expliquer que si
nous devons appliquer le cahier des
charges tel qu'il a été présenté
nous ne pourrons pas tenir les délais et
il a fallu sur les séparateurs sur les
contenants sur la façon de travailler
discuter avec eux et il faut reconnaître
que adrexo a fait évoluer son cahier des
charges pour pouvoir coller au plus
proche de nos usines de production et
faire en sorte que ça match le plus
possible chaque opérateur a ses
spécificités
alors on va continuer même voyez puis
monsieur le rudulier excusez moi je
j'entends ce que vous dites mais il ya
une chose que j'ai du mal à comprendre
quand vous avez répondu à l'appel
d'offres vous avez répondu à l'appel
d'offres tel qu'il était rédigé il était
rédigée de façon identique pour tout le
monde c'était c'était l'appel d'offres
qui était rédigée avec un certain tri et
c'est là dessus que vous avez répondu
j'ai juste à me le permet pas nous
savons nous tous répondu sur des marchés
qui daté de 2019 2020 on est sur des
marchés pluriannuel et les marchés avec
les préfectures et est vraiment basée
sur un process 100% poste
et quand le deuxième opérateur est
arrivé il ya eu aucune évolution ni
d'avenant ni quoi que ce soit et sur
lequel on a dû prendre les nouvelles
contraintes qu'ils étaient
donné par adrexo pour pouvoir comme le
disait loïc avoir une double production
pour voir des avoirs des gestions qui
était complètement différente
donc on à antrim et plus suit l'arrivée
d'un nouvel entrant par rapport à des
marchés qui étaient existant de façon
curial ben oui mais votre micro parce
que personne vous entendre vous avez
répondu à un cahier des charges qui a
été modifié en cours de l'exécution du
marché
oui mais chez le rudulier premier merci
monsieur le président de ma question est
assez simple c'est dans le prolongement
de cette discussion
vous avez une connaissance du deuxième
opérateur à quelle date précisément
combien de temps il vous a fallu pour
réviser l'ensemble de vos process
au vu de ce second opérateur est notre
question sur la concomitance des deux
scrutins est ce que ça a eu un impact
chez vous par rapport à votre à votre
mission première qui est sûr encore
monsieur benachenhou et oui juste un
petit complément je suppose que vous
avez déjà dans le passé sur d'autres
marchés pas électoraux bien sûr
travaillé avec adrexo donc je vous en
avoir confirmation d'auxi été des
interlocuteurs connu de vous dans leurs
méthodes de travail gérer chaque fois
bien bien merci
allons-y jeudi devant la parole ce que
vous en ferez de on a pris connaissance
du marché d'adrexo
septembre octobre 2020 non donc c'est
pas possible alors décembre voilà ok
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai un doute
mais c'est pas le point que je voulais
aborder spécifiquement de décembre 2020
jusque globalement le début de
l'opération du premier tour on a
travaillé tous tous les routeurs
d'ailleurs concernés par ce nouveau
prestataire de distribution sur le mode
opératoire et on a affiné d'ailleurs sur
les bacs les contenants les étiquetages
pour essayer de trouver le juste
équilibre entre les besoins d'actions
qui sont tout à fait compréhensibles et
nos usines nos outils de production que
l'on a dû adapter
concernant coma et je précise bien que
concernant koba sur le deuxième tour d
[Musique]
des élections le cahier des charges
d'adrexo a complètement changé la veille
du démarrage du deuxième tour
tout simplement parce que il avait été
prévu eu égard aux cellules que l'on a
mis en place un jour bien sûr les
vingt-sept cellule que adrexo nous livre
globalement les mêmes types de
contenants que la poste avait l'habitude
de nous livrer c'est à dire des bagues
des rôles jusqu'en l'an comprends bien
on a bien dissocier les deux approches
on halal approche purement industriel
c'est à dire que l'on va mettre des gros
bacs à ont sorti une machine sur lequel
avec les volumes et les canons ce que
nous produisons pas machine on va mettre
les plis directement dans des gros bacs
quand on fait unis sous pli manuel vous
vous doutez bien mais ce qui va là pour
cuba est valable aussi bien entendu pour
l'ensemble des préfectures fait le fond
en régie ou tout opérateur qui le fait
en régie les volumes sont bien entendu
très inférieur c'est de dire que les
cellules sont adaptés pour que l'on
puisse remplir des petits bacs
globalement de 200 ou 300 pis que l'on
va mettre sur des rôles à roulettes et
que l'on va faire tranquillement roulé
pour décharger tout simplement l'étape
pour ne prendre que cet exemple
ça c'est ce qu'on aurait dû avoir dans
les cellules et la veille du démarrage
ou deux jours avant on reçoit un mail
d'adrexo nous disant que pour des
questions x on n'aura pas de bac on
n'aura pas de rôle
vous faites comment dans ces cas là on
va vous livrer des grands clubs on va
vous livrer des cartons on va vous
livrer quelques rôles on l'oubli mais on
est à deux jours du démarrage et on
apprend réellement que toute la chaîne
d' d'anticipation de travail sur les
cellules je pense bien sûr les cellules
a été complètement chamboulée
je vous cache pas que vu le contexte nos
relations avec adrexo parce que vous les
avez eu aussi en auditions se sont
légèrement tendus légèrement tendus et
je reste poli d'accord monsieur lefebvre
et constituer ensuite monsieur le
rudulier concernant groupe diffusion
plus nous n'avions pas ces modes de
fonctionnement en cellule donc on était
dans un processus industriel
le cahier des charges a été discuté on a
essayé de travaillant en co construction
c'est un processus où l'ensemble des
maillons de la chaîne des imprimeurs aux
routeurs aux distributeurs a vraiment
intérêt à travailler main dans la main
donc c'est ce que nous avons privilégié
y compris avec la poste la poste elle
aussi ayant fait des évolutions sur son
système d'information cercle la poste a
elle aussi demandé notamment sur la
notion de yb bordereau un certain nombre
de choses qui n'existaient pas avant
mais nous avons pu travailler avec eux
pour
voilà pour pour que ça se passe du mieux
possible
je voulais répondre à une question sur
la sous traitance pas de sous traitance
chez nous sauf à ce que vous considériez
que le recours à l'intérim et de la
sous-traitance mais nous avons fait que
l'intérim pas de sous traitance nous
avons opérés directement dans nos usines
les marchés que nous avons nous avons
signé le haut alors je vais être très
transparent
avec vous nous avons en heure total
quinze mille heures de travail sûr je
parle du 2ème tour parce que c'est celui
qui est le plus critique c'est là où on
a le pic de recours à l'intérim qui
serait parti sans 8000 cdi et 6500
intérim donc vous vous donnez là pour
vous donner la proportion le double
scrutin il était un problème
le double scrutin a clairement était le
problème du deuxième tour et il a été
d'autant plus qu'on n'a pas cumulé deux
scrutins simple mais deux scrutins dont
un qui est la cantonale départementale
complexe je vais vous donner un chiffre
à notre échelle à nous quand nous
lançons la production des régionales ont
fait 3 ce qu'on appelle bon à rouler
trois validation
trois lots il y a trois compositions de
documents et après on peut partir en
production
est-ce qu'on parce qu'on opère trois
régions parce que nous opérons trois
régions à l'intérieur desquelles nous
avons plusieurs départements mais les
profs sont communes aux départements de
la même région sur les régies sur les
départementales
nous avions 183 composition de l'eau 183
bon à rouler donc cumuler des élections
n'est pas un problème en soi si ce sont
des scrutins simple industrialisable
voilà mais cumulées des scrutins dont
l'un est assez complexe
c'est ça qui vient avec chaque petit
grain de sable supplémentaires poser une
problématique
allez je vais demander à monsieur
grenier
la proportion du recours à l'intérim
chez vous pour qu'on ait les éléments
complets ensuite monsieur le rudulier
monsieur kerrouche chez madame boyer
alors la proportion est bien entendu
très variable en fonction de si on est
sur un site industriel ou si on est sur
un site cellule pour être clair sur un
site cellules ces huit mille cinq cents
intérimaires fall 8000 intérimaire et
c'est quasiment 100% puisque par
définition c'est l'encadrement koba bien
sûr toute la formation comment on pourra
en reparler mais c'est que de l'intérim
ça ne ne demande pas d'ailleurs de
compétences particulières sa demande
juste de la rigueur et un bon
encadrement sur les sites industriels là
on est 6 e du 50 50
c'est à dire de l'encadrement
principalement koba des personnels
expérimentés est dans les 50e restons
puisqu'on est bien là depuis 40 ans
objectivement vous avez les trois quarts
de notre personnel intérimaire sont des
personnels qui sont habitués à
travailler sur des matériels industriels
donc que nous utilisons et puis on a 20
30 % de personnel que l'on a intérimaire
que nous n'avons jamais vu qui viennent
et qu'ils découvrent
globalement ce que ce que l'on a à faire
ça n'a juste à tous a toujours
fonctionné comme ça y compris sur un
site éphémère puisque nous n'avons pas
de site industriel à lyon hormis quand
nous faisons des élections et on a
toujours le plaisir d'ailleurs de revoir
des intérimaires qui chaque année quand
on revient ou qu'il ya des élections
viennent travailler sur un premier tour
sur un deuxième tour voilà sur des
matériels donc merci monsieur monsieur
le rudulier oui merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à la
société coma est ce que vous avez fait
part de vos difficultés avec la société
adrexo au service de l'état aux services
préfectoraux pour le second tour tels
que nous les wauquiez et si oui quelle a
été la réponse des services préfectoraux
et ma deuxième question s'adresse à
monsieur lefebvre
qu'est ce que vous entendez par scrutin
simple est ce que c'est un scrutin par
rapport à un nombre de candidats donc un
nombre de de propagande nettement
inférieurs comme les régionales pour le
second tour par rapport aux
départementales ou est-ce qu'à d'autres
définitions d'autres explications sur un
scrutin simple merci monsieur kerrouche
bien d'après ce que vous avez dit si
j'ai bien compris est plus simple de
travailler avec un seul avec un seul
distributeur simplement pour que vous
puissiez nous le
le confirmer la deuxième chose c'est de
manière plus plus général au delà du
fait que effectivement il y a eu un
cumul rares l'a22 de scrutin est-ce que
avec un intérêt tour de quinze jours on
aurait été dû mieux pour le dire pour le
dire simplement et alors est ce que
c'est un terreau tour de quinze jours
doit être pensé uniquement en cas de
cumul d'élections où est ce que il
faudrait éventuellement le le
généraliser quel que soit quelle que
soit l'élection au regard des
difficultés que vous avez rencontrées à
cette élection particulière merci madame
boyer et monsieur le président je suis
assez perplexe s'excuser moi parce que
on a l'impression qu'on découvre ces
scrutins comme c'était la première fois
or c'est pas la première fois que ces
choses-là sont arrivés mais c'est la
première fois que nous avons
connaissance de difficultés de cette
ampleur et c'est ça qui me surprend donc
ma question est la suivante qu'est ce
qui s'est passé la première fois nous
avons eu ces scrutins régionaux et
départementaux avec le scrutin binominal
donc exactement la même chose la fois
précédente de différent par rapport à
cette année 2021
parce que lors du premier scrutin alors
que c'était une première à c'était le
premier scrutin binominal donc avec des
mini circonscription cantonales enfin
départementale plus les élections
régionales donc on s'est retrouvé dans
un cas de figure strictement identiques
or je n'ai pas souvenir qu'on ait connu
des difficultés de l'ampleur de celle de
2021 donc quels sont les problèmes que
vous avez rencontrées ou les difficultés
que vous avez rencontrées qui sont
différentes des précédentes et je vous
donne la parole je précise simplement
que 2015
il ya bien deux
élections la même année mais pas ceux là
impérial temporalité une en mars une
anse décembre pour les jeunes à 7 avant
où on a eu un double scrutin où
effectivement il ya aussi retrouver dans
une situation à peu près identique à
aujourd'hui je vais répondre à la
première question de la première
question mais volume ce qu'on a réussi
ce qu'on a raté parce que c'est
important si de le dire puisque tout n'a
pas été parfait donc il faut aussi le
dire donc sur des départementales pour
répondre à votre question
pardon sur les départementales nous
avons réussi à produire 90 2 71%
donc nos inventions 14 millions 274 nous
allons nous en avons eu 12 millions 948
et je rejoins mon loïc oui les
départementales sont l'élection la plus
complexe à faire dans notre pays
plus que par définition il ya beaucoup
de cantons certain nombre de candidats
par comptons drew c'est assez complexe
on l'a fait sur le premier tour donc que
je ne vois pas de problème majeur mais
quand je vois que globalement 20 heures
parce qu'on avait au total 54 heures de
productions pas 60 heures comme ça a été
dit hier ses 54 eur 1 36 +18 on a fait
90 % 91% des départementales pour les
régionales par contre l'élection bond le
plus simple puisque on raisonne par
région la halle inverse
on n'a pas été très bon puisqu'on a fait
62 % 62% et de manière très variable en
fonction des départements puisqu'on a eu
du sang pour sang et mais on a eu aussi
du 24 août 27 % très variable en
fonction des départements les
difficultés
alors d'abord répondre à la question oui
bien sûr qu'on a alerté alors c'est même
pas aller c'est pas le bon terme
oui bien sûr qu'on est en relation
permanente avec le ministère de
l'intérieur et avec la société adrexo et
avec aussi la poste on n'en parle pas la
poste qui a aussi avec nos cellules
infligeront revient sur le cas de coma a
dû s'adapter aussi à ses 27 cellule à
son organisation quelque chose qui
n'était pas prévu au départ et sur
lequel globalement ça s'est très très
bien passé ça s'est très très bien passé
je dis pas que ça a été facile on a
aussi pas mal de batailler sur les
contenants sur l'organisation sur les
transports
je me mets à la place de deux des
personnes de la presse on a eu en l'a
quasiment au quotidien
oui enfin c'était un vrai casse tête
mais ça s'est très très bien passé avec
adrexo on a eu des échanges de mails
alors on a une problématique avec un
trac sosa a été relevé aussi c'est que
on s'adresse à qui s'est compliquée la
poste vous doutez bien qu'on ne
s'adresse pas au président donc on a des
relais régionaux locaux voire même sur
site et on essaye de dans la mesure du
possible de trouver des juste équilibre
entre leurs besoins et nos
problématiques el qadr x on a eu ce
problème là puisqu'on était plutôt en
relation commerciale puis après
technique puis après locale mais vous
avez compris que localement on avait
plutôt des intérimaires donc on avait
une vraie difficulté a essayé de
d'avancé et et j'en veux pour preuve que
nos relations se sont pleinement
dégradée que c'est une préfète que je
remercie d'ailleurs qui a pris son
téléphone était appelée d'à côté adrexo
ces combats dix ans entendez-vous
oui mais non mais sauf qu'on était le 24
je le dirai ça a été très très très
difficile alors est-ce que adrexo de
manière parce qu'il faut aller plus loin
je rebondis est-ce que adrexo a été le
mot ou la cause de tous nos nos
problèmes
la réponse est clairement non clairement
non parce que si ça avait été le cas on
aurait été pénalisée en paca rhône-alpes
uniquement puisque pour notre entreprise
adrexo ne servait que la zone rhône
alpes on a eu des difficultés en paca on
a eu des difficultés en nouvelles
aquitaine un peu moins en occitanie on
en a eu aussi est aussi en ile de france
et pour des problématiques sont
d'ailleurs là al'inverse très
différentes
la nouvelle aquitaine que l'on traite
historiquement depuis plus de dix ans
quand vous avez cinq candidats donc dix
documents à mettre sous pli en 36 heures
sur des régionales ça coince ça coince
on pourrait le transposer dans une
moindre mesure en ile de france
quatre candidats huit documents ça
coince donc pour répondre à votre
question les trente six heures au delà
du double scrutin
au delà du double scrutin reste un
véritable sujet dans l'est
les élections que l'on vit on va dire
complètement changé ses cinq ou dix
dernières années voilà les manquements
de la société adriq seront semblait se
confirmer devant la commission d'
enquête du sénat les syndicats de la
société de distribution ont en effet
révélé lors de cette double audition que
les intérimaires embauchés pour
distribuer la propagande électorale
n'avait bénéficié en fait que d'une
heure de formation pour la merci de nous
avoir suivi l'actualité politique et
parlementaire se poursuit sur public
sénat
m
[Musique]
dieu du stade week-end du web plus
besoin de choisir mais ses prises de
parole en solo de nos héros pose parfois
des problèmes de communication beaucoup
plus politique qu'ils en ont l'air ces
sept semaines de racheter hashtag ce
soir à 22h sur public sénat
[Musique]
c
la femme réseau toujours subordonné à
l'homme la plupart du temps elle est
vraiment un objet sexuel ou une servante
économique est toujours sous payé là
plutôt des chances égales à celle de
loeb est toujours assez arié la
maternité au foyer je crois pas du tout
eu de progrès
malheureusement beauvoir est née au
début du 20e siècle
à l'époque on ne reconnaît ni le droit
de vote des femmes ni l'autonomie
financière ni l'avortement est lourd
jeudi la cage de la prison dans lequel
sont infirmées les femmes depuis des
millénaires à bourg-des-comptes c'était
enthousiasmant chez les femmes
jeudi puis la révolution sur ce plan là
sur le plan du travail ménager s'est lui
refusé c'est obliger les hommes à faire
avec elle après bien si ce qui est
échangé toute la société en seraient
bouleversés
mais comment a t'elle conquis sa liberté
car elle n'est pas née beauvoir elle
l'est devenue beauvoir laventure d'être
soit demain à 22h sur public sénat
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si
vous nous rejoignez sur public sénat
ravi de vous retrouver pour ce tout
dernier numéro d' allons plus loin on va
de nouveau prendre le temps d'analyser
et de questionner toute l'actualité
politique et parlementaire pour la
dernière fois de la saison et voit
d'abord le fer avec notre invité du jour
pour qui c'est aussi une dernière fois
dallier bienvenus c'est n'a jamais l'air
de la seine-saint-denis sénateurs encore
pour quelques jours seulement puisque
vous démissionner de votre mandat vous
allez vous concentrer sur votre nouvelle
mission de président de la commission
des finances du conseil départemental de
seine saint denis vous allez nous
expliquer tout cela dans un instant
allons plus loin c'est aussi le club
trois intervenants qui ont des choses à
vous dire avec nous ce soir quand un
calme et bienvenue quand ans vous
revenez sur l'avant projet de loi autour
du passé ni terre qui a fait descendre
dans la rue quelques milliers de
personnes hier le texte arrive la
semaine prochaine au sénat
voilà il sera sont adoptés 1 mais les
sénateurs alerte contre les zones
d'ombré dans ce texte qui est envoyé au
conseil d'état
mario bigras et également avec nous ce
soir bienvenue marion l'europe on sait
concocter un plan de bataille pour
réduire les émissions de co2 certains
parlent d'un big bang environnementale
environnementale pour certains social
pour d'autres en particulier pour la
filière automobile
et puis steve jourdain est également
avec nous pour cette dernière bienvenue
steve un comité interministériel de la
laïcité à la place de l'observatoire qui
a été dissous le mois dernier une
laïcité qui en chasse une autre
interrogation avec un point
d'interrogation dans une demi-heure
notre grand entretien
nous serons ce soir alexander en ai filé
directeur de l'opéra de paris nous
ferons le bilan avec lui de cette année
qu'au vidé de ses conséquences
financières humaines culturelles le past
and i ter il connaît le système est déjà
en place depuis le mois de juin il nous
dira comment il s'est organisé
inspirera peut-être ceux qui vont devoir
s'y préparer nous sommes allés tourner
dans deux autres lieux de spectacle
vivant
reportage de notre journaliste cécile 6
ou à suivre hashtag lpl si vous avez
envie de réagir sur twitter
mais d'abord l'actualité sénatoriales
c'est la suite des débats autour du
projet de loi sur la décentralisation
les dernières heures était consacré aux
agences régionales de santé dont
l'organisation a été très critiqué au
plus fort de la crise sanitaire changer
le système de gouvernance et la volonté
du sénat explications andré fait face
lors de la première vague les régions
ont distribué des masques alors que ce
n'était pas leur compétence quelques
mois plus tard des maires ont organisé
des dépistage massif à la place de
l'état
un investissement au plus fort de la
tempête que le sénat récompense
aujourd'hui nous avons voulu simplement
faire en sorte que les élus locaux du
fait du travail qu'ils ont fourni qui
est considérable soit considéré
désormais dans le cas des conseils
d'administration de la de l'agencé de
santé
les sénateurs ont voté pour qu'il y ait
deux chefs à la tête des ars les agences
régionales de santé
d'un côté le préfet de région qui
représente l'état de l'autre le
président de région
un élu local et ça le gouvernement y
était opposé un désaccord entre deux
présidents étant susceptible de bloquer
le fonctionnement de lagence par
ailleurs le conseil régional ne dispose
pas de compétence en matière sanitaire
qui justifierait cette coprésidence
elle dit que ce n'est pas de la
compétence de la région sauf que dans
l'article suivant l'article 32 proposée
par le gouvernement
on dit que les régions peuvent financer
les investissements publics et privés
des établissements de santé ont
participé mener droit de rien dire ça
c'est pas possible
avec ce vote le sénat donne aussi plus
de poids aux élus locaux dans les
conseils d'administration des ars ce qui
a été décidé
des en séance c'est d'avoir un conseil
d'administration composé à parts égales
deux représentants de l'état des
organismes d'assurance maladie des
collectivités territoriales et des
usagers et ça c'est une nouveauté
puisque jusqu'ici même si toutes ces
personnes étaient dans les conseils de
surveillance et bien le gouvernement les
exécutifs avait fait en sorte que dans
la partie réglementaire il renforçait la
part de l'état et donc qu'on avait des
représentants de l'état les sénateurs
espère maintenant que c'est
rééquilibrages seront conservés par le
gouvernement lors de l'examen du texte à
l'assemblée et fils d'ali vous riez déjà
vous ne pensez pas du tout que ce sera
retenue par le comité pour vous il ya
d'autres sessions de manière plus
générale je pense que ce quinquennat
aura été une formidable occasion manquée
entre les collectivités locales et
l'état
on attendait tous à un moment ou à un
autre l'acte iii de la décentralisation
qui serait enfin celui où on aurait une
réorganisation pourra plus d'efficacité
en matière de dépenses publiques
pour plus de clarté pour nos concitoyens
on attendait un grand texte fait il est
jamais venu au début du quinquennat
président de la république était plutôt
dans l'eure comment dire pour pas être
trop désagréable
bon les élus locaux les corps
intermédiaires on se souvient que
c'était vraiment pas sa tasse de thé il
aura fallu attendre la crise des gilet
jaune et sous l'impulsion du président
larcher pour que le président de la
république se disent les maires peuvent
servir à quelque chose dans ce pays et
puis il ya eu la crise sanitaire
et là aussi on a découvert stupéfaits
que l'état n'était pas très alors pour
des raisons x ou y et les élus locaux
ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu avec les
moyens qui étaient les leurs donc on ne
va pas leur reprocher aujourd'hui
d'avoir fait sans compétence
particulière essayer face aux armadas va
essayer d'améliorer la situation de nos
mets savoureux déçu par ce texte
une frappe avons fait les choses dans
mes cela ça n'est pas le grand texte que
qu'on pouvait attendre voilà cesser bon
voilà c'est un texte de fin de fin de
session avec quelques possibilités mais
ça n'est pas l'acte iii de la
décentralisation dont on a besoin
car je suis en forme le voeu que ce soit
un débat la campagne présidentielle et
post présidentielle on y aille quand je
dis on y aille ça veut dire vraiment
réorganiser l'état et et voir ce dont
l'état s'occupe et ce qu'ils lâchent au
profit des collectivités territoriales
et là on voit bien dans le dans le débat
sur la rs mais voilà l'état l'état veut
toujours tout contrôler même si de
façade et acceptent parfois un peu de un
peu d'avancé en direction des élus a pu
immédiatement de l'autre côté ils
essayent de reprendre la main les ars
trop parisienne comme dit dominique
bussereau trop paris tous les cas assez
loin du t1 je pense que la crise
sanitaire la montre est venu à coup sûr
on va continuer philippe dallier mais on
va intégrer nos chroniqueurs c'est
l'heure du club
[Musique]
quentin le pass sanitaire de la discorde
c'est votre sujet donc ce soit je le
disais quelques milliers de français ont
exprimé leur inquiétude et même leur
colère contre les annonces des manuels
macro lundi soir qu'en pensent les
sénateurs et bien déjà on en sait plus
sur les annonces de lundi soir grâce à
ce document c'est l'avant projet de loi
qui a été envoyée au conseil d'état
alors attention ce n'est pas le document
de ce qui a été adopté en conseil des
ministres sa part est examiné ni de ce
qui sera inscrit à l'ordre du jour des
assemblées mais déjà ça donne quelques
détails sur ce que veut faire le
gouvernement avec le pass sanitaires
parmi les mesures on retient
l'obligation pour les exploitants de
lieux recevant du public de contrôler le
ps sanitaires un manquement dans ce
contrôle
et bien c'est sévèrement punis dans ce
texte de loi un restaurateur ou un
directeur de cinéma par exemple
risquerait jusqu'à 45000 euros d'amendé
et un an de prison
alors c'est difficile pour ces
professionnels selon le président de la
commission des lois du sénat on écoute
c'est leur faire porter qu'une mission
qui de prime abord peut apparaître
d'évidence mais qui al'expertise on peut
s'avérer difficile pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux une grande
administration qui contrôle à ses
entrées via un dispositif de portiques
de sans doute arriver à le faire mais un
exploitant de bars de restaurants en
terrasse c'est pas toujours simple donc
nous aurons à voir ça évidemment dans le
texte un aspect très pratique mais
essentielle
voilà on verra ce que fera le sénat
avait que cet aspect très pratique mais
essentielle quand le texte sera examiné
en séance c'est le 23 juillet rebekah il
ya un autre point qui interroge content
c'est niveau des amendes encourues même
pour le simple client oui ce client qui
ne disposera pas de passes sanitaire
peut craindre une lourde amende si le
texte est un deux et adopter un tel quel
regardez si vous êtes contrôlés sans
vous encourez 10000 euros d'amendé et
six mois d'emprisonnement
c'est là un point qui a vraiment fait
sursauter les sénateurs de la commission
des lois écoutait la socialiste marie
pierre de la gontrie
je peux le comprendre on est dans la com
politique c'est à dire qu'on veut
affirmer le fait que un il faut se
vacciner que deux si on n'est pas
vacciné on va avoir une vie quotidienne
compliqué on pourra avoir accès aux
services fondamentaux mais pas aux
loisirs pour faire simple et que trois
ceux qui doivent y veiller
ou se faire vacciner même s'ils ne le
font pas ça va pas être simple pour eux
bon après les peines ne seront pas elles
sont effectivement j'ai été frappée
comme vous elles sont très fortes
elles sont à mon sens trop forte voilà
un autre sénateur nous parlait même et
bien d'un risque d'inconstitutionnalité
dans la gradation des peines les unes
par rapport aux autres c'est clairement
là un des points chauds
un des points de vigilance autour du
texte rebecca en comptant les sénateurs
ne vont modifier le texte qu'à la marge
oui c'est vrai il ya un accord global
autour du texte avec des modifications à
la marge comme vous disiez effectivement
les socialistes par exemple il pourrait
s'opposer à l' isolement automatique des
personnes testées positives pourquoi
parce que ça pourrait avoir des
conséquences négatives sur le fait que
les gens ne se testerait plus par
exemple parmi les vrais opposants les
seuls vrais opposants au texte il ya
quelques lr quelques centristes voyez on
a vu cette tribune dans le pavillon bleu
figaro avec l'eurodéputée
françois-xavier de bellamy et le
sénateur centriste loïc hervé selon eux
le pass sanitaires et je cite une remise
en cause profonde et inédite de notre
modèle de société
écoutez le et car vire il y a deux mois
devant le parlement le gouvernement est
venue la main sur le coeur nous
expliquer très clairement que jamais le
past anita ne sera étendue aux aux actes
de la vie quotidienne d'ailleurs le
conseil d'état dans un arrêt rendu le 6
juillet explique que le passé ni terre
est acceptable
précisément parce qu'il ne touche pas à
la vie quotidienne hier ou aujourd'hui
un patron de restaurants ou de bar
serait amendé
s'ils le demandent pas salutaire demain
il sera amendée s'il ne le demande pas
ce bouleversement là
en plein été ce changement de pied moi
je le ne comprends pas je le condamne
voilà un dernier mot dans votre dernière
émission pour dire que ce qui énerve
aussi passablement les sénateurs m et
casser la méthode avec un président de
république qui fait des annonces comme
ça sans vérifier la faisabilité des
mesures sans même aussi prendre en
compte que le débat parlementaire on y
revient toujours et ce dernier et non
plus en france et au recours notamment
celui devant le conseil constitutionnel
mais peut-être que le plus important en
fin de compte c'était le choc de
l'annoncé de lundi est telle qu'il a ça
a marché et raison le premier plus parce
qu'on a vu trois millions de demandes de
rendez vous pour se faire vacciner
depuis est cette allocution lundi ciel
est votre point de vue philippe daly
c'est très compliqué on se dit que
fermeté a marché trois millions de
personnes qui prennent rendez-vous ayant
un temps c'est sa soeur tu les libertés
individuelles
oui mais la question c'est qu'est ce
qu'on fait on attend le mois d'août où
le mois de septembre pour constater que
le nombre de personnes vaccinées n'a pas
véritablement augmenter et que le
verrions le variant qui se répondent à
une ville qu à la vitesse grand v touche
de plus en plus de monde et puis on
recommence avec quoi des mesures de
confinement de restrictions il ya un
moment donné il faut prendre des
décisions alors c'est vrai que les
annonces jupitérienne serait pour les
parlementaires
le streak plus dans quelques temps
quelques temps mais découvrir ce qu'on
est censé faire télévision le soir à 20h
à 100 effectivement il ya eu un minimum
de précautions de prise
c'est un peu agaçant alors j'espère que
le sénat trouvera le bon compromis parce
qu'effectivement 45000 euros d'amendé
vous 10000 euros c est certainement
excessif mais pour autant il faut bien
faire prendre conscience à nos
concitoyens que tant que nous n'aurons
pas 80 85 % de personnes qui sont
vaccinées
on peut ne pas en sortir de cette
affaire et ça ça ne sera plus
supportable longtemps c'est à dire que
le quoi qu'il en coûte
moi je pense qu'on est au bout du bout
du bout et je ne pense pas que
l'économie française ni surtout le
budget
de la nation pause pourrait supporter
encore des dépenses mais comment vous
l'apercevez cette colère qui a été
exprimée alors par près de vingt mille
personnes vont me direz c'est pas grand
champ de vison tive axe il ya déjà des
il ya des spécialistes de ce genre de
chose alors je ne dis pas que certains
ne sont pas de parfaite bonne foi etc
mais pas forcément des anti vaccins sont
des gens pour qui le passent sanitaire
est un cap de trop un câble de trop
c'est parce qu'ils veulent pas se faire
vacciner parce que sinon je pense qu'il
n'y verrais pas spécialement
d'inconvénients donc voilà la société en
tous les cas le parlement à un moment
donné doit prendre ses responsabilités
pour essayer de protéger globalement la
société parce que sinon on laisse
quelques faire quelques heures quelques
dizaines de millions de personnes
décider de ce qui va se passer parce
qu'elle refuse de se faire vacciner
écoutez vous refusez de vous faire
vacciner il y aura des inconvénients
effectivement vous devrez les assumer la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous comme
gérard larcher vous dites si nécessaire
il faudra y aller ben moi je pense qu'à
un moment donné
écoutez regardez la vaccination pour les
soignants il ya quelques mois c'était un
tabou complet tout le monde personne ne
voulait mettre le sujet sur la table
enfin il vit sur la table certains
soignants j'en ai entendu je sais pas
s'ils le feront quitteront leur métier
ce qui est regrettable mais ceci étant
dit voilà on y va et on le fait et pour
l'ensemble des français je pense
qu'effectivement sauf pour quelques
exceptions médical si je fais lire je
pense qu'il faut aller vers une
généralisation de la vaccination
marion je me tourne vers vous l'europe a
pris tout le monde de court hier avec
des annonces environnementale
fracassante j'ai envie de dire c'est
dans le domaine des transports que
certains parlent déjà d'un big bang
c'est à ce point là oui un big bang
écologique c'est en tout cas ce que
promet bruxelles avec la présentation de
cette feuille de route en faveur du
climat et une annonce officielle qui
intervient un an après l'engagement des
vingt-sept à atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 ce plan qui est la
priorité du mandat de la présidente
ursula von der leyen porte le nom de fit
for fifty-five par et pour 55
et pourquoi ce chiffre de 50,5 et bien
parce qu'il correspond aux 55 %
d'émissions carbone que l'union
européenne espère réduire
d'ici à 2030 et pour y parvenir elle
décide de tarifier le carbone écoutez à
ce sujet la présidente plus pauvres
sempot le principe est simple si les
émissions de co2 doivent avoir un prix
un prix sur le co2 qui incite les
consommateurs les producteurs et les
innovateurs à choisir les technologies
propres à s'orienter vers les produits
propres et durables
oui notre stand products pour son plan
la commission a donc ciblé plusieurs
secteurs clés vous en avez cité un est
l'un des plus polluants sur le continent
effectivement le transport dès 2023
la commission veut taxer par exemple le
kérosène pour les vols intérieurs à
l'union européenne est poussé à
l'utilisation des carburants verts à
base d'hydrogène
mais la mesure la plus emblématique
c'est la fin de la vente des voitures
essence diesel et hybride à partir de
l'idée étant qu'à partir de cette date
là toutes les voitures neuves
immatriculées et des émissions en
carbone nul
à noter que sur ce point le gouvernement
français a tenté de défendre le maintien
des véhicules hybrides mais sans succès
et pour accélérer le développement des
carburants alternatifs la commission va
également imposé à ses états membres le
déploiement de bornes de recharge à
travers toute l'europe
l'idée serait d'installer des bandes
toutes les 60 km pour les recharges
électriques et tous les 150 km pour le
ravitaillement en hydrogène et qu'on dit
la filière automobile nous avons
interrogé le président délégué de la
chambre syndicale internationale de
l'automobile et thierry archambault
pour lui les constructeurs automobiles
ont déjà opéré des changements et la
date de 2035 et nabeul à condition que
la puissance publique l'accompagnent sur
mettre en place pour tous ceux qui
prennent la filière cette révolution va
créer des emplois
soit à destination de ceux qui manquent
à bord de leurs documents des centaines
de personnes cette opération je puisse
en tout cas personne n'est pas fait
encore justement dans la filière
automobile 7 environ 100000 emplois qui
pourraient être perdus d'ici 15 ans d'où
l'urgence d'anticiper les
transformations et les adaptations et du
côté des responsables politiques comment
réagit-on alors on notera pour beaucoup
les inquiétudes principalement sur le
volet social justement certains
brandissent que le risque de voir
apparaître des mouvements de
contestation tippl gilet jaune
en effet les fournisseurs de carbone et
de fioul domestique seront contraints
d'acheter des quotas d'émission de co2
et cela devrait mécaniquement se
répercuter sur la facture des ménages
est pénalisé à les plus précaires
d'où cette demande notamment de
greenpeace france c'est aux
multinationales et aux plus aisés de
faire la grande part de l'effort
sinon on confond sobriété et précarité
et pour le sénateur écologiste jacques
fernique membre de la commission des
affaires européennes
l'union doit effectivement faire
davantage d'efforts il est clair que
passer d'un système à l'autre sans avoir
en tête le souci d'accompagnement social
le souci d'accompagnement pour que du
point de vue de l'emploi du point de vue
des ddt des politiques économiques sur
les territoires soient pas la vaste des
organisations et du perdant perdant pour
beaucoup de nos concitoyens ça il faut y
travailler
les pays d'europe de l'est et d'europe
centrale de leur côté ont fait savoir
que le calendrier des mesures étaient
trop courts berlin et certains pays du
nord craignent eux des représailles
commerciales sur le projet de taxe
carbone aux frontières pour les
importations de produits les plus
polluants
après les annonces place donc aux
discussions aux négociations entre les
héros députés les 27 états membres et à
noter de zélés
man qui pourrait peser dans les débats
les élections allemandes à la rentrée et
le poids que prendront les verts mais
aussi la présidence française au conseil
de l'union européenne au début de
l'année 2022 et pour le sénateur jacques
fernique la france devra être à la
hauteur
si la france n'a pas la volonté de
clairement avancé avec en gardant la
cohérence de l'objectif des mois 55% et
moi on n'y sera pas et de ce point de
vue là ils ont beaucoup à apprendre nos
deux responsables et nos décideurs
français parce que pour notre propre loi
climat on n'y est pas on est au mieux
dans les 35 % de réduction sur la base
de nos émissions de 90 donc il va
falloir apprendre la méthodologie pour
avoir des résultats à la hauteur pour
viser les résultats à la hauteur
et puis il faut aussi que que nos
ministres et nos décideurs français
comprennent que le lieu d'investissement
prioritaire aujourd'hui c'est l'europe
c'est pas des hauts fonctionnaires qu'on
y délèguent mais il ya des ministres qui
doivent y être je dirais pas temps plein
mais qui doit y être clairement
franchement est bien préparée quand ils
y sont parce que ces négociations
l'histoire ne repassera pas les plats à
des négociations qui vont donc commencer
et bruxelles se fixent le cap de l'année
2023 pour que son plan soit adopté et
vous filer le dernier comment vous le
trouvez ce plan européen trop fort trop
ambitieux c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire trop et je sais pas à la question
c'est effectivement la capacité que nous
avons à tout gérer en même temps si
effectivement il faut reconvertir à des
centaines de milliers d'employés
aujourd'hui à vers d'autres filières
pose une difficulté après taxer plus les
émissions carbone ça veut dire
effectivement aggravée les taxes et le
prix du fioul
licence etc pour ceux qui en auront
encore besoin donc on voit bien dans
quel dans quels écueils
entre temps que trente 30 quels écueils
on pourrait se trouver donc c'est vrai
rappelons nous du démarrage de la crise
et gilet jaune parce que c'est pas faute
de l'avoir dit à l'époque ici au sénat
en disant attention vous allez maintenir
l'augmentation des taxes et puis c'est
parti derrière avec une crise qui a été
d'une violence extrêmement grave donc
puis il ya d'autres sujets qu'on
pourrait évoquer l'avenir de la filière
nucléaire parce que tout ça c'est bien
gentil de dire on va passer au tout
électrique
tant mieux mais de l'autre côté on ferme
des centrales nucléaires pas certain que
les économies les nouvelles énergies
permettront de remplacer tout sa fin ce
que j'aimerais c'est avoir une vision
globale de la part de l'état une vraie
stratégie
oui il est contre on aimerait
aujourd'hui qu'on a pas les doutes quand
même et donc qu'on nous explique comment
on peut atteindre cet objectif en 2035
sans problème d'approvisionnement
d'électricité pour tous ces véhicules
qui vont charte chercher à recharger
quelque part avec suffisamment de bornes
partout en france parce que si
effectivement on est limité en terme de
déplacement il y aura aussi des
inconvénients majeurs dans les amériques
pour les particuliers qui c'est une là
j'en reviens à ce que je disais sur la
crise des gilet jaune
si effectivement pour les français les
plus modestes eux se trouvent confrontés
à une augmentation des coûts sans être
de l'autre côté alors j'entendais à la
radio je crois un spécialiste qui disait
que le prix des véhicules électriques
devraient dans quatre cinq ans à être
équivalent à celui d'un véhicule
thermique
ce qui paraît que le prix des batteries
diminue de moitié à peu près tous les
4-5 ans donc ça ça serait plutôt une
bonne nouvelle mais à l'évidence si on
veut que les français changent leur
véhicule pour abandonner le thermique il
faut que derrière les incitations que ce
soit possible pour aller ch'ti je me
tourne vers vous et dernière fois ci
c'est parti pour le comité
interministériel de la laïcité il a donc
été inauguré ce matin par jean castex un
comité qui vient remplacer
l'observatoire de la laïcité une
instance purement consultatif présidé
par l'ancien ministre socialiste jean
louis bianco instance dans laquelle on
retrouvait des parlementaires mais aussi
les chercheurs spécialistes de la loi
de séparation des églises et de l'état
la fameuse loi de 1905 après huit ans de
service clap de fin donc l'observatoire
était supprimé par décret le mois
dernier alors pourquoi parce qu'il était
accusé de faire preuve de laxisme
vis-à-vis de l'islam radical la
polémique est née
on s'en souvient à la suite de la
décapitation de samuel pâtit place
désormais à une laïcité en actes selon
les mots de marlène schiappa ce matin
autour du premier ministre nous avons
est l'aboutissement d'un travail de fond
de plusieurs mois menée de manière
interministériel que j'ai le plaisir de
coordonnées au titre de mes fonctions
puisque je suis chargé de la citoyenneté
et de la laïcité
et donc nous allons mettre en oeuvre une
feuille de route concrète volontariste
en acte avec une vingtaine de mesures
interministériel pour faire vivre la
laïcité concrètement et notamment
appliquer les mesures que nous avons
fait voter dans la loi pour conforter
les principes de la république
ce comité vient donc prendre la place de
l'observatoire il vient prendre la place
mais en disant ça on en dit trop ou pas
assez on entre on comprend pas vraiment
de quoi il s'agit le comité de la
laïcité n'a en effet rien à voir dans sa
forme avec l'observatoire puisqu'il
s'agit d'une structure au sein de
laquelle on retrouve des membres du
gouvernement c'est un comité dit inter
ministériel il est chapeauté par
matignon et ça eh bien ça change tout
pour le socialiste jean pierre sueur
écoutez le je regrette que ce que l'on
passe d'un organisme ouvert associatif
avec beaucoup de d'expression alors
certes il y avait des débats certes un
organisme qui est tout simplement qu'ils
s'appellent nous cachons pas derrière
notre petit doigt qui s'appelle le
gouvernement puisque quand on une idée
du ministère ce que peut faire à tout
moment tout premier mini ça s'appelle le
gouvernement alors sur le fond quelles
seront les missions de ce comité bien
empêcher une nouvelle affaire un nouveau
drame c mais elle pâtit c'est l'objectif
pour le moins ambitieux du gouvernement
en fait ce comité sera surtout chargé de
superviser la mise en place de mesures
souhaitées par le gouvernement de
mesures adoptées par le parlement la
semaine prochaine la loi sur le
séparatisme sera définitivement adoptée
et le comité sera chargé de vérifier
comment certaines des mesures prévues
par le texte déploie très
concrètement sur le terrain la feuille
de route du comité de la laïcité la voix
s'il s'agira de former des agents de la
fonction publique au principe de la
laïcité d'ici à 2025 il aura aussi pour
mission ce comité de déployer des
référents laïcité dans des
administrations ils seront chargés
ces référents officiellement
d'accompagner les agents et de répondre
à leurs questions concernant la laïcité
le comité devra aussi mettre en place
une journée de la laïcité ça sera pour
le 9 décembre des mesures qui en
séduisent certains même à gauche je vous
vois rigoler aussi à l'autre est
pourquoi jean-pierre soir se félicite
lui en tout cas de cette mesure de cette
création d'une journée nationale de la
laïcité à la française écouter le jeu
les moi même proposé je crois à la
demande d'un certain nombre
d'associations et de groupes philosophie
qu'ils ont demandé qui ont demandé que
le 9 décembre jour de la promulgation de
la loi de 1905 soit une journée de la
laïcité c'est une bonne idée il faut la
faire vivre philippe dallier bye bye
l'observatoire de la laïcité vous allez
le regretter
non non la vraie question c'est est ce
ce comité interministériel sera plus
efficace ou moins longs partager le
point de vue de jean pierre sueur
c'est effectivement une affaire qui
devient gouvernementale et qui va
concerner d'abord les administrations
publiques d'états avec la possibilité de
former des agents etc
c'est une bonne chose enfin oui non mais
ça c'était dans chaque année ça c'est
plutôt une bonne chose maintenant j'ai
toujours l'impression qu'on se sent
obligé de créer
de nouvelles structures avec une
lourdeur forcément qui va exister pour
vous l'observatoire ça n'allait pas non
ça ne l'est pas parce que c'était là la
manière dont ils fonctionnaient et puis
la manière dont ils étaient composés là
effectivement c'est le gouvernement ce
qui prend la main qui va vérifier que
les décisions prises par le parlement
sont mises en oeuvre et appliqué sur le
terrain
enfin ceci étant dit chaque préfet dans
son département foot chaque préfet dans
sa région peut veiller aussi à cela sans
qu'on ait forcément besoin de créer un
comité nouveau et cette journée du 9
décembre cette journée de la laïcité
vous avez écouté une de plus mais qu
écouter mais prenez le calendrier
français je ne sais pas à combien de
journées de commémoration divers et
variés nous sommes arrivés mais sait il
y en a bien pas une semaine à mon avis
sans qu'il y ait quelque chose célébrer
ou la laïcité c'est à part mais c'est
très bien tout est très bien mais il ya
un moment quand même on se demande si
enfin quelle efficacité ça et puis ça
finit par passer complètement inaperçue
parce que les gens ne prêtent ou 9
décembre
beaucoup de français savent que c'est la
promulgation la loi 1905 je suis pas
certain non deux derniers sujets pour
terminer si vous le voulez bien son
chronique juste sans autre entre nous on
trouve nul entre nous mardi prochain au
sénat vont venir les candidats
potentiels au système de départage pour
la présidentielle michel barnier
philippe juvin bruno retailleau laurent
wauquiez valérie pécresse devrait être à
ce rendez vous au sénat par xavier
bertrand
comment observer vous tout cela ce que
je sais c'est que nous n'avons aucune
espèce de chances de jouer un rôle dans
la présidentielle
et peut-être d'être qualifié pour le
second tour si nous nous retrouvons avec
plus d'un candidat qui représente nos
couleurs au sens large et bien
évidemment je ne parle pas
d'appartenance politique stricto sensu
et ça je pense que tout le monde en est
conscient
donc gérard larcher a la lourde tâche
d'essayer effectivement d'organiser ce
système de départage moi je ne sais pas
ce qu'il en sera
rendez vous à la fin du mois d'août au
début du mois de septembre mais en tous
les cas tout le monde a conscience que
plus d'un candidat
autant dire que ça n'est pas la peine
d'avoir deux candidats et en hollande en
a tellement conscience que vous avez
bertrand dit moi j'y vais j'y vais seul
c'est peut-être aussi une manière de
forcer le destin et puis d'essayer de
convaincre les autres de renoncer dès
maintenant c'est mal les connaître ou
pas il a raison il va finir par gagner
on y allant tout seul et était on verra
ce que disent les sondages aussi parce
que on verra la fin du mois d'août que
disent les sondages les sondages ne
peuvent pas être pour moi une méthode de
départage mais enfin on verra bien quand
même que si un candidat est entre 18 et
20 et les autres sont entre 12 et 13
et faudra en tirer les conclusions
maintenant ce que j'aimerais c'est que
je viens soulagement d'un xavier
bertrand est ce qu'on peut imaginer et
laurent wauquiez se range sagement
derrière la candidature de xavier
bertrand vous l'imaginez sérieusement je
ne sais pas mais je l'espère parce
qu'alors pour le coup si on voulait
désespéré complètement notre électorat
alors donnons l'image de la plus
parfaite division et puis alors là les
carottes sont cuites quoi mais on
récompense quelqu'un qui est parti du
parti a l'air c'est pas un problème aux
militants qui eux sont restés même quand
la barre premier loyer mais valérie
pécresse aussi est partie au lendemain
du départ de wauquiez donc tout le monde
n'a pas compris
donc c'est vrai que les militants sont
quand même assez assez perturbé sans
parler des élus locaux et pourtant nos
élus locaux tiennent sur le terrain
c'est c c'est quand même le truc le plus
remarquable que ça soit les municipales
où les départementales et régionales
on a tenu le terrain bon et bien
essayons de capitaliser sur ses bons
résultats plutôt que deux
d'aller vers un espèce de conflit et si
vous disent les français vous êtes
connecté au terrain vous retournez à une
mission locale justement qu'est ce que
vous disent les français pas forcément
militants lr uni même sympathisants ceux
qui hésitent ce qui serait tentée par
une candidature de droite en observant
tout cela qu'est ce qu'on vous dit ma
grande inquiétude pour les
présidentielles ça va être le taux de
participation
parce que j'aimerais être convaincu que
pour une élection aussi importante nous
ne reconnaîtrons pas nous ne connaîtrons
pas ce que nous avons connu au pays si
pâle en juin 2000 hommes une ce que nous
avons connu au départemental en juin
2021 et ce qui m'inquiète le plus mais
là c'est une question qui dépasse
largement notre électorat
ce qui m'inquiète le plus c'est cette
espèce de désespérance des français qui
ne croient plus en la politique
il ne le croit plus pourquoi aller voter
et donc si nous n'avons pas les
candidats qui propose des choses qui
seront capables de mettre en oeuvre et
donc convaincre les français on pourrait
avoir une très mauvaise surprise en
matière de participation
donc c'est plutôt sale à la santé de
notre démocratie locale qui d'autant la
démocratie locale seulement on nomme
démocratie tout court qui m'a qui
m'inquiète ou et vous vous y croyez
encore à la politique au niveau national
bah écoutez j'ai tourné une page je la
tourne avec vous ce soir en tant que
parlementaire donc c'est peut-être que
j'en ai fait un peu le tour et que au
bout de 17 ans au sodique voilà il est
peut-être temps de faire autre chose
vous avez des regrets vous avez non je
peux avoir de regret parce que vous
savez voilà j'ai été par le monteur 17
ans j'étais maire 22 ans je suis élu
local depuis 38 ans est ce que vous
imaginez ça depuis 1983 alors des fois
je me regarde dans la glace et je me dis
mais je fais figure de dinosaure et donc
je me dis qu'à un moment donné il faut
peut être regarder à faire autre chose
avec une certaine fierté quand même le
sentiment d'un devoir accompli d'avoir
fait des bouges je pense j'espère que
vous ne trouverez personne devant le
palais pour vous dire le contraire je
pense avoir été un de ceux qui a
vraiment bossé sur ces sujets et ça a
été reconnu comme tel aussi bien à
droite qu'à gauche ailleurs et dans les
gouvernements quels qu'ils étaient parce
que j'en ai quand même vu passer les
gouvernements et j'ai été plus souvent
l'opposition de la majorité ça
finalement été très court non je suis
fier du boulot que j'ai fais tu ici je
suis fier d'avoir été parlementaire bon
maintenant c'est une page de ma vie qui
se tourne et puis voilà farges la
remplissent autrement ça c'est vrai
sujet et on est ravi que vous l'ayez
tournée avec nous cette page merci
infiniment philibert s'il avoue avoir
passé sept demi heure avec nous et de
vous être confiées à nou plein de belles
choses pour la suite et merci à nos
chroniqueurs ça a été voulue sionneau
maurice beaucoup est un plaisir de
travailler avec vous et de et de faire
ce club allait à lpl continue quand même
avec notre grand entretien je vous le
disais nous recevons ce soir alexander
nef directeur de l'opéra national de
paris
il est à la tête d'une institution qui
sort d'une période difficile entre le co
vides et les mouvements sociaux qui ont
précédé la crise sanitaire
alexander nef nous dira comment il
rebondit
comment il fait renaître sa
programmation comment il a redonné du
souffle aux centaines de personnes qui
travaillent avec lui voyons d'abord
comment s'en sortent d'autres lieux de
spectacles vivants cécile siksou est
allé tourner au théâtre de la huchette
et à la philharmonie reportage
je me lève après c'est pour faire mon
petit poulet rôti donc je ne vois pas
qui les derniers ajustements pour la
troupe de cette petite salle parisienne
depuis 63 ans au théâtre de la huchette
on joue deux pièces d'eugène ionesco
c'était des films à une programmation
toute faite qui a permis de reprendre
les représentations dès le 5 juin avec
des jauges et le public a tout de suite
été haut en dépenses sentait qu'il y
avait chez les spectateurs une envie
absolument une très forte de retourner
au théâtre je les ressentis moi aussi en
allant voir moi-même d'autres spectacles
ou franchement il y avait des
applaudissements très très plus fort que
d'habitude
gonzague félipe et l'administrateur du
théâtre
pour lui cette mise en route rapide a
aussi été possible grâce aux aides de
l'état c'est vrai qu'on a on a eu des
aides qui nous ont permis de tenir et
qui nous ont permis aussi de faire la
reprise assez rapidement dans six mois
que ça va être dur en fait
eh ben on sait pas ce qui va se passer
en six mois là c'est l'été tout le monde
ressort on a envie de ressortir donc ils
sont très belle on a très belle salle
mais à la rentrée on sait pas
incertitude aussi dans un tout autre
établissement à la philharmonie de paris
uc de saint simon le secrétaire général
a pu rouvrir les portes dès le 19 mai et
jusqu'au 12 juillet avec des jauges mais
aussi un pass sanitaire que juste ici
nous avons actuellement
contrôle vigipirate le contrôle des
billets se fait là et nous avions
pendant que le pass and it et un
troisième qu'on prouve que nous avions
du coup mis à l'extérieur nous avons
nous avions installé des tentes et le
contrôle se faisait à l'extérieur
pendant un mois et demi dans cette
grande institution où normalement on se
prépare et mois al avance la
programmation des spectacles a cette
fois été compliqué c'était un peu le
bazar beaucoup de choses que nous avions
prévu nous pouvions plus les faire parce
que les artistes venaient de trop loin
donc il était soumis à des quarantaines
autre raison voilà il n'avait pas pu
travailler leurs projets certains
projets quand et du spectacle où ça se
travaille très longtemps à l'avancé
donc là il n'avait pas pu travailler
donc à partir du 19 mai nous avons
repris un rythme quasi habituel avec
beaucoup de concerts en revanche peu de
choses était ce qui était prévu des
changements parfois incompris par le
public qui n'a pas rempli les salles un
manque à gagner pour l'institution dont
la billetterie représente près de 15
millions de recettes sur un budget de 80
2 millions d'euros nous avons du mal à
nous projeter sur le retour du public ou
pas nous sommes confiants qu'à terme y
reviendra ça je pense que il ya aucun
doute là dessus
en revanche quand est-ce qu'il reviendra
ça c'est la grande inconnue de saint
simon espère bien reprendre une saison
normale dès le 28 août après la pause
estivale
mais la menace du variant delta pourrait
bien une nouvelle fois chambouler le
programme et allons encore plus loin
avec vous alexander nef merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans
l'entretien d' allant plus loin je
rappelle que vous êtes c'est directeur
général de l'opéra de paris
vous sortez vos aussi d'une période plus
que compliquée peut-être même un peu
sombre un peu noir est ce que vous
diriez que vous êtes en train tout
doucement de reconnaître que vos équipes
sont en train de revivre tout doucement
dont la saison s'est terminée hier en
meilleur soir et nous avons pu faire
quand même des mois de spectacles à
partir de la mi mai ce qui nous a
effectivement donné de l'énergie de
pouvoir sauver ce petit bout de saison
en la saison d'habitude commence en
septembre stirling juillet là on a
commencé mi mai pour terminer mi juillet
c'était vraiment un institut année très
très dur nous pourrons garder la forme
des équipes artistiques et hameaux ont
les faire travailler pour des projets de
captation et caetera et retrouver le
public c'est notre mission et on était
tous très très heureux de pouvoir y
arriver mais ça donne vraiment l'énergie
là pendant cette petite pause estivale
pour en reprendre après l'été vous avez
senti que le souffle était revenu à la
fois du côté des artistes du côté des
équipes techniques et du côté du public
il ne boude pas le public il revient le
public est revenu à partir de la mi mai
avec des joueurs comme qu'on vous le
savez qui était progressive on a
commencé avec 35% d'une salle après un
65 après la jauge pleine à partir de la
fin juin
je pense il ya une petite hésitation de
confondre le pass sanitaire qu'est ce
que ça veut dire comment ça s'applique à
ce que vous vous l'avez déjà le passé ni
temps on l'a appliqué quasiment à partir
de mi juin pour nous parce qu'on a des
très grandes salles à ce qu'il ya de
1700 places garni à 2000 places du coup
pour pouvoir remplir il nous fallait le
pass sanitaires et je pense tout le
monde s'est habitué je pense aussi avec
le taux de vaccination qui augmente les
gens viennent plus facilement théâtre
quand ils ont leur passé ni terme avec
une vaccination qui est unique et
complète que quand il faut faire un test
chaque fois quand on veut venir c'est un
point vraiment important se passe
sanitaire en ce moment parce qu'on
entend beaucoup de responsables de l'oco
d'instituts de restaurants qui vont
devoir le mettre en place
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez leur dire
peut-être pour les rassurer ce soir est
ce que oui ça se met en place facilement
est ce qu'on arrive vite à trouver des
gens pour s'en occuper est ce que ça ne
coûte pas si cher que ça de trouver du
personnel pour le faire est ce que les
gens acceptent facilement comment ça se
passe puisque vous avez un petit peu de
recul je pense est difficile à dire en
général pour nous la question d'une
certaine façon c'est pas vraiment posé
parce que c'était la condition pour
pouvoir remplir la salle
c'est plus de travail pour les agents
d'accueil comme comme vous l'avez vu
dans la petite vidéo de la philharmonie
il n'ya pas seulement vigipirate et
contrôler le biais ça s'ajoute
maintenant le contrôle du passé ni terre
et aussi le contrôle d'une pièce
d'identité
parce qu'il faut bien trouver que c'est
pas n'importe quel passant les thermes
est le vôtre que ça correspond pour une
fois une très grande salle comme
bastille avec 2700 places
très souvent on a commencé avec 10 à 15
minutes de retard parce qu'on n'a pas
réussi à faire entrer les hommes le
public avec un petit peu de recul aussi
ce que vous diriez que vous avez eu
assez de visibilité tout au long de
cette crise pour envisager
progressivement des réouvertures est-ce
que tout a été clair est-ce que les
consignes venant de là où on était clair
est-ce que vous dirais que globalement
vous avez été aidés ou ça a été
compliqué on a définitivement été aidé
ça c'est sûr on a toujours gardé un
contact très étroit avec comme avec nos
collègues ont misé sur la culture et
puis d'autres ministères pourrons-nous
pouvoir nous projeter dans l'avenir
après pour nous l'avenir c'est une
saison qui se construit
[Musique]
89 ans ça veut dire très difficile de
réagir âme aux variantes du virus qui
émergent dans une semaine
dix jours de semaine du coup notre
programmation très souvent on essaie
dans ces situations on a dû commencer
les répétitions pour un spectacle sans
savoir si on peut le donner avait pu les
coupes public ou pas oh mais très
souvent ces les captations qui nous ont
sauvés et effectivement les spectacles
de mais il ya du neuf est certain on a
commencé les répétitions pour une
création mondiale au palais garnier qui
a eu sa première le 21 mai quand nous
avons commencé les répétitions en avril
on ne savait pas si cette production est
laisserait un malaise réalisé avec du
public la captation était prévu mais
après capter devant une salle vide
là il faut vraiment que les artistes
hommes s'engagent encore plus c'est le
public qui donne une réplique d'une
certaine façon qui donne de l'énergie
si on parle chiffres maintenant est-ce
que vous avez une idée déjà du coût
économique de cette crise pour l'opéra
de paris
gémeauxvous dire oui mais
malheureusement on sait déjà avec le
variant delta que ça pas tout à fait
terminée mal on a effectivement le faire
fait nos comptes pour l'année 2020 où le
père a perdu presque 90 millions d'euros
à
recette on a réussi à économiser environ
on a reçu des aides de l'état à hauteur
de 41 millions d'euros
du coup on s'en est sorti c'était pas
facile mais on a pu s'en sortir il ya
des aides d'état qui sont annoncés pour
l'année 2000 21 déjà et une de notre
côté on travaille aussi à maîtriser
surtout de dépenses et coûts déry que
l'état français a été généreux et a même
été plus généreux que d'autres pays
puisque j'imagine que vous êtes en lien
avec vos homologues un peu partout dans
le monde
est-ce que vous avez quand même que la
france a sauvé la culture et en
l'occurrence l'opéra de paris ou pas
écoutez je pense encore une fois on a
été très très bien soutenu pas seulement
avec l'argent parce que de soutenir la
culture dans une situation où on ne peut
pas donner ce spectacle c'est quand même
très très compliqué de tous les côtés
parce qu'il faut garder une visibilité
un lien avec le public et c'est très
bien tout ce qu'on a fait
le soufre plateforme
en termes de numérique digital et à la
fin le vrai spectacle se passe en salle
une salle pleine sa économiquement mais
aussi artistiquement c'est ça qui nous
anime et je pense que c'est vrai pour
toutes les institutions du spectacle
vivant et du coup cette scène
l'autonomie fermeture très longue
ça a été la chose la plus dure c'est ça
abîme et les artistes ou pas vous diriez
qui sortent abîmé cette crise quand même
je pense que pas seulement les artistes
mais tout le monde en sort fatigué je le
sais pas si on sans abîmer
mais on est fatigué parce que deux fûts
faire une saison puisqu'on a l'habitude
de faire même si les titres change avec
une saison c'est plus ou moins la même
chose chaque année selon s'élance à
chaque septembre pour terminer en
juillet on en a l'habitude de faire le
contraire de ne pas faire une saison et
se retrouve jamais savoir quand on
pourra reprendre
ça prend beaucoup beaucoup plus
d'énergie en plus de garder la forme des
collectifs artistiques des coeurs de
leurs six assauts du palais 1 200
pouvoir leur donner des spectacles c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué du coup on a
essayé que les artistes n'arrête pas
on a eu le droit de répéter de préparer
des spectacles ce qui était très très
bien c'était essentiel même pour le
maintien de notre forme artistique
après si on retrouve pas son public ça
commence à tourner en plus dans le vide
est ce qu a contrario vous dirai puisque
c'est une crise majeure mondiale
planétaire incroyable est-ce qu'elle
pourra elle pourrait déboucher aussi sur
une forme d'énergie créatrice est ce que
quelque part dans cinq ans peut-être dix
ans je sais pas quel montant il faut
qu'elle recule et fo pour digérer
quelque chose comme ce qu'on vit
actuellement mais d'un point de vue de
la création est ce que ça pourra
déboucher sur des heures incroyable
aussi c'est possible je pense là à me
répond toujours un moment de la vie dans
notre société ça c'est sûr ce qui est
sûr aussi que on s'est posé beaucoup de
questions pendant cette période de
fermeture nous les institutions les
artistes aussi pourquoi nous sommes là
c'est quoi notre mission nous commentons
vu la remplir ma la sortie du sein de
cette crise ça c'est des questions très
essentiel que des fois on se ne les pose
pas assez quand la grande boutique
on m'a même appelée l'opéra tourner en
pleine force on n'a pas nécessairement
le temps pour cette réflexion il y aura
un avant et un après pour vous aussi
pour alexander nef
bah c'est sûr déjà parce que je suis
arrivé à l'opéra en tant que nouveau le
nouveau directeur en pleine crise
je suis arrivé en septembre dernier et
tout le monde pensait dix ans noël c'est
terminé voilà on y est toujours
du coup de pouvoir tenir avec la maison
de travailler avec les gens de maison
pour tenir c'est un moment très très
important aussi que je tombe
parfaitement inédit
dans ma carrière de directeur personnes
m'avaient prévenu car moi un jour il
fallait gérer une pandémie
on a l'habitude de beaucoup géré au
théâtre mais ils font des mises ça c'est
vraiment mais ils ont voté alors
continuons nous projeter sur la praye en
espérant vous l'avez dit que le variant
delta nous laisse un tout petit peu
tranquille qu'est ce qui attend votre
public pour septembre qu'elle est
qu'elle est la programmation dans les
mois qui viennent voilà on est en paix
maintenant pause estivale où je vous ai
dit et on reprend tout de suite le 1er
septembre avec un nouveau spectacle de
marina abramovic sur maria callas ce qui
est ni à nous faire un lien ballet c'est
quelque chose entre les eux une
performance si vous voulez apprendre en
vue d'une très très grande artiste qui
avoue nous propose cette réflexion sur
la vie des classes
après il ya plein de reprise a gagné
combat voici la première nouvelle
production c'est un opéra
oublié aujourd'hui un peu qui s'appelle
we deep basé sur le temps de sophocle
mais justement traite d'un roi dont la
ville est frappée par la peste et on se
demande pourquoi quand je vous dis quand
on a programmé sept heures enfin nous on
savait rien de cette pandémie
mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ça nous
frappe que on va ouvrir en septembre
avec cette offre là quand on a tous vécu
ensemble une une pandémie
vous diriez que ce sont des oeuvres
accessibles auquel un public pas
forcément habitués à aller à l'opéra
pour être réceptif je crois qu'elle en
général et a effectivement des heures et
qui sont plus difficiles que d'autres
après mais pour les non initiés il faut
surtout pas avoir peur parce qu'à la
base les histoires que l'on raconte
opéra sont très simple c'est de l'amour
là mort en la n1 amitié c'est autour des
grands thèmes de la condition humaine
que se construit notre notre projet si
vous voulez je dis toujours aux publics
qui n'ont pas l'habitude de venir nous
voir ne préparais rien ne gâchez pas
votre expérience
à moins que vous n'ayez eu c'est à dire
l'elysée rien avant de ne pas les airs
et on a pour l'opéra et elle est sur
titres ça veut dire vous à vous allez
quand même si on chante en italien en
allemand en anglais en russe
vous allez comprendre le texte parce que
les projeter sur le proscenium n'y a pas
de problème pour suivre le spectacle moi
je pensais le premier contact avec en
oeuvre d'art doit se faire par l'émotion
après si ça vous intéresse plus vous
allez entrer dans votre recherche
intellectuelle c'est très bien ainsi
mais surtout l'opéra l'émotion que
transporte la musique
c'est votre porte d'entrée et je crois
que vous faites vous même des choses
pour que l'opéra ne soit plus réservé à
une élite vous avez nommés par exemple
un directeur musical gustavo dudamel qui
lui justement en charge de rendre
l'opéra plus accessible encore un plus
large public pas c'est quelqu'un qui en
fait incarnent cette ouverture c'est
déjà un très grand chef prochaine du
coup on est on est très très heureux
qu'il va nous rejoindre comme nouveau
directeur musical à partir de septembre
et c'est aussi quelqu'un qui croie
profonde de membres q la musique a une
mission dans la société que ces oeuvres
racontent quelque chose sur nous qui
nous permettent de comprendre mieux qui
nous sommes
mais qui vit c'est d'une manière très
naturelle et c'est en effet c'est notre
projet c'est à dire l'art et la vie
c'est pas vraiment séparés
là le miroir de la vie et s'exposant à
l'art
on peut mieux se découvrir et je crois
que gustavo dudamel est lui même a été
lui-même formé à la musique grâce à un
programme social alors l'opéra c'est pas
que du classique
il ya aussi le hip hop la culture
urbaine la diversité ça a été possible
notamment avec les indes galantes
chef-d'oeuvre baroque de jean philippe
rameau réinventé par le metteur en scène
clément cogitore la chorégraphe bintou
dembélé
ce fut une première pour l'opéra de
paris ce n'était pas sous votre
mandature mais je crois que vous êtes
aussi très fier de ce spectacle un
documentaire a été réalisé sur cette
aventure on va découvrir quelques images
ensemble pour les téléspectateurs qui ne
connaissent pas et on en parle juste
après quoi leur nez au brésil
ouache sénégalais d'origine espagnole
j'ai grandi à grenoble mes parents sont
de l'oise dont c'est compliqué parce que
j'ai des racines mais je suis coupé
d'elle
mine de rien le fait d'être né en côte
d'ivoire ça donne une force
[Musique]
voilà et le documentaire est signé
philippe béziat c'est typiquement le
genre d'oeuvre qui peut amener un autre
public à l'opéra mais c'est tout à fait
possible que je pense parce que la
diversité ça se joue sur beaucoup de
niveau s'est pas seulement le public
c'est aussi les artistes et les 1,40
c'était un moment très important pour la
maison parce que pour la première fois
on a eu un groupe de danseurs sur scène
qui ont incarné vraiment un
si je veux dire un grand classique de
l'opéra français avec les internautes à
rameau du coup c'est le monde
contemporain qui rencontre le patrimoine
c'est exactement ça qu'on essaie de
faire avec chaque spectacle c'est
compliqué quand même de faire bouger les
lignes dans l'opéra dans ce team de
culture dit élitiste parce que ça le
reste encore un peu malgré tout il ya
des codes il ya encore des des
conservatismes des gens qui disent ah
non non pas de hip hop à l'opéra où
c'est compliqué pour vous de de
démocratiser l'opéra ou pas c'est un
défi après que je crois profondément que
les heures sont ouverts à tout le monde
on en a parlé il ya beaucoup de mystère
autour de ce qu'il faut comprendre de
commenter faut se préparer
je crois vraiment de franchir le cette
barrière d'entrée
qui très souvent on n'est pas financière
qui est culturel qui questions de tabac
de se sentir appartenir à cette maison
est sûre ça qu'on veut travailler
effectivement dans une dynamique on crée
des spectacles avec les artistes du
xxème siècle pour un public du 21e
siècle même si ou lé un recours
aujourd'hui à 400 ans de répertoire dans
la même demi donc dans la domaine de
l'opéra amis c'est aujourd'hui pour des
gens d'aujourd'hui et vu ça ça mais très
très important vraiment de dire c'est
pas on n'est pas un musée on n'est pas
une école non qu on est un lieu de
spectacle vivant
on invite les gens à découvrir à se
promener mais son ombre selon leurs
propres règles ses on n'a pas envie de
trop encadré cette expérience mais vous
avez parlé du frein financier
c'est vrai que je pense que beaucoup de
gens qui ne regardent ce soir et qui se
disent une place alors à l'opéra c'est
hors de prix
quels sont les prix qui écope combien
pour des deux théâtres gold bastille et
garnier ça commence autour des 15 euros
on est très mal placé ou pas moi pour
les jeux c'est mieux mais il ya des très
belles offres pour les jeunes aussi pour
les familles après ça commence à 15
euros ça peut aller jusqu'à 200 tu me
pour une très bonne place une très belle
place mais on veut surtout que le nombre
de places sous sont euros soit bien
présent parce que ça fait partie de
notre mission de service public après le
modèle économique comme tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui
et oui il faut qu'on ramène par notre
billetterie quand même presque 75
millions d'euros par an alors si l'opéra
si on veut n'est pas à l'opéra l'opéra
peut venir à vous je crois qu'on descend
dernier vous en avez un tout petit peu
parlé vous avez créé une plateforme pour
rendre l'opéra accessible à tous depuis
chez soi à prix réduits en direct ou en
replay est ce que ça a bien marché et
est ce que la formule va continuer ça va
absolument continuer c'est quelque chose
qu'on a lancé un peu al improvise un
baume à décembre dernier à cause du
confinement qui a été prolongée on avait
plutôt en tête de lancer un mot
printemps ou ou même à l'automne après
on s'est dit il faut vraiment à me crier
cette présence
et elle illustre le lien avec le public
qui ne pas venir en salle et on l'a
lancée avec un direct du palais de la
bahia dr le 13 décembre qui était un
succès formidable nomination des toiles
sur scène inclus en direct d'une salle
vide mais une une grande force après on
a fait plein d'autres captation au cours
de la saison on a mis en ligne est
d'aider nos choses de nos archives des
concerts de l'ancien ce sont des
concerts de musique de chambre des
projets de l'académie notre notre
académie qui forment des jeunes artistes
et artisans il ya vraiment quelque chose
pour tout le monde sur cette plateforme
qui s'appelle l'opéra chez soi et qui a
des contenus gratuits aussi plein de
contenus gratuits et quelques contenus
dans un pays aussi vous savez si ça à
toucher un nouveau public ou pas vous
avez une idée la sociologie de ce public
y regarder l'opéra chez soi on commence
à en avoir une petite idée c'est
effectivement des gens qui n'ont pas pu
venir en salle et habitués dont des
habitués d'accord après il ya eu suppl 1
plein de gens surtout des familles qui
se sont faits une soirée devant la télé
en regard d'un orient d'un opéra ballet
on est vraiment très content de ce
succès c'est ce qui nous permet de
d'élargir notre public parce que vous
savez un l'opéra de paris avant la crise
on a quand même réussi à vendre presque
800 500 en 2000 places dont du théâtre
on donnera environ 400 spectacles dans
les deux grandes salles mais on est
presque au plafond là
on peut pas donner plus spectacle et on
verra qui en plus du public du coup pour
nous cette idée de sortir de nos salles
d'une manière virtuelle l'âme digital
pour atteindre encore plus de gens ce qu
on fait 2 avec la plateforme dans les
cinémas il ya plein d'initiatives a
effectivement ou l'opéra va venir chez
vous donc voilà quelque chose de positif
qui ressort de cette crise merci
infiniment alexander nef d'avoir été
notre invité ce soir
merci beaucoup d'avoir réservé notre
dernier